[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
[Music]
hello everybody happy friday here we are
again don't sound so enthusiastic thomas
yeah i'm enthusiastic yeah
i'm pissed off
can't find my motorcycle key
yeah i can't find the key to the
lightning
yeah he has two he has more than one
motorcycle but yeah he was because he
was going up to the man clinic this
morning and he was gonna take the bike
and he's like where's the motorcycle i'm
like i don't know i haven't seen it
couldn't find it i suspect i think
pookie took it that pookie took it
somewhere because it has like a little
rubber soft rubber thing on it and that
seems like the thing that she'd be like
ooh
toy for me
upside down i can't find it i know it's
in here or the motorcycle wouldn't be
here
i usually leave them in the ignitions
but sometimes i'll put them on the
nightstand
yeah you either you always put it in the
nightstand or like the long table in
front of the tv yeah which are the two
places that pookie really really likes
to [ __ ] around i've checked all my gear
and the pockets everything i just can't
find it
yeah i got two buells
i got it i got a lightning and i got a
[ __ ] thunderbolt yeah i had to take
the thunderbolt
actually it's a firebolt
custom firebolt
yeah and you have and you have another
one too that's like an old like that was
your dad yeah i got a yeah i got a 1972
honda ct 70 that that is now 140.
little monkey bike yeah it only weighs
40 43 pounds i think goes about 70.
maxed out about 70. yeah but you know
the range is like four miles it only
carries like uh half a gallon yeah it's
it's really little
it's cool looking though like you it was
your dad's and you brought it back yeah
repainted and repainted it and rebuilt
it and everything yeah it's cool looking
all new wheels and suspension and brakes
and it's a cafe racer now a little
little mini cafe racer and then i got an
rd 350 two-stroke just that i it needs a
new crank and a new top end on it i
built it rebuilt a new frame
different wheels and inverted front end
and dual [ __ ]
suspension or dual uh front brakes
[ __ ] extended swing arm and [ __ ] it
was going to be a badass [ __ ] rd it
was going to be an rd 300 350 or maybe
probably maybe put maybe 350 banshee top
end or you know out of a [ __ ]
four-wheeler
race by four-wheeler
yeah maybe a 400.
dj maniac says they now have a mobile
clinic called the man-van oh yeah it
comes and brings you your drugs
we need a man van around here somebody
needs to bring the man
it needs it will have truck nuts on it
obviously hell yeah um you know have
some [ __ ] frank frazetta looking [ __ ]
on the sides of it
oh my god that'd be hilarious if they
did that they just had like all this
coney and like barbarian [ __ ] on the
outside of the van
that truck that's tackling from the back
big big old like jiggly [ __ ] on the top
yeah why not just go all out um it's
funny because the clinic that i go to
you know like in the dudes that own it
the dudes that own it are [ __ ]
players man [ __ ] all the all the
technicians that work there are all
[ __ ] fitness chicks and you walk in
you know
how's it going you're feeling good
you're looking good take your shirt off
yeah you're looking good yeah a couple
more months you're looking good yeah you
know it's just like
where you can take your shirt off
well well also they're trying to like
upsell more services yeah yeah yeah yeah
flattering the ego yeah yeah that's
always good for us yeah they kind of
look like that too though you should
know that yeah they look like that too
though
jenny's shirt is awesome thank you yes i
know it is i just got this like pretty
recently i think i've worn on the show
before but look there's there's other
like there's several other catzilla
designs
but i got this one from i think busted
tease
bustedts.com or something like that but
yeah see this was like that was like my
favorite one yeah because i like i just
i just really like like the paws on that
where he's going
to just like [ __ ] crack me up
oh my god all right so
yeah so we think that maybe uh mr roboto
asked if you were a fan of the side car
no no
okay well that was that was easy no
[Laughter]
care to justify that opinion or just no
more
supposed to have three wheels
[Laughter]
all right but yeah we do uh we do
suspect that pookie has stolen your
motorcycle i think so yeah i can't
really imagine where else it could be
because
i mean you have
the last time you rode your bike
was when like a couple weeks ago right
and
no not even that yeah well yeah okay so
yeah five days four days maybe yeah so
it's like when you came back you must
have just like put it down because it
wasn't in your motorcycle pants it
wasn't in the dryer
it wasn't you know because i already
looked in there
because i did laundry today it wasn't in
the floor on the [ __ ] closet it just
wasn't in the garage it's just not
anywhere
i mean it is somewhere we just don't
know where she went off with it it's
only i kind of think that maybe because
but the thing about pookie is that
you know
she didn't take it far probably because
unlike beijing beijing has a thing where
it's like she comes in and likes little
stuffed toys and she will carry them
around the house in her mouth yeah and
like take him kind of far like she'll
take him out of my office and like go
way out into the dining room with him
and stuff um pookie doesn't really do
that pookie will carry stuff for like
you know two feet and then she'll be
like boring and then she'll just like
drop it or you know just kind of pushing
around with her paw or whatever so
i feel like
she couldn't have taken it that far did
you look underneath the table like where
the tv is yeah i moved all that stuff i
tore the bed apart looked underneath the
bed pushed the bed out was it in the
closet someplace i took parts of the
closet probably looked where she sleeps
underneath your clothes underneath the
rack you're talking about it wasn't
there i thought maybe she'd take it
there and chew on it
yeah because she likes to play in the
closet i couldn't find it
because i find her sleeping in there
sometimes by the little rack with the
towels on it like
yeah i don't know where it is she's got
like her little spot i'll eventually run
into it i guess
yeah it'll turn up it's just there's a
million if if pookie took it it could be
like a million places it could be in
that closet for christ's sake it could
be lots of places but like i said if she
carried it somewhere it's probably not
far from where it was originally i
looked in her apartment complex it
wasn't in there it wasn't her apartment
complex yeah she doesn't carry stuff up
in the apartment complex yeah she
usually just goes up there unencumbered
because she just goes up there to nap
you know what i mean i can't find it
well i don't know like i said it'll
it'll turn up
if pookie was a dog it would get buried
so it will turn up yeah it's got to be
in the house someplace i just can't i
just don't know where um yeah the
motorcycle key is a [ __ ] nightmare
[ __ ] man i just had to get another key
remember how the key broke for my
[ __ ] ancient 2004
yeah what is it ford taurus 100 bucks it
was like a hundred dollars because even
back in 2004 like the you know the tops
of the keys have like you know chips in
them so it's like it's not like the old
days where you could just go to walmart
and pay like four bucks and like they
could just cut a new one like in 10
minutes
yeah that's not how it works anymore now
you have to get like get it [ __ ]
programmed and all those other kind of
crap on a motorcycle you need the vin
number and everything
yeah
what did i how did i get um because i
think i did actually go to
where did i go to get the replacement
keys because you you called a guy and he
came
that's right i had to call yeah the
mobile it's not the man band it was the
key van
and uh yeah the mobile guy came to the
house
and
it was yet enough being like 200 it was
three keys though no he gave me four
keys two ignition keys and two uh door
and trunk keys
so
that's not too bad so they turned out to
be what like 50 to 75 bucks each yeah
but he came back and he had like a you
know thing in the back of his van and he
had to like program the keys and
everything i was like
i thought because my car was so old
i thought it would be like
really easy and cheap to get a to get a
key cut because my old one broke but
nope
nope
because you know when that when the
other key broke it's like it wasn't
working anymore like it wouldn't work in
the ignition the car wouldn't start so i
had to get a new one whether i wanted to
or not
yeah
so uh
13 o'clock oh zach was saying too that
he really liked when we do mental health
topics and we should probably do a show
on autism which we i promise we will one
of these days because i want to do one
about that too um he was asking would
you guys ever own a dog i'm not a big
dog person
um
but i guess it would depend
i don't know i feel like
i feel like if you have a dog it's
better if they have like a big area to
like run around
which i guess they kind of do here but
i don't know i kind of feel like that's
more of unless it's like a little bit of
yappy type dog
i don't know i've never been a real big
dog
person
they're too
needy
i guess i like dogs i just i just don't
think i'd want to have one this would be
like having a kid
having pookie's kind of like having a
kid but
she's i mean she's pretty happy like
you know
left to her own devices
most of the time yeah evidently uh
evidently uh
munchausen did beat incels i guess
that's what they're asking
the what now
munch housing syndrome beat out in cells
it did yeah but i'm gonna put in so i
put like
here's the thing though
i'm pretty sure that munchausen syndrome
i think it was in a poll like a long
time ago
and i think it tied
with the topic that won so we did the
other topic but we talked about
munchausen a little bit on the side
track show but i feel like because it
was a sidetrack show we didn't talk
about it the whole time and we got you
know sidetracked so
in a way i kind of forgot that that
happened so i put it in the poll again
and then it won and then i was like well
and then i was like oh wait [ __ ] we
already i think we already kind of did
this but then i thought well a lot of
people don't listen to the side track
shows one and two
i think that we didn't devote the whole
show to that you know what i'm saying
which you're probably not gonna do this
time either obviously no no roboto you
can't hotwire a motorcycle
the ecm won't allow it
it's got a computerized brain in there
and the ignition all has to the chip has
to be near the ignition and everything
or it won't start the fuel injector
won't won't run the computer won't run
they know what they're doing
they've had that technology going from
going back forever
yeah i'm just like i'm super buying with
all that stuff like i said my car is
super old yeah it's a
and but it's still going yeah a
carburetor an older carbureted
motorcycle you probably you could but no
not a fuel-injected one
danny rolling ghost face talking about
dogs it's a pain in the ass to have to
go walk them at all hours yeah that's
another thing i mean i go for a walk
anyway but it's like i don't want to
like have to walk every time they're
like hey can i go outside it's like you
know go use a litter box like a kitty
get your [ __ ] together
but you know what i mean i don't know i
was i was thinking about it the other
day because uh my sister
her uh her doggy just passed away
uh and she's had that dog for like [ __ ]
man as long as i can remember and it's
like i was seeing her instagram post and
i was like oh it was just making me so
sad because that dog is like so cute but
you know i don't know i've just never
really been a big dog person
we never really had dogs growing up we
had one when i was a kid
and it was like the stupidest dog ever
and uh it was a husky but it was a puppy
yeah he was super cute and everything
but
i don't know
i was always when i was little i was
like afraid of dogs because i don't want
him like jumping on me and drooling on
me and stuff and i don't like it yeah
david just said you're getting big
you're starting to get trolls
actually those aren't trolls those are
bots it's not it's not a person it's a
computer doing that
look at how fast they can post
no human can post that fast
yeah i mean you know
but in a way like it's kind of it's
annoying but i'm kind of like well maybe
that means that our channel is like
actually big enough to get some like
[ __ ] notice so you know it's not a
human date it's not a human doing it
though no i know it's an it's an
aggressive computer program that does it
that's aggressive computer programs
like [ __ ] yeah ah sky nuts coming
it's like
it's like cyber attacking
like to what end though like what do
they hope to accomplish um could be
anything uh if you have enough hate
speech in the comment section on your
channel it can get deleted
that's that i think that's probably what
it is
either that or it's another platform
trying to cyber attack this platform in
other words you know that might be like
a smaller one that's trying to yeah that
might be bit shoot doing that or that
might be a foreign uh a foreign platform
trying to get people to come to theirs
to get off of uh
um youtube
yeah well good luck with this corporate
corporations doing that
tv drugger says i have two huskies hell
of a lot of work yeah we didn't have
that dog for very long like we moved and
we had to like give him to somebody else
and he was just little i mean he was
just a puppy and i was just a little kid
and i was just kind of like i don't want
dogs they're just like they jump on me
and they're licking me and they're
stinky
so you know i was kind of like that but
like i said i like cats because
they a lot of times they can kind of
take care of themselves but they're
still like friendly and affectionate and
sweet and everything like that and do
cute [ __ ] but they are not like
constantly up in your face although
pookie is more in your face than
most cats i feel like
because she's not because like i said
beijing is like super aloof she's just
like [ __ ] off don't bother me but pookie
is just like hey what you doing what you
doing what you doing what you doing like
he'll sit on the floor and be playing
like video games and she just like walks
around and around him like that like
trying to like walk on the what are you
doing daddy what are you doing what are
you doing she's like walking on the
keyboard and [ __ ] you know what i mean
uh yeah tv says the fur is the worst
they shed a lot year round
yeah you know what are you gonna do we
have like little balls of
uh little balls of cat hair all over the
[ __ ] place
well maniac it's not that
we didn't really say that
arnold didn't want to kill other people
in movies
he didn't want to be the villain
he never wanted to be the best yeah i
don't think he had a problem with
killing people per se i think it was
just he didn't want to be a bad you want
to be a bad guy so if he could kill bad
guys that was fine but he didn't want to
like you know be a villain
because and like i said i can understand
if you're an actor here comes taylor you
don't want to get typecast yeah here
comes teela what's up i get it
dogs and cats living together
yeah happy friday everybody
i know
[Laughter]
um yeah zach's also says do you like tea
or coffee much i love putting ice in
mine i'm yeah i like i'm a big uh coffee
freak i like all different kinds of
coffee tea like i can take or leave
but every now and then you made a very
nice chai the other night yeah which is
really weird because
i had been thinking because we were just
like sitting around watching movies or
mst or something like that and i thought
to myself i'm like man you know it'd be
good like some kind of like hot tea or
hot chocolate or something like that
even though it's [ __ ] summer time but
we have the eight but we have the ac on
so i'm pretending that it's winter
and then like five minutes later he was
like i'm gonna make some chai and i was
just like
[ __ ] give me some of that although you
drank like two things of it and it's
like too sweet for me i couldn't even
like drink a whole thing but it was like
really good
yeah i have uh
let's see
mine is cherry vodka and sprite is what
mine is mr roberto is asking how much is
the cookbook and where do you go to
order it is 35 and you can go to
lulu.com
and search
13 o'clock or search like time to cook
with 13 o'clock and you should be able
to find it i think
um in all of our new videos there should
be a link to it
if there's not then i'll add a link to
it after we finish the live stream
so you know but i'm pretty sure that
there's a link to it because i have that
thing like youtube you can have
all of the like regular like all the
credits and [ __ ] you can have that
already in there
uh esther said iced coffee you love it
yeah i also love iced coffee i like hot
coffee iced coffee pretty much any kind
of coffee i'll [ __ ] drink it
you know what i mean um yeah tilas is
still technically at work no libations
for me yet well you know that's
something to look forward to
um
i had a i had a drink last night too
only just only one though
because we were watching who was it that
sent me the link and told me about that
um documentary that just came on netflix
about [ __ ] dennis nielsen the dennis
nilsson tapes
yeah i watched that last night and that
was some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
we might talk about that on sunday holy
crap i had no i don't think i'd ever
heard dennis nelson like talking to any
like great degree like even though i
read some like quotes of his and stuff
and
the one thing that struck me while i was
watching that documentary i was like
look it's bad enough that you're a
serial killer and like a necrophile and
stuff like that but do you have to be
like a pretentious douchebag on top of
it holy crap it's just kind of like you
know what i mean it's like just the way
he talks just came across which was like
oh my god he's like so into himself
it's just i don't know for some reason
that really made me mad
it's like i don't know why just like his
whole like um pers like his whole like
[ __ ] tone of voice like i'm obviously
so much better than all of these people
blah blah blah he was kind of like that
type of dude and i was just like oh boy
he's asking but he's seen um don't
breathe too yet
see i've been wanting to see that
i haven't read any reviews of it because
like i said if i want to see it at some
point in the future i don't really like
to be detained
from what i've seen because i'm you know
i subscribe to like all the horror [ __ ]
like on youtube right
so a lot of times i'll kind of see
i kind of hate this i kind of hate how a
lot of movie book review channels
they'll have like a thumbnail instead
and i do this too on my book review
thing but usually i'm just kind of
smiling it doesn't really mean anything
about how i feel about the book but
they'll have like a facial expression
that will suggest like how they felt
about the movie so like sometimes you'll
have like
you know a screenshot of the person to
be like hey this new movie that came out
and they're just like
and they're making a face like that and
i'm just kind of like oh maybe it's not
good you know what i mean so if you see
enough of them like that you're kind of
like i get the impression that maybe the
movie isn't good
um
i don't know i've been i haven't seen a
lot of i've been seeing kind of like
mixed [ __ ] on this
but
i don't know we'll see how it goes i
really liked the first one
but
i don't know i don't know who will see
it but i want to see candyman before we
see that though
and i think candyman comes out next week
because i'm super jazzed about that and
the new trailer for it is like really
good it looks really good
so i'm hoping that it doesn't let me
down
because it looks awesome and like i said
it's not a remake it's a it's a sequel
you know like it's that baby that was in
the fire that grew up you know what i'm
saying and so they have like a lot of
the same actors and stuff so i don't
know we'll see how it goes
um all right so
yeah no need for me too says they made
him sympathetic though despite his nasty
way of getting justice from this see
that's what i was kind of hearing i was
hearing they're making him a sympathetic
character which i don't know how i feel
about that because
even though you kind of felt sorry for
him in the first movie because like oh
these jackals like broke into his house
and he's like getting back at them but
then you found out that he was also
a [ __ ] so
you know i'm trying not to spoil too
much like in case you haven't seen the
first one but
you know and so i don't know how i feel
about them making him him a sympathetic
character
is todd gonna be a candy man
i don't know like in the trailer it
sounded like his voice
and i had heard that he was coming back
for it
um i don't know if he's actually gonna
be in it or if she's gonna be his voice
or i don't know what they're doing with
it
um but
like i said the trailer looked pretty
badass it looks pretty cool looking at
least
and
i don't know i just i'm i'm really kind
of like excited about it i really want
to see it i really want to see it when
are they ever when is [ __ ] antlers
ever coming out for christ's sake
i want it i've been wanting to see that
for like a year and a half t says todd
makes an appearance but does she doesn't
think she doesn't think he's the main
actor in it that's what i thought i
thought he was just kind of like gonna
be
like a sideline kind of which is
understandable because because it's been
like a long you know it's been a long
time since the old one he's like an
older dude now but
although we just saw
well we saw the hatchet movies and he
was in those but that was
like a long time ago
it isn't i was just like oh we just saw
that movie but then i was like oh that
movie came out like 2006. so you know
uh thank you dom the bomb another great
retrospective this week in witchfinder
general yeah i think a whole program on
matthew hopkins would be interesting
yeah that actually might be something to
do
because we did one on the salem witch
trials but i don't think we really did
one on like european witch trials which
is a whole different ball of wax
um and like i said matthew hopkins being
like the most famous witch finder but
there was a bunch of other ones too so
it's just kind of like interesting the
whole cultural framework that led to all
these people going hey i'm just going to
wander around the country and
torture and kill women won't that be fun
you know what i mean
release is 8 27 for candy man yeah yeah
i just saw the other the new trailer for
it like a few days ago and it said it
was about the 27th so yeah like a week
from today so next friday it's out
zach says because i'm a big time
photography nerd what's the best looking
movie you guys have seen
ooh
best looking as a from a photography
standpoint it was from like just cool as
[ __ ] looking
the first yeah the original the original
suspiria the original susperia i love
all of that like super saturated
color i thought blood machines was
[ __ ] cool looking
i did as well actually that was very
well i like that whole like
retro wave aesthetic and i like that a
lot of people are really still on shadow
in it
it should be
it's in the series section though not in
the movie section so i'm not sure if
it's still there yeah go in there look
at blood machines
it's kind of like
four music videos back to back but
they're not music videos it's sci-fi but
it has like a music video kind of vibe
to it's weird real weird
a lot of good imagery
tila says antlers will be out 10 29 so
october 29th so a few days before
halloween okay so finally because like i
said i saw the trailer for that and i'm
just like goddamn like we need more
wendigo movies in our lives a lot of
people said blade runner color out of
space that's another good pick i mean
there's so many
really
uh
best looking movie jean cocktail beauty
and the beast done in black and white
yeah that's a good one too like yeah
there's like there's so many it's like
really really hard to pick it's just you
know the original suspiria from 1977
which is the first one that i thought of
just because
i just love that
i love that over-the-top super saturated
color type of [ __ ]
uh amanda marie says hey tom and jenny
and chat hi there amanda what's going on
all right so
are you are you ready to get into yeah
i'm ready okay
are you ready to get it of course i'm
ready
well i don't well i don't know yeah i'm
ready i don't know sometimes you got to
like ease into stuff you know
sorry i made like a kind of a dirty
gesture then
i wanted to like ease into stuff
so like i said anybody that didn't tune
in for the sidetrack show where we sort
of kind of talked about munchausen
syndrome now we're talking about it
again
but what we're gonna do is
i wanted to go like a little bit into
like just the general [ __ ] about it and
then i got like some cases if we don't
get into the case because i think we
talked a little bit about
the um
the dd blanchard case
which is kind of like a real famous
probably the most famous case of like
munchausen center by proxy at least um
so i put that last so if we don't get to
that then that's fine because i think we
talked about it some on the
on the side track show but if we do get
to it that's that's cool too but i have
like um kind of a handful of a bunch of
other cases most of the cases that we're
talking about though are
munchausen syndrome by proxy i guess
because
those are the ones that are more likely
to turn up in the media because if you
just have munchausen syndrome
which we'll get into in a minute it's
not that's just like the popular name
that's not like the official name
um if you just have that you're usually
just like hurting yourself
um whereas
the proxy version is more akin to child
abuse so that's more
you know likely to like turn up in the
media because
your ass gets arrested you know what i'm
saying
so you know
all right um
yeah danny rolling goes face brother
ravenous that's also about the windigo
that's actually a really good movie i've
been wanting to do
i don't think we ever did a
retrospective on that and i kind of feel
like we should because i feel like
that's a really underrated movie i
remember seeing that in the theater like
back in the [ __ ] 90s whenever it came
out when did that come out 90.99
something like that have you ever seen
that oh i don't think i've ever seen oh
it's good um what's his face isn't like
uh guy pierce is in it and uh
and uh like somebody yeah but it's it's
really really good though but yeah it's
like a wendigo story but it's like it's
it's a when to go sort of like a guy
like he resorted to cannibalism and
turned into a wendigo and then he comes
and like starts eating people but it's
like it's almost kind of like a black
comedy
sort of but it's
a really really really dark comedy you
know what i mean so it's not like zany
over the top comedy
but yeah so um yeah uh yeah no need for
me to says suicides probably get
misdiagnosed because of it i do kind of
feel like and i was listening to if you
guys are not i'm a big fan of this dude
he has like he posts like so many videos
dr grande he's um like a psychotherapist
and
he's always talking about different
mental health issues even like stuff
that's in the news like you know
celebrities or whatever they're having
nervous breakdowns or whatever like
people ask him about it and then he just
kind of like does a very sober
kind of layout he's like i'm not
diagnosing anybody i don't know them but
it's just like that you know from the
outside this is what it looks like to me
and he's so [ __ ] funny because he's
just so
um he's just very dry and he's very
matter-of-fact and he will talk he'll
just be talking about like some really
serious [ __ ] and then like he'll make a
joke but it'll be like in the exact same
tone of voice as like the [ __ ] that he
was like the serious [ __ ] that he was
talking about so sometimes if you're
just like talking like listening to it
in the background you're just like oh
[ __ ] that was like so funny it's just
like he has like the driest sense of
humor and just like for some reason that
really like abuses the [ __ ] out of me
but i watched his um
munchausen syndrome video earlier which
is actually really good i think it's
only like 15 minutes long
but um but it's worth watching he's just
he's just like really interesting i
don't know
but um yeah so
if you guys don't know like i said now
munchausen syndrome is not what they
call it anymore
um that was a name that was coined
back in 1951
and
uh as of the dsm-5 like the you know the
new diagnostic statistical
manual or whatever they're actually now
calling it a factitious disorder
uh imposed upon self which is bunch
hansen syndrome or factitious disorder
imposed upon another which is munchausen
syndrome by proxy and the reason they
did that was because
which i'll kind of get into because
munchaus it's not really like a super
accurate name considering like the
nomenclature you know what i mean so if
you guys don't know
munchausen syndrome
is when you essentially
pretend to be sick or
make yourself sick
for
reasons of
getting
attention
or
something it's like a pathological
reason
because the thing about it is that some
people make themselves sick for
monetary gain for example it's like you
know i'm trying to get like medical
benefits i'm trying to get uh drugs uh
you know that happens a lot i'm trying
to you know start trying to start a
gofundme or something like that because
i have cancer and i'm like making all so
like people that are like trying to make
money out of it or i'm trying to i'm
pretending i have cancer so i can do
like the you know the disney
what do they call that one the the
cancer kids that go to disney like the
make-a-wish foundation or whatever so
like you know there's there's [ __ ] like
that
but you're trying to get something out
of it like some kind of monetary gain
that's not the same thing that's just
called like malingering
um
this uh munchausen syndrome in
particular is one where you don't really
have any obvious motive
other than
attention you know what i'm saying
um and it's usually people that are very
very troubled it is a mental illness but
it's a also a very hard mental illness
to diagnose
because one thing that people with it
will do
is that if they start going to a
hospital for example and like presenting
with this disease that disease blah blah
and if somebody like if people start
trying like questioning what they're
doing there or like you know why you
don't have this what's the matter with
you and stuff then they'll start like
hopping around to like other doctors or
other hospitals um
just because
they don't they
they don't really know exactly
like why
i mean they have some suspicions about
what the pathology is
but usually it's for some kind of
attention because they like the
attention that comes with being
a sick person you know what i'm saying
yeah so
so there's that whole thing so that's
how they differentiate it between
somebody that's just doing it for
you know obvi like you know reason like
money or something like that
um it's just if you don't have you're
not getting anything out of it really
like you're not getting any material
gain
so now originally like i said this
disorder was first
it had been identified prior to this but
it didn't really have a name
so the guy that um
kind of named it back in 1951 he was his
name was richard asher and he was a
hematologist and an endocrinologist
who's british
and he basically came out like in a
paper and said um you know i know like
it's he called it a common syndrome
which most doctors have seen uh but
little has been written
and he's the one that called it
munchausen syndrome now this is what he
said i don't know if you guys know but
like uh
baron munchausen uh was an 18th century
german aristocrat
and his whole he kind of got famous and
the reason people still remember him
is because
he used to tell just like these crazy
[ __ ] stories about his
travels and it's like some of them were
obviously impossible you know what i
mean like he would just tell these
fantastical
tales of like all his exploits like he
did this that he like fought dragons and
all this other kind of [ __ ] so he would
like say that kind of stuff
so he kind of got famous for being
essentially alive a bullshitter yeah
yeah um
so when richard asher decided to um you
know name this uh this disorder
he called it
uh munchausen syndrome because they're
just naming it after him because what he
said and these were his quotes at the
time
he says like the famous baron von
munchausen the persons affected have
always traveled widely usually to go to
different doctors or hospitals or
whatever uh and their stories like those
attributed to him are both dramatic and
untruthful right but as time went on i
kind of feel like people were like well
yeah but
that guy baron munchausen from what they
could determine was probably just a
pathological liar or just liked making
stuff up um you know he was just like a
bullshitter like i said
and the motives for people that have
munchausen syndrome or factitious
disorder are not
the same as that
um because he was probably just making
up stories like because to entertain
people or because it made them feel
important or whatever it wasn't really
the same motivation
as
as they think for people that have
that have this disorder you know what
i'm saying so it's like so that's why
they decided yeah we're not they still
call it that like in popular culture and
like i've seen
like i watched a bunch of videos that
were like you know doctors
psychotherapists and stuff talking about
it and they said you know that's not the
official name but since that's the name
that most people are familiar with you
know that's we can just use the both the
names interchangeably because most
people if we say munchausen syndrome
most people know what we're talking
about if you say factitious disorder
imposed upon self which is what its
official
name is then no one will know what
you're talking about so they do actually
still use the popular name but that's
not the official name so you know like i
said
so uh
so what ends up happening
now these are people like i said
munchausen syndrome and munchausen
syndrome by proxy are kind it's sort of
the same thing there are two variations
of the same thing there's also
munchausen cinder by internet which
we'll get into in a minute which is kind
of a new variant
but they're essentially the same thing
but it's just the object of the of the
disorder is different munchausen
syndrome is people that do it to
themselves whereas much as in syndrome
by proxy is usually they do it to
somebody else usually a child not always
but in 90 of the cases it's usually a
caregiver usually a mother um doing [ __ ]
to their kids to get attention uh or
sometimes like someone elderly in their
care like like their grandma or
something like that there is some cases
where that happens too
so people that have
munchausen syndrome not by proxy but
just munchausen syndrome
um
what you will see is that
they will pretend to have
physical symptoms
so
a lot of things that are kind of like
non-specific it's like oh they have
chest pains or they have a fever they
have a stomach ache or you know
something that
is vague enough that it could be
attributable to like a lot of different
uh things
uh another thing they will do is that
they have been known to do things like
if they go to a doctor or a hospital
like and they're not like monitored
every second they'll do something like
you know give a urine sample and they'll
like somehow like put blood in there so
it looks like there's blood in their
urine
you know [ __ ] like that they'll give
themselves
uh things like they'll deliberately try
to get sick like they'll um you know rub
poop or dirt like in a wound so it'll
get infected um they'll take like epic
acts to you know to like throw up
um you know or take you know because a
lot of them have like you know are in
nursing or have medical knowledge so a
lot of them will take like stuff like
anticoagulants or something like that
like to make you know so their blood
doesn't clot like that kind of [ __ ]
um they there have also been cases where
some of them
um pretended to have psychological
symptoms
um to an extent of saying oh i hear
voices like they want you know to be
diagnosed with schizophrenia um you know
i see things that aren't there stuff
like that um this isn't quite as common
but it does happen uh it's usually
physical symptoms but usually physical
symptoms that are vague enough that
could be attributable and like i said
the real hardcore ones
um will
actually go to the links of like trying
to produce those symptoms by
taking various things
you know
you know making themselves sick
deliberately
now another thing that they do too and
like i said this is kind of why i guess
this is kind of why like it was called
munch house and center because the whole
traveling thing is because as i said if
they turn up
at enough
doctors and hospitals like around their
area
people are going to start to get
suspicious right why does this person
keep like turning up with all these
different
maladies or whatever so they have a
tendency to
kind of go like far-ranging like they'll
go to this doctor that that hospital
that hospital they'll go there a bunch
of times and then like if somebody
starts like questioning them then
they'll start going farther and farther
out
um i saw this one uh
show like one youtube show about this
where he was like an uh one doctor i
think he was from india and he was
talking he was like giving a class on
those or a lecture and he said we call
these hospital hoppers or frequent
flyers that's what they call them like
somebody that just comes in all the time
and like i said you have to
differentiate because
you know as most people know and i'm
sure everybody in the medical profession
knows you do have a small percentage of
people who will come in and fake
symptoms to get drugs
but these people are not doing that
these people are faking symptoms they
don't care about getting drugs they're
just faking symptoms because
they want to be seen as a sick person
that's kind of like their only
motivation you know what i mean which is
weird when you think about it let's say
a kind of hypochondria
it is but the thing about hypochondria
i kind of feel like they think they're
sick it's yeah it's similar don't i
think they know they're not sick they
just want to be serious they're not
entirely sure if they know because the
thing about it is that they think a lot
of the [ __ ] is maybe
to an extent subconscious i don't think
they're subconsciously putting blood
into their urine sample because
obviously you know what you're doing but
i don't think i'm saying it's
subconscious in the sense that i don't
think they know the reason why they're
doing it you know what i'm saying that's
well that's kind of one of the things
that differentiates it
from
well i mean hypochondria
is just like somebody's like you know
it's like somebody goes to webmd and
like every time every disease you read
about oh [ __ ] do i have that i have this
that the other then that they're like
you know going to the doctor and like
freaking out about it
whereas i feel like people with
munchausen syndrome it's like a much
deeper
uh issue i think they really really have
a lot of because they're i mean you know
we'll get into it in a minute but
there are a lot of like red flags or
like people types of people that have
this type of thing and i feel like they
go more all in to it
to like i said to the extent where they
will give themselves medications that
will make themselves sick or will make
themselves like produce the symptoms
that they want to produce
and a lot of them are really really good
at it because
a lot of them like i said are either in
the medical profession or they know a
lot about
you know they they kind of spend a lot
of their time learning about it so they
know about like all this you know what
symptoms do you need to present for this
diagnosis like what drugs
you know will produce this symptom so
they are really really good at doing
that
um so it seems like something they
devote a lot of their time to which i
feel like a hypochondriac
it seems like kind of the same mental
state but hypochondriac seems a little
less severe what gets me is that they
present all this [ __ ] what if they
[ __ ] convince somebody that they have
liver disease
or something
would they actually go through
the operation and get their livers
removed
well you can't remove a liver but you
know well they can remove some of your
lips yeah would they remove something
else oh yeah
they will they will absolutely have a
perfectly good body part
yeah
if they can get somebody to do it damn
um or they will you know take some [ __ ]
that will [ __ ] it up so they can so like
i said now in severe cases there have
been cases where people actually did do
that
where
they you know where they personally like
went through they said they had this
disease that disease and went through
various you know before somebody caught
on uh and a lot of times they have to
like doctor shop to find somebody that's
actually gonna do that or like i said
that they actually have to
um
take some kind of drug that will produce
like the symptoms they want in order to
get
uh the result that they want so some of
them will go through some like
completely unnecessary surgery i was
thinking to myself when i was reading
about some cases of these people
i was kind of like these people
if they're american
must have some real badass insurance
because
[ __ ] man i don't even go to the doctor
when i am sick i can't imagine because i
can't afford it so i can't even imagine
going to doctors like over and over when
you don't even need to and like getting
surgery we don't even need to it's like
how the [ __ ] do you even pay for that i
don't even know like how how does your
insurance company be like nope and like
cut you off
because i don't know i don't understand
it but
maybe they have some kind of workaround
for that i'm not really sure
but uh you know so yeah so and another
thing that's kind of difficult about
again like diagnosing this it's kind of
hard to diagnose because it's kind of
all about deception
and a lot of the people are
savvy enough
to know that when the doctor's hospital
of like whatever in one area gets
suspicious
they'll like move away or they'll go to
a different one that's like farther away
where nobody knows them because they
know that
there's not going to be like a huge
you know coordination necessarily
between like the old hospital and the
new one so they you know for a while
they can
get satisfaction at like a new place
um
the thing about it too and there's not i
hate to say because there's not really
any um
i don't want to say there's no treatment
for it but treatment for it is very
difficult and it's really not it's it's
it's not a case of like oh you know you
have you know this mental illness will
give you this medication uh medication
is usually not uh prescribed in this
situation they're like really
all you can do is you know cognitive
behavioral therapy stuff like that and
the fact about it is that it's really
really hard to diagnose and it's really
really hard to
get people to
even admit that they have it because
it's a whole
disorder
that's based around
deceiving other people and deceiving
yourself
and people that have it are really
really
resistant
to
being told that they are
not sick or you know that they're like
wrong so it's personality disorder
it is uh it is co-morbid with um
interestingly not it is a little bit
comorbid with narcissistic personality
disorder but not as much as you might
think because this does seem like a
narcissistic type of thing it's actually
more comorbid at least
from what i could determine with
anti-social personality disorder
which is kind of interesting but yeah i
kind of wanted to get into that a little
bit later too i was thinking almost like
histrionic almost
yeah it's not i don't know well the
thing constantly have to be high levels
of [ __ ]
panic and [ __ ] ultra drama
drama queen [ __ ]
you think that they would want to be the
center of attention of all this looking
it's a medical emergency
it there is some aspect of that but
they're pretty sure um just from looking
because this is a pretty rare uh
disorder i gotta say
but just from looking at the people that
have it yes a lot of times it is for
attention because they want to be the
center of attention
but not always some people they think
it might have something to do they said
now to a large extent people that
present with this
um
usually had some kind of like traumatic
like were emotionally physically or
sexually abused as children
um a lot of them had a lot of
uh terrible medical problems also when
they were children um so they maybe they
associate being sick
with
getting attention or getting affection
or being cared for so there might be
that kind of thing um there's also maybe
they think that it's
people that think that they deserve to
be sick or they deserve to be
punished they don't deserve to be well
there's another kind of um they think
maybe that might have something to do
with it as well so it's not really as
cut and dried as people just want
attention because i feel like the you
know i that that's a big part of it
but
i definitely think that the
the psychiat the psychology behind it is
a lot more complex than that because
some of the people really do
i mean a lot of them had really [ __ ]
up like childhoods and stuff like that
and
they might be associating like i said
being cared for in a hospital or being
like with
the only happy times from their
childhood which is really messed up but
there does seem to be some aspect of
that
um so yeah so like i said there's that's
very uh that's a red flag for people
that um
that may present with that later is if
they had some kind of trauma like is
that emotional trauma physical trauma
you know sexual abuse something like
that when they were kids or if they were
very very ill as children spent a lot of
time in the hospital or bedridden or
whatever um
and they got a bunch of medical
attention when they were kids that's a
big red flag uh like i said there are
some personality disorders that are
comorbid with it which i'll get to in a
minute um also there's kind of an aspect
too going through it where a person
has like a grudge against authority
figures uh healthcare figures in
particular
so there was a strain of that in there
as well that that turns up a lot
um
there's also an issue like when they
were younger if they were like abandoned
or neglected uh by their parents
uh so as i said some of the psychiatry
behind it like i said nobody knows
entirely what causes this or what
exactly like i said it's this kind of
stuff is always like way more complex
but as i mentioned earlier
um
some people feel a compulsion to punish
themselves
uh by
legi like literally making themselves
sick
because they think they deserve it
again you know maybe they need to feel
important or be the center of attention
um or they don't want to take
responsibility for their own uh health
care their own well-being and so pass it
on to other people so they can be kind
of like helpless and be cared for
they think there may be an aspect of
that too
um
so yeah so like i said it's it's pretty
i don't i don't want to say it's common
in people that had like real uh bad
medical problems when they were children
but that is something that they look for
like if they suspect that somebody is
presenting with that
now as i mentioned there are some other
like personality disorders that are
associated with this
uh the big one being anti-social
personal just personality disorder which
you know a lot of serial killers have
that too you know what i'm just saying
um that's where
if someone has
um antisocial personality disorder and
also presents with munchausens probably
that's probably more like an
anti-authority type of thing and they
get off on
manipulating uh doctors
which kind of gives them a sense of
control sense of power over what they
deem authority figures so that's usually
what that goes along with uh also
munchausen is also comorbid with
borderline personality disorder
um which is somebody who
is kind of like
i don't want to say it's like um
it's kind of like somebody that kind of
vacillates between
uh real positive feelings toward others
and real negative feelings toward others
like they don't really
uh they can't really control uh their
emotions
uh and again uh
as we mentioned before also comorbid
with narcissistic personality disorder
um
which
often presents as a someone that either
they they kind of go between seeing
themselves as worthless or seeing
themselves as like super special and
better than everyone so you can kind of
see how how that kind of all uh goes
along
now
so like i said it kind of feels like
this is a person that wants to play this
particular role they're not getting
anything else out of
um making themselves sick other than
attention and like i said in some
extreme cases they absolutely have
undergone
completely unnecessary
surgeries completely unnecessary
procedures um you know it's it's rare
that it would get to a point
unless they produce the symptoms
themselves somehow that a doctor is
gonna be like hey we're gonna like you
know take out this that the other thing
i think i there have been some where
like
people's gallbladders were removed and
stuff like that would when they probably
didn't need to be
um so they actually absolutely will go
through
completely unnecessary procedures
just to
satisfy this strange like psychological
uh disorder that they have
um yeah now jenny's taught me we've been
going on about psychiatry a lot about
personality disorders
i remember um the woman who lived across
the hallway for me in boston she was in
mental health she was she was a
psychiatrist and she was like a mental
health uh
worker
she was taking care of all these
outpatients and she had all these books
and she'd loan them to me
and there's a lot of overlap in those
personality disorder stuff there are
yeah a lot of overlap
well we were going to do a show on this
other guy this german dude who
infiltrated psychiatry he he blamed
psychiatrists for killing his mom he
thought it was all a bunch of [ __ ]
horse [ __ ]
i don't want to say it's a whole bunch
of horse [ __ ] but i'm not sure it's
totally a science all the time when you
look at those personalities disorders
and the way they they lay it out
yeah it's accurately describing certain
kind of personalities that do exist
but it also kind of reads a little bit
like a horoscope you can fit anybody
into some of those sometimes and it's
just kind of
it's hard i think
to come up with a hard science
that explains personalities and the mind
i just
it's always going to end up being kind
of hokey i think
well it's necessarily broad and vague
because people are complex yeah people
are too complex i guess which is
normally why i mean you know when i was
everything i was reading about
munchausen syndrome you know there's
certain things that have to be present
yeah and you know if those things aren't
present that people because there's lots
of other reasons why somebody might show
up at you know at the hospital with a
sickness that they don't really have
like i said the most common one probably
being you know i want to get some drugs
but
you know like i said this is very very
rare but they're only there has to be
certain things and honestly
it seems like because they're so good at
you know people with this disorder
because they're so good at like working
their work in the system
um going from hospital to hospital going
from doctor to doctor even changing
their names sometimes back in the old
days when that was easier to do um they
would do [ __ ] like that so you know no
one would look at their history um you
know so it's really really hard to
diagnose because a lot of times you know
doctors nurses stuff like that they see
a lot of patients
so it's kind of like you know you see
this person showing up like every few
months for
whatever and it's like it doesn't seem
that weird
um you know it'd be different if the
person was like showing up every [ __ ]
day being like oh my god i have this oh
my god i have that then everybody would
know okay get the [ __ ] out of here but
they're smart enough to
kind of work the system to their
advantage you can read their you can
read that literature and you can say
yeah there are personality types and
there are people that are fit kind of a
mold kind of like this
and you can put them into a group
and that's kind of what that literature
was doing but what was funny is that
their version of normal would be called
the well-adjusted individual or
well-adjusted person but they really
can't really define that they're only
really focused on mental illness
but codifying and describing it doesn't
really explain it and it's just
it's weird i think a lot of it sounded
more like philosophy to me but
i tell you what
borderline's personalities you can find
them
people that have munch owls and
syndromes like this they actually exist
yeah this is obvious
there's something that matters and they
do have something in common like yeah
like like and you know if you know
anybody that has
histrionic personality disorder it's
like you're talking to the same person
over and over again it's
it's two different people but they have
that disorder but they're so similar
personality wise yeah but it may just be
that that's the way humans are humans
aren't that well the thing about it is
just kind of like yeah and i mean people
are pretty much the same i mean well
people are complex but there are types
but those types kind of bleed into one
another
um so you can't just like make
definitive lines yeah you know this
person's like this this person's like
that because it might have you know
there might be some like [ __ ] grave
fuzzy area in there and that's what she
would you know and she did it for a
living and she was like yeah you know
that's just the book there's it's it's
it's a lot more
amorphous well you have well it is and
and you well that's why you kind of have
to like work with every individual
person
because it's like what's this person's
deal you know what i mean and honestly
like i took a lot of like psychology
abnormal psychology all that kind of
stuff like in college and the one uh the
one main guy that was like the professor
i took like most of his classes um you
know he was a psychotherapist and he's
like basically he's like there's no hard
and fast rules but
um you know the difference between like
because you were saying before about
like a normal person or a well-adjusted
person and a mentally ill person he's
like well the main difference that we
look at is like if
is this problem that you have bothering
you enough to like come and see us yeah
yeah um because obviously well-adjusted
people don't feel like they need to go
there
so you know what i mean so he's like
that's kind of like the first
you know line of defense because it's
like you came here so obviously it's
bothering you so
when we're talking about this
science
psychology and psychiatry
you have to under you have to be kind of
lenient with it it's not a science in
the way physics is science well because
people aren't numbers or planets or you
know and there is no
real like
they can describe personality types and
they can describe certain type of mental
disorders there's a lot of stuff in
common
there
but they may treat them in different
ways there is no there is no set way to
treat it sometimes a lot of times it's
just basically chemical lobotomy
uh if it's if it's real serious well
like i said it depends on the person
which is why
i mean ideally if somebody you know has
some kind of like mental illness you're
supposed to find
a therapist psychiatrist or something
like that that kind of like fits with
you and you're supposed to like work
together to like figure some [ __ ] out
whether it's medication whether it's
talk therapy whether it's a combination
of several things you're supposed to
like work together with that person
because like i said everybody's an
individual which is why you can't just
yes they have a big giant [ __ ] book
the dsm which is full of all the
disorders
but not everybody fits into every
category but they know that it's like
you just have to like meet the person
and then another things it's part of the
medical industry and just the medical
industry if you've got any friends that
are involved in that or have ever dealt
with it there's an
it's a pro it's it's a for-profit
business and there's an element of snake
oil in a lot of that [ __ ] you know
like well you know like diabetes and
[ __ ] erectile dysfunction and a weird
[ __ ] they can make an alopecia losing
your hair there's a bunch of different
ways to [ __ ] make money
but off of that that which really
doesn't address sometimes the the direct
the core issue that caused the problem
in the first place because solving the
problem might be cheaper than treating
the problem there's a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's weird
the the medical care that rich people
get are not the ones that you get at the
hospital well obviously yeah well i was
saying i think when you were out there
making drinks i was just like how can
you even afford to have munch house and
centrum syndrome in the united states i
can't like i you know i don't have
insurance so it's just kind of like um
you know even if i am sick it's like i'm
not i'm just like [ __ ] it i'll just like
i'll just uh you know power through it
but it's like so i can't imagine what
kind of insurance these people must have
to just go from doctor to doctor or
doctor and be like hey sure like take
one of my kidneys out [ __ ] sake
how many thousands what's that like 200
000 i don't even know how much that goes
for nowadays um but the fact that you
could just do that like cavalierly i
mean i know it's a mental illness they
can't help it
but you know what i mean it's just kind
of like every time we watch hoarders and
it's like those people make me like
super mad but it's like i understand
it's a mental illness they can't help
being like that um you know and it's the
same thing with munchausen syndrome they
can't help being like that and to a
large extent they're not
super aware of it um or they're not
super aware of like you know the the
deep-seated reasons why they're doing it
um you know they just want like a result
and that's all they're worried about so
they're not really thinking about why am
i doing this they you know they don't
have a lot of insight into that
um so you know so you kind of have to
give them like some sympathy in that
regard but
it's still like infuriating it's
infuriating to like see from the outside
because you're like
obviously obviously you're why are you
putting blood in your urine sample why
are you like injecting yourself with
whatever like why are you taking all
these ipa so you can just like go in the
hospital oh my god i'm so sick you know
what i mean um
but like i said they're not doing it for
the same reasons that somebody that was
just like looking for money like hey i'm
gonna start a gofundme and like make a
hundred thousand dollars for my cancer
treatments when they don't have cancer
because some people have done that yeah
um but like i said that's shitty but
it's that's more understandable because
it's like hey i'm trying to scam a
hundred thousand dollars out of some
well-meaning people um don't do that
either but they're they know what
they're doing they're very aware that
they don't have cancer they're just like
making it a scam these people
i think they're to an extent it seems
like they're aware that they're not sick
but not to the same extent that someone
that's doing it
just for monetary gain you know what i
mean it's there's there's an element of
like subconscious
[ __ ] going on yeah no need for me
says there's no snake oil with my sugars
that away yeah but there's a lot more to
it than you think there's a way to cure
diabetes you could do you can do it with
uh
there's a gene replication there's one
thing and you can [ __ ] inject
healthy [ __ ] um replicated dna i
forgot exactly what's into your kidney
and
and you can piggyback that with a with a
virus which will reprogram or rebuild a
kidney that's one thing you can do
another thing you can do is um the
production of insulin is usually
dependent upon [ __ ] like your
endocrine system sometimes things like
pituitary gland syst pituitary gland
stimulants can help you [ __ ] um
overcome diabetes also being
uh thinned like if you get overweight
you're gonna be prone to it also if
you've had a high
carbohydrate diet early on in life it'll
[ __ ] you up
especially if you're caucasian or black
asians now they're a lot more resistant
to to diabetes they got a system that
can they can make
they make a lot more insulin they make
it easier that's because they for
thousands of years they've been empires
built on rice which is high carbohydrate
there's a lot a lot of ways around
things that like for instance when i
started hrt never had heartburn again
never
never had [ __ ] acid reflux
could eat anything and it's because my
um all my endocrine systems run running
a lot harder so i make all those
digestive enzymes better than i used to
so i don't have heartburn
all my joints feel good you never need
anything else so a lot of times there's
an underlying issue
but these little drugs that they sell
your little [ __ ] bad dates they'll
they will fix that one particular
problem but
the real problem was further up on the
damn chain and they know it
rich people don't take those things yeah
they take they take the real [ __ ] and
like i said too i kind of feel like
sometimes
people
and this is goes on both sides like the
medical profession and patience yeah
it's like sometimes you just want the
problem solved with one thing it's like
you don't really want to go keep going
back for test after testing just to
determine like what the root cause is
yeah um so because you know i get that
like if i just had heartburn or
something like that i'm like yeah just
give me a [ __ ]
sec and like just leave me alone i don't
really want to like know if there's some
other [ __ ] issue that i'm going to
have to keep going back and get tested
and then maybe get surgery and do this
and just cost me hundreds of thousands
of dollars
real problem is as you pass 40 your
android system just doesn't run that
well so you're not producing the same
hormones and the enzymes that you used
to produce that help you digest and do
all this [ __ ] that you you did when you
were young that's why you get fatter and
fatter you just can't [ __ ] metabolism
is not running right
take some hcg
or clomid
which is a [ __ ] just like kicking
that damn pituitary gland all your [ __ ]
will just boom it'll just wake up
now you can't do it all the time but a
couple times a month
but they don't want to tell you that
clomid doesn't cost anything it's cheap
okay says i don't like to take anything
daily or regularly yeah i don't either
no you take a pill i want my own body to
keep doing a thing it's like when you're
older it's different and if you take a
[ __ ] clomid pill maybe two a week
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] solves a lot
of it right there
i mean honestly like all i i take three
aspirin or ibuprofen like
the night after i drink a lot so i don't
have a hangover the next morning but
other than that i don't really like to
take it i don't even like to take a
multivitamin
i don't know
just like i don't really like to
it's just kind of like i've you know
i've gone without it like most of my
life so
it'll be all right it'll be all right
um yeah so where was i all right so um
like i said earlier
people that have this this disorder
even though it seems very much like
they're deceiving people on purpose
which to an extent they are
but i don't really think that they're
fully aware of like the reasons behind
what they're doing which like i said is
one of the reasons why it's a disorder
um
and as i mentioned they usually have a
lot of medical knowledge used to be back
in the old days before the internet
before everything was on the internet
um one of the red flags like if they
suspected that somebody had munchausen
syndrome they would look into is this
person a nurse or is this person in the
medical profession because that like
upped the um
the likelihood that they had munchies
and cinnamon a lot because you saw it
not you know not a lot in medical
professions but people that they
suspected of having it um you know if
you were in the medical profession then
they would suspect you even more it was
like a red flag because they're like oh
well here's somebody that can
go to a doctor
and describe exactly
you know the symptoms and because they
they know exactly what that would entail
um nowadays it's not as much of a red
flag obviously because everything's on
the internet and everybody can find out
everything
so
somebody who was determined enough
wouldn't even have to be a nurse or
anything because you could just go to
[ __ ] like i said webmd or something
like that and you could just like read
all about whatever disease you wanted to
present as
you know what symptoms do i need you
know what drugs can i give myself to
produce that so it's so it's not as much
anymore interestingly too then this is
not all of them
but
it's very very common
for people with munchausen syndrome
to be
super super friendly
to
hospital staff particularly like if they
want to like come to the hospital all
the time like they have some lingering
disease or something so they always like
want to come to the hospital they want
to make friends with all the nurses and
the staff and everything like that
you know like they want to hang out like
it's a social event however
if they are challenged or somebody says
something like hey i don't think you
have this or i think you're lying about
this that and the other then they will
go full [ __ ] karen and they will have
a [ __ ] meltdown about it and they'll
start becoming abusive i'm gonna sue you
blah blah so it's kind of like one or
the other but they said that's another
thing that they see very very often uh
and usually if they are challenged they
will just be like oh whatever i'm gonna
sue you blah blah and then they'll take
off and then they won't come back
because they'll go to another place so
that's like a pretty common as well now
like i said this is kind of hard to
diagnose
uh basically what they do and when i get
into like talking about some of the
cases of it
um it's kind of sad because particularly
you know cases of munchausen by proxy
which i feel like are maybe more like a
little bit easier to diagnose than
somebody that's doing it to themselves
um you know it's obviously be it'd be
more suspicious when you do it to
somebody else particularly a kid
but
i kind of feel like what ends up
happening is that
you have to like suspect it
and then
if you did suspect it you'd actually
have to go back through their entire
medical history and that would usually
entail going backwards like let's
discover
what all of the doctors and hospitals
that they went to in the past you know
what i mean you would also have to like
do a bunch of checks
to
find if there was like some drugs in
their system that would produce some
kind of symptoms that they were
presenting with that maybe they
shouldn't have been taking
um that's another thing that they look
for
and
uh you know doctors will also want to
like rule out
any other possible motivations like i
said most common one is people that want
to get painkillers
so they come in complaining about stuff
hoping they get drugs um you know so
they're trying kind of trying to rule
that out is this so like i said this is
a very very difficult uh thing to
diagnose so the only re i mean the only
time that they will actually say this is
probably
a case of munchausen syndrome um if they
find evidence that this person is
definitely inducing symptoms or
fabricating them
um
if there is no other reason that they're
doing it as in they're not trying to get
drugs they're not trying to make money
off it anything like that like there's
no
reason that people would understand like
why they were doing it so that's kind of
like
so it seems like like the only reason
that they're there is because they want
to be seen as a sick person you know
what i mean that's like the only way
that they would uh determine it and as i
mentioned before
uh very very difficult
to treat and there's really not any
consensus like i said not really a lot
of medications prescribed i don't really
see anything it's like oh give him this
and it'll be fine or anything um most of
it was like needed some combo of like
cognitive behavioral therapy family
therapy something like that depending on
what the situation was um and
psychiatrists are kind of two minds
about it um some of them think that you
should just like confront them directly
like hey you're a big fat liar um you
know you don't have this and that and
some people like more more like a soft
shoe kind of approach uh think works
better but like i said i think that's
probably
on a case about case-by-case basis i'm
i'm sure that different things will work
for different people and like i said i'm
going back to like the hoarders thing
again because people with like ocd
because sometimes you see that
on you know just from that tv show
sometimes
um confronting the person directly and
being like you are a filthy pig you need
to clean this stuff up like sometimes
that works better and then sometimes
being kind of like soft pedaling it
sometimes that works better so it just
depends on the kind of person that
you're talking to
showed up what's up victor hey
sandra didn't show up oh yeah
we didn't see what her funny name was
she must be going to get peanut butter
no she was going to get plastic surgery
i saw after she saw the my mental image
over she went out there to go match that
that's what it is yeah i'm sure that
everyone cares everyone in the world
cares how much
cares what you think about their boobs
yeah and immediately went out and spent
thousands of dollars
to get some boobs
that's his fantasy anyway
it was cool though
it was a cool idea
it was a cool idea victor just showed up
thank you victor
jenny i love your shirt thank you oh and
start over i'm late
you should see what's in these things
man i ain't gonna grab it i'll get too
much money well i mean people can like
imagine what yeah imagine that [ __ ] yeah
did we yeah you you told me about only
fans
yeah they shut only fans down no they
didn't shut it down no more you can't
have like you can have nudity like
within parameters but you can't have
like porn anymore yeah you're gonna
watch what happens to that that shit's
gonna [ __ ] that shit's gonna go out
of business
probably because i kind of feel like
that was like the only that's what that
was for i mean yeah there was other [ __ ]
on there but i kind of feel like that's
where they made all their money and they
said well we have to we're uh we're
being pressured by the banks well and by
paypal and stuff like that because
well no paypal and [ __ ] like that they
intervene with all that kind of stuff
all the time because they're you know
that's that's kind of like you have to
have some kind of like wave for people
to pay like on the website this is the
time this is the time these [ __ ] need
to start dropping their nuts
and go ahead and get involved in [ __ ]
bitcoin
banks should not they might actually
banks have no business in what you buy
banks are corporations
[ __ ] them they're in no business
they shouldn't even care if you [ __ ]
buy a ton of cocaine that's none of
their [ __ ] business and that's not
illegal in every country
all right [ __ ] those banks get into
bitcoin get those old-school banksters
out of the [ __ ] system they're
obsolete nobody needs them
they got kicked out of a lot of those
northern european countries for those
[ __ ] predatory practices now they
just have little apps on their phones
their government has put a little app
and they have their own bank even our
constitution says that the congress is
imprints the money not these [ __ ]
banks
it should just be an app on your phone
they need to put these guys out of
business [ __ ] them
zack says tom i have boobs and i don't
even need to work on them where's my
exact where's my
attention here's the thing zach
zach wants to jump in here okay
trying to get my attention because he
knows i've had i've had some few drinks
yeah and i know i know what's going on
behind behind the scene
zach chicken hawking he's [ __ ]
chicken hawk and swooping down on all
these straight guys in the damn comment
sections that leave those straight boys
alone zach he's just like looking like i
know it's in your nature i know it's
your nature leave them straight boys
alone they're straight for a reason stop
stop try stop trying to [ __ ]
dirtify these [ __ ] your your
your your what do they call it jenny i
have no idea what you're trying to do
when you when you [ __ ] up the sanctity
you when you when you thank you victor
he says here's point zero zero zero one
bitcoin
thank you
that's pretty funny that that was a good
one he's trying to defile that's what it
is zach's trying to defile the sanctity
of the straight man
leave it alone zach
are straight straight men are sanctified
sanctified talk about yeah who knew the
sanctity yeah don't defile that what
your butthole don't defeat yeah they're
virgins leave them alone oh they're
virgils
yeah yeah [ __ ] right
y'all [ __ ] has never been pegged
these women have these [ __ ] weird-ass
fantasies that's so much a fantasy i
just think it would be funny
that's what the spartans thought i would
i would get a lot of like uh sadistic
pleasure out of it probably yeah more
than more than fantasy that's what would
happen if you lost the battle to the
spartans they raped the enemy [ __ ]
soldiers
well you know yeah hey we saw that on
that was on spartacus too wasn't it uh i
i don't know if they raped him did they
rape anybody yeah did not would they
have one guy raped c or caesar remember
that that's right yeah yeah yeah what's
this what's his ass what yeah that's
right that was uh [ __ ] man
yeah uh it didn't happen in real life
but well no but i'll just have it on the
program on the show it did they raped
julius caesar
yeah yeah that was [ __ ]
caesar got bloodworked yeah wasn't that
poppy that did that
it was the son of the that's right it
was the main it was the same antagonist
yeah yeah yeah that's right that taylor
did you feel that dude was a douchebag i
hated that tila did you finish spartacus
i know you've been truant on your
homework that [ __ ] gets really good man
every season he's put every you can't
even have a conversation with him
everything's like a test that's a test
in these [ __ ] it's like a pop quiz
yeah i know
we need a pegasus
we need a pegging show let's make it
happen
[Laughter]
i agree we should do a whole pegging
show
[Laughter]
time has come
what movie is this spartacus the kirk
doug no it's the spartacus
series it was on stars i want to say
yeah it's now on amazon but you can
watch it on amazon prime you can watch
most of them
free i think only the last season you
got to watch you got to pay for yeah do
we want okay it has ads but like amazon
prime i think you can watch the first
three since four seasons you watch the
first three seasons but then you have to
pay for the fourth season maybe or maybe
the third and fourth ones we had to pay
for i don't remember i can't remember
but it doesn't matter they're good
they're they're
well worth it
[Laughter]
did tom say truant this [ __ ]
yeah
who said that taylor yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god okay
the one i guess the show the one the one
with the xena yeah that one well she was
just in the photo she was bad in that
man yeah
but but did newspaper so bad she was
good yeah she's really um she was just
in the first two seasons first two
seasons yeah lucretia yeah she was a
great character
yeah a lot of good drama in it yeah i
mean i really like a lot of good a lot
of good action scenes i mean the third
and the fourth seasons were good too but
i feel like the first two were were
better because they they had batiatas
and lucretia and those were like the
best two characters i thought
um yeah so
i guess i guess t i guess t said [ __ ] it
she stopped watching it
[Laughter]
she just said did tom tate true it yeah
i did i said true it
i [ __ ] put on you're pretty curly i
went full white boy with that one
full white boy
he's like he's like a teacher yeah
that's your teacher wig yeah
you need a little like graduation cat no
this is my [ __ ] this is my michael
caine wig
did i tell you guys that like pookie has
become obsessed with that severed hand
that i have back there because remember
he had that like when he had the
halloween costume yet that's every hand
that sat on his shoulder
um pookie has become like really really
interested in that several hand yeah for
whatever reason she's scared of it
she'll come in here well yeah but she's
also like really interested she'll come
in here and like sit in front of it like
look at it yeah and then like she'll put
her little nose up to it and it's like
she'll kind of like take her paw and
like do the thumb like that and kind of
pull it and then she'll be like oh she's
like i moved and then like a couple of
times she's pulled it hard and it fell
off and she's like oh and she like jumps
away from it like
i think she thinks it's your hand yeah
she knows it's a hands
and it's not attached and she's like
what the [ __ ] is going on with this
but it's like it's just really funny i
was watching her like yeah i was like
watching her the other day i don't think
she knew i was watching her but she was
just like [ __ ]
she was just like poking at that [ __ ]
hand it was like so funny
uh tila says if tom breaks out a whip
and threatens me i will tell jenny to
break out a dildo
yeah
you can't [ __ ] with us seriously [ __ ]
t's in there pretending to be a woman i
know that's a white man that's a white
man on that account
it's a white drag queen
how do you know that i just got i just
feel it oh okay i just feel it say
spiritual
all right spiritual
[Laughter]
remember we went to that drag restaurant
yeah remember that [ __ ] hamburger
mary's hamburger mary's in the [ __ ]
and and drinking police are serving and
[ __ ] yeah
that's been there like god as long as i
can remember yeah it's pretty good it's
downtown orlando yeah that's right it's
church street
yeah they do drag shows i don't you know
i don't that's been a while but they do
drag shows a couple times a week yeah um
yeah it's super fun
food's not bad either yeah i saw t
working there
it was a white man
what era is that michael caine wig looks
like his 70s hair yeah it's late 70s
it's from he got that exactly from the
hand yeah it's actually
a
secret from the movie the hand it's it's
actually from it's actually a willy
wonka wig yeah but it actually does look
like michael caine's hair from the hand
which came out of what 1981 yeah that
was 81. great movie i think fantastic
movie well it was what's is that like
oliver stone's first was it for his
first movie or
it might have been his first time and
milius were kind of working on it behind
the scenes
yeah it was kind of a john millius a
[ __ ] adjacent dude who did conan and
red down and everything and
but uh millie is also [ __ ] basically
wrote apocalypse now too
yeah he wrote a lot of that guy yeah so
manly [ __ ] manly [ __ ] the man
[ __ ]
zach is asking if you're into asian
women
even it no zach is asking no eva uh
he says even as a gay i think even as a
gay yeah
i'm not sure that says even as gay yeah
i think some asian women are hot as [ __ ]
lmao yeah
it depends on the person like i said
it's just like anybody else i don't know
we're talking about pure physicality you
know what i mean [ __ ] now you get me
sidetracked okay that's for the side
attraction what else i know you [ __ ]
don't show up
i lived in i lived in south korea for a
year if you guys don't know the show but
i was stationed there in the army and um
yeah i liked korea it's a beautiful
place
i liked um
korean history was really interesting i
was on camp graves first in the 506
infantry party i was a dmz mp on
but they're
on the um dmz with uh north korea uh
right outside ajsa
had friends of mine the liberty bell
for those you you guys know what i'm
talking about all that shut down now
cam greaves is now a [ __ ] museum
on the dmz tour so i was i had the real
dmz experience
anyway uh
yeah man i was [ __ ] at hooker hill
when hooker hill was hooker hill and
everything and [ __ ] e taiwan and tom
deshawn and all that and [ __ ] the
paradise club he's called the parasite
club at [ __ ] old [ __ ] camp
what you call it but no don't worry
about that [ __ ] um
for some reason there's like a
stereotype that white guys are [ __ ]
big into these
asian women and i think some of them are
i think it's uh i think it's like a
fetish but it's weird to like fetishize
an entire race of people that's very
strong they do have a certain look
that's very different you know what i
mean they they do they do um some of
them it's not all i mean it's just like
anything else there's variation you know
some of them are ugly some of them are
real good looking but the good-looking
ones do have a certain look
but the thing is though is that looks
aren't really enough it looks or or one
of the things that
is like the first impression you know
that a guy gets that's what he's judged
judges a woman's
attractiveness based on her looks and
her qualities it's just ingrained in you
it's part of being a male not only of
the human species but all the other
species you know [ __ ] all
males that are
mammals do it you know they look at a
woman they check this [ __ ] out you know
um
problem is is that the kind of guy that
i am
eastern cultures do not produce the
types of personalities that i like
um i like kind of
rebel women who are
creative and um
to me and have a certain amount of
sexuality to me that's sexy
eastern cultures are about conformity
and fitting in they don't produce the
kind of individual that interests me
um
and then the chances are in those
cultures the kind of women that would be
suitable for me would be
unsuitable for me in other words they'd
be hookers or prostitutes or something
like that
so yeah you might want to mess around
but you don't want to [ __ ] marry
somebody like that you don't want to
like you know you don't want that as
your girlfriend
and uh
and that not that's not only korea
that's japan too you know
in japan those women are boring unless
there's some kind of we'll see i think
and i don't know if this is um unless
there's some kind of hooker or porn star
this is i don't think this is as
prevalent as that used to be but i think
that the reason that there was this sort
of uh subculture of like white dudes
that were super into asian women was
exactly because they were seen as more
submissive
than yeah
maybe
i think they would that was a large fact
i think they might i think it was more
like they were into these demure type
yeah they don't want
[Laughter]
it's just it's just a different way of
looking at things i guess i don't
doesn't really matter
i like i like
i like there isn't just one kind of
woman that i like there's several
different types that i like i'm not
most men like variety and then
in the comment section they'll say so
you like there's a certain variety of
personalities and a certain variety of
looks that are acceptable
or good you know what i'm talking about
i'm talking about well i'm kind of the
same there isn't just one i don't really
i don't have a type right i don't think
there's i mean i know some people do but
i don't have that you do have a type i
have a type but it's not things that you
will not go for well yeah but i don't
think that's i don't think that's narrow
enough to be called a type because i
kind of think that it's like well i
don't like xyz but everything else is on
the table as long as you're cool right
kind of thing when it comes to sexiness
white women
black women and hispanic women
and hispanic as an in a [ __ ] very
inaccurate term that doesn't mean
anything i grew up in brazil too
but the people that you would call
hispanic women actually are are
they all have their own individual
styles and that's what
to me that's the direction you would
want to go
you know i'm talking about
one of those
yeah yeah well like i said i always
think it's easier to like just
i don't know like i said i kind of go by
individual people i don't have a thing
it's like i i can't really think of
anything
i don't know i guess i can think of a
couple things that probably be like deal
breakers i guess they would say but not
that many things right because it
depending on the person it's like you
know that could work for you or it might
not be that big a deal or you know what
i mean it just depends on what the
person is so i'm not really that
concerned about types or anything like
that right and and and it's
it all depends on the individual but the
end of it ethnic ethnicity is a factor
ethnicity and race is a factor
because
those those cultures produce certain
kind of people
and the attractive versions of those are
going to be different you know i'm
talking about yeah uh there is some
crossover like for instance sherry
sherry mouse is black
but she's attractive
but she's also gothic but she's
attracted because she's gothic
know what i mean so she wouldn't be as a
tr she wouldn't be the same kind of
attraction would be say like
some attractive black chick that was
like into the [ __ ] i don't know maybe
like the r b
scene yeah it wouldn't and that's not a
different type yeah that's just almost
like i don't want it like superficial
that sounds like dismissive but i don't
mean it like that right yeah that's just
kind of like because a lot of stuff i
like is you know dudes that are into
like goblets
or horror [ __ ] it's like you know i like
dudes like that right um it doesn't
matter other than that it doesn't really
matter like what race you are if you're
fat or skinny or whatever it's like if
you're in there you're a [ __ ] cool
black dude we know cool black dudes in
the goth scene they're they're white
women find them acceptable because
they're into the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what i mean it's just it's all
like they have [ __ ] in common with you
you like this you have the same interest
right yeah so it doesn't even like we're
all speaking the same way and like race
and [ __ ] like that doesn't really come
in to it because it's like they're all
just into the same [ __ ] as sure so no
one's it kind of comes into it because
they're spinning off of it in a certain
way but i can all know it's like it just
really doesn't it never really seemed
like that big a deal to me i guess i
don't know well okay like
goth
goth white chicks wear a lot of black
clothing and everything kind of set off
[ __ ]
white skin and they look pale like a
vampiric
but if you look at sherry sherry does
that but she'll also wear [ __ ] all
white
so then you have that a different
contract so she is she does play off of
that yeah with white hair and white
clothes and red contacts and
so no you you can play off of that yeah
like t was saying what does a black goth
look like and then t google goths of
color
and yeah there are
black goth female looks that white women
couldn't do
they couldn't do but they yeah or it
wouldn't look the same which wouldn't be
the same
like you know
haitian voodoo
goth black chicks oh they're gonna do
that it looks [ __ ] great
or which my friend crystal does
sometimes right
or [ __ ] black girl doing
1970s blacula goth with the bell bottoms
and the afro and everything that looks
great
you know what i mean why a girl can't do
that
it's just yeah it would look really
really right right
so ethnicity is a factor yeah it's a
positive factor you just have to know
how to play on it
yeah
you know you look at a lot of [ __ ]
white goth girls are playing off [ __ ]
european aristocracy motifs
yeah yeah so yeah that works yeah
because you want some like white ass
skin you want to look like all like
victorian [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah like i
don't have any blood what are you doing
right it's it and it is definitely
ethnic definitely
so you know it works
ethnicity is a good thing but like i
said you know you can make a lot of
things work if you right if you know
what you're doing right
and just like that mexican goth girl
loretta vamps where she did the mexican
goth things of the [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] santa muerte and [ __ ] that
[ __ ] worked yeah and the aztec motifs
and [ __ ] yeah
somebody uh camp guy said something
about the movie magic
which
uh
spoiler alert i just did a review of
that movie which i've seen many times
and i love that movie uh which is going
up
actually if you have patreon it probably
went up this morning
uh but if you don't have patreon then
you'll be able to see it tomorrow
morning um victor says i like dudes but
nice boobs are always nice to look at
too who doesn't like boobs right boobs
are great
i like you know i'm i'm a mostly
straight woman and i also like boobs uh
gran there's hammer said did you meet
any korean goth chicks no it didn't
exist
that barely didn't that barely existed
in the united states at the time that i
was there it was the early 90s
yeah
chile goes way but she was golf but
attractive oops
that's not what i said
i probably meant aesthetically the way
the goth thing looked on her was [ __ ]
attractive that's what i meant
yeah because like i said i'm kind of
like
yeah i'm kind of more into like what
like
what their like
whole look is what's your whole like
aesthetic kind of [ __ ] going on right
you know what i mean not so much like
what your face looks like or anything
like that but how did you put put
yourself yeah that's what you said
i'm drunk and you're [ __ ] reading
into the context
[ __ ]
no they got a lot of good-looking black
one what are you talking about
they go they got a lot of good women
over there there's a lot of good looking
women
they're very racist yeah you know what i
mean
i see good work look at women all the
time you see the good looking dudes all
the time they got ugly [ __ ] of
[ __ ] every race too well you got ugly
dudes of every race too that's what i
mean yeah like you know
but like i said you know even if you're
like funny looking you can still like
pull some [ __ ] off
that doesn't you know i'm not saying
yeah you can be funny looking and still
like be sexy yeah
do you just gotta work it just work it
yeah so did you see the haitian god look
she goes i'm gonna [ __ ] google that
it was in glass of color one of them
showed up
and she was wearing brown and black and
she had the dreads and the bones and
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] and the [ __ ] in
the neck piece and the it looked really
good see that shit's fantastic yeah yeah
i love that like it looked like yes
you look like a voodoo priestess i love
that yeah
um
crystal does that yeah she does that too
well she did our friend crystal she
works at universal
and one year i think this was a couple
years back
um you know how they have it universally
of halloween horror nights right very
famously and one year they had like a
big one of their houses or their
sections was like a voodoo
thing so she got to play like voodoo
priestess so she was like the hostess of
the area
um and she looked [ __ ] great yeah man
she did like went all out yeah she had a
bone in her nose a [ __ ] yellow
[ __ ] dress
um she had a top hat didn't she i think
she did yeah yeah it looked good
look good
all right so where was i yeah i don't
remember now and probably i need another
drink okay
um
yeah so
yeah and i might have to also i'll go to
the bathroom soon but i'll wait until
you come back
so uh all right where was i so i was
gonna say okay so the most common
at least like i said this is very hard
uh disorder to diagnose
um so they're not sure entirely how
prevalent it is according to dr grande
he said that from his research um at
least in the united states not worldwide
in the united states um
they
diagnose about 200 cases of munchausen
syndrome
by proxy a year
but they're not sure if that's an under
diagnosis or an over diagnosis because
they say look um
you know this disorder is kind of based
the whole basis of it is deception
so it could be
it's probably more likely that they're
under diagnosing it because maybe people
that have it
um you know are moving around from place
to place and are kind of like falling
through the cracks
so they don't get diagnosed with it
but um but he's saying that's so it is
very very rare
but it could be more prevalent than
uh than we think just because it's hard
to diagnose
now
roughly 90
of the cases of the identified cases of
munchausen syndrome not necessarily
munchausen by proxy but munchausen
syndrome generally i accidentally poured
that juice in it if you want to
no it's all right it's good enough yeah
i don't care all right you know you know
how i get i'll once i've had a couple i
was just like i'll drink anything
well i don't want to say that
i'm not going to drink urine or anything
like that but i'm just saying you know
to a to some degree i'll drink anything
uh 90 of people that are diagnosed with
munchausen syndrome uh not necessarily
munchism by proxy
uh are women between the ages of 20 to
40
years old
um and usually have something to do with
the medical profession like i said not
always nurses not only stuff like that
but
there are a lot of people that work in
healthcare
that are into it the other 10 percent
roughly 10
interestingly
unmarried white men
30 to 50 years old
not entirely sure
why it's just these two groups that are
affected really doesn't seem to be
uh you don't really see many people of
other ages other ethnic groups other you
know anything like that um affected by
this does seem to be
you know 90 is women 20 to 40 uh and the
rest of them are usually unmarried white
men 30 to 50. not entirely sure what the
overlap is there but
that's the two uh most common
groups
now
let's talk a little bit about
munch houses by internet now this
probably isn't what you're thinking this
isn't like hypocrite because i thought
it was like hypochondria like oh my god
i went to webmd and i have every disease
that's on there
this is not exactly that
munchausen by internet is kind of like
i don't think i don't think this is in
the dsm because i don't think it's like
technically but i think it's like a
variant
what this person will do is not so much
show up at a hospital and like give
themselves like hey i injected myself
with feces so i have like e coli now or
something like that which you know we'll
get to that in a minute
um you know it's it's not that extreme
but people who have munch houses by
internet
will basically go on to
like say forums or discussion groups or
something like that for people with a
particular disease like you know people
with leukemia or cystic fibrosis or
whatever
and
will say that they have this disease and
get involved in the community
um
just
and kind of base their identity around
having this disease you know what i'm
saying um so in it to an extent this is
less harmful
because all they're doing
you know is making up this [ __ ]
identity on the internet that's all
based around having this disease and
people who actually have this disease
are like talking to them and being
supportive and [ __ ] like that except
this person's like [ __ ] scamming
kinda
um so
uh so some of the ways that they have
said to like determine whether a person
has this or not uh they said this person
will tend to
post on forums about the disease or
whatever but
the their posts usually have stuff
that's just like uh kind of copy pasted
from you know like webmd or like some
other like big medical site they'll do
that
um they also tend to
say that their symptoms
are a lot more severe
than
most people would experience with the
same uh illness uh you know so there's
that
um they'll also have like real dramatic
uh kind of ups and downs like oh my god
like i had this and like i almost died
but i recovered from it um you know that
kind of thing just so they can get
attention get like accolades and stuff
a lot of times they'll say stuff about
you know they'll they'll kind of come up
with these elaborate fictions about
being at this particular hospital or
something like that and if anybody looks
into it that hospital is not real
um
they also kind of extend out to
you know not only do i have this
horrible
fatal life-threatening illness that i
want to tell everybody about
but sometimes it extends out to now your
family members have an illness or your
family members were in this horrible car
accident and they're crippled and
stuff like that i said that tends to
happen when
excuse me when attention on the forum
goes to somebody else
so they're basically just trying to
bring attention back to themselves
by being like oh my god my you know my
boyfriend just got murdered you know so
they'll do that kind of thing um so it's
the same pathology it's just arguably
less harmful because they're not harming
themselves or not harming children or
anything like that they're just going on
the internet and making up stories
and you know presumably just to get
attention because they feel like they
want to be a sick person and that's like
the way they get attention which is kind
of sad but you know
you doing all right yeah fine doing good
all right so you take a break yeah i'm
just like gonna run the bathroom and
then after that we were gonna talk about
like i got some cases
okay we'll talk about some mostly of
like mostly of munches and by proxy but
some of these people had munchausen
syndrome
themselves and then inflicted it on
their children also do we have a uh any
commercials we gotta play yeah play that
strange reality zad okay in 2019 the
first strange realities conference took
place in nashville tennessee the
pandemic in turmoil the following year
could not stop 2020's conference from
thriving in cyberspace as a live
streaming event now for 2021 the third
annual strange realities conference will
combine these worlds into a paranormal
hybrid event live in person in nashville
and streaming online
join us in exploring just how truly
strange our reality can be with an
interdimensional lineup of speakers
presenting unique and intellectual
perspectives on magic mysteries and the
paranormal
featuring
dr j michael bennett aka dr future tim
bernal soraya azcat dr stephen finley
aaron gulias amy pachula brent raines
chris ernst heather mosher michael
hughes jose herrera joshua cutchen
nathan isaac pd newman steven snyder aka
recluse david metcalf timothy renner
steve stockton and friend collier
tickets available on
strangerealtheconference.com
it's gonna be amazing
[Music]
see i didn't see i didn't see maine full
screen i had to [ __ ] scroll up i'm
going where did you left like a bunch of
like black screen with the [ __ ] only
few seconds
yeah look at your silly curly hair yeah
being
i just like cracked up when i walked in
and saw your little curly ass like
sitting
sitting in the captain's chair oh my god
yeah so [ __ ] funny
[Laughter]
looking at her youtube now yeah she's
looking at sherry
oh okay sherry's cool man she's awesome
yeah i love her yeah
she's been over the house
looking she's from tampa though
yeah
danny rolling ghostface says uh how
about that chick that purposely
poured drano in her eyes to blind
herself yeah
see that's what i mean it's like well
it's not so much stupid it's it's a
mental illness yeah and it's just kind
of like she identified as a blind person
so she wanted to [ __ ] make herself
blind that's [ __ ] crazy
that's like that's you have to be like
really [ __ ] up to do something like
that because that's you can't really
undo that now somebody commented i saw
comments about that [ __ ] recently and
they said that she killed herself i
don't know if that's true though oh i
don't know either all right but like i
kind of know you're talking about but i
don't know like all the details so i
don't really like one there's a lot of
people that do weird [ __ ] like the dude
that wanted to become a lion and [ __ ]
just turned himself into a lion using
[ __ ] uh oh well there's a lot of
those like there's like the snake guy
that's like all covered with scales and
it's like he had his tongue split and
stuff i don't honestly killed himself
though oh i mean to that extent it's
like
like i said just like everything else
it's on a spectrum
i don't really have a problem with these
extreme body modifications hey pookie
where you been she's down here by my
foot
i don't have a problem with these
extreme body modifications like if you
want to look like a snake or a lion
whatever man like you do you
um
but
that said there comes a point where
extreme body modification is maybe maybe
not always
uh is maybe a symptom of something else
uh maybe a symptom of particularly when
you have because you remember when we
were watching like that documentary or
whatever like about these women that
just get like bigger and bigger and
bigger bigger like boob implants yeah um
to a point where it's like they can't
even really stand upright anymore
um you know
it's like
up to a certain point fine you know if
that's what you want it to look like
then that's you know like i said it's
your body uh do what you want but
you do have to like take into
consideration that
like at past a certain extreme where
you're like doing harm to yourself right
then maybe
someone should intervene and there's a
there's a significant portion
of bodybuilders um have body dysmorphia
guys like rich piana
what dead by 40 something
yeah so there definitely is
beyond steroids yeah and he was a good
guy everybody liked rich he wasn't a pro
bodybuilder he was a youtuber
and he sold [ __ ] health supplements
but man there was nothing close to
health with what he was doing nothing
you know what i mean yeah that is not
health
jacking yourself up yeah there comes to
a point like up to a point it's fine
everybody's like yeah that's like i said
that's your body do what you want with
it but after a certain point
right oh boy right there
that is about the max
you don't want to get any bigger than
that
any bigger than that it's not health
anymore that'll kill you
your heart can't supply all that
well do you remember all the drugs you
need to maintain that we might have
talked about this on the bodybuilding
show but remember like back in the 90s
because i feel like there was kind of a
trend for just like monstrously
yeah huge and it's to a point where they
were just like
freakish looking um and at that point
it's like look you know a human body
isn't really supposed to look like that
right um and the [ __ ] that you have to
do to get your body to look like that is
probably not good for you like i said
it's your body you're an adult but uh
there comes a point where someone should
be like uh hey man
you're gonna die if you don't stop
[ __ ] doing that yeah you know what i
mean it's just kind of like i mean i
kind of see it on the same spectrum as
like you know
this is like weird to say but somebody
has like an eating disorder it's like
you know you have like anorexia like you
don't eat it's like you know you know
being thin to an extent is good but
right you know if you get too thin
you're gonna die right it's the same
kind of thing you start going beneath
five percent body fat you're [ __ ]
risking your [ __ ] life
and what's funny is that that dude right
there is maybe at about eight percent so
even he would be borderline
i mean you need some fat you need some
fat you do right that's what makes your
brain work correctly
um and like i said i have a you know a
family member that was anorexic
and had to be
force-fed through her nose
um or she would have died
so
you know
but it's like i get it it's a mental
disorder but they know that it's a
mental disorder you can dye it
up to a point
but if you get to a point where your
[ __ ] organs are shutting down you're
growing hair all over your body because
your body's desperately trying to keep
itself warm there's a story like going
live there
on world star somebody just posted a
video of a dude [ __ ] knifing another
dude to death where he was banging the
other guy's wife
jakes
oh florida florida in florida yeah
figures this is how is that dude his
wife you start
you got it on video
yeah [ __ ] florida man is not is a is
a factor because like i said
we're the kind of like the new
california in a certain way well a lot
of people move here from other places so
you kind of it's it's kind of like a you
know everyone's from everywhere else i'm
not i'm from here it's mostly rural and
suburban
and uh it's hot here
um it's kind of it's not a restrictive
environment
and [ __ ] get wild
well something that i've read i mean
from a statistical standpoint that
sounds like it's probably correct
um the reason that you get like more of
these crazy stories out of florida is
because we have the sunshine law
where
you get arrested for a crime uh it's
public knowledge not every state has
that
so if you go around like searching
for crimes uh you're gonna find more of
them from florida just because they
release more of them to the public just
because that's what the law is you don't
have any if you're an adult and you've
been convicted of a crime no matter how
crazy it is um it's public knowledge
it's up on the internet uh you know it's
it's searchable
so
and like i said not every state has that
some of their privacy laws pertaining to
crime are more uh restrictive than ours
so you do kind of see a lot more
stories so i'm not saying like crazy
[ __ ] doesn't happen in other states
obviously it does uh because people are
stupid everywhere um
but you just see more of it out of
florida just because
everything is automatically public they
don't like unless you're a minor
um as far as i can determine but yeah
we've had sunshine last for like a
pretty long time
i'm not from florida i moved here i
[ __ ] loved it uh i lived in
california [ __ ] mississippi
brazil korea all over the world i liked
florida i found to be very special
i liked the people i liked the scene the
vibe here is very positive it's very
[ __ ] fun uh if you have money that
helps that helps everybody that helps
everywhere
being poor sucks
yeah it has one downside it's [ __ ]
hot really hot
through most of the time no not most
it's really about three or four months
out of the year it's really [ __ ] hot
um the rest of the time
it's hot
but then um winter and spring and it's
not that it's it's not it's cool 70s 60s
50s sometimes but it's like it's more
than it's like muggy though yeah it's
humid yeah it's humid which which makes
it feel [ __ ] super hot
um
and then when it gets down to 50 it
feels super [ __ ] cold because it's
humid
it's just bone penetrating
but you just
you just stay in for a couple months out
of the year
honestly most of my childhood you just
stay in yeah like i said what i grew up
in with you know mostly i stayed a lot
at my grandmother's house and her house
was built in 1958 her house was built
with no central air
and the whole time i was growing up it
never had central air it had one window
unit which they installed in the dining
room
so
in the summer so if you're in one of the
back bedrooms which i was um no air
conditioning got back there you didn't
want to leave the windows open because
big giant roaches would fly in yeah um
you know even though there was screen
they'd still like get around
and um so
we didn't really want to do that and
like i said even with the windows open
it didn't really help because there was
no
breeze there's no breeze and even if
there is a breeze it's hot and wet yeah
so amanda says just like tom said in
other streams it's dagobah from star
wars it is it is
like that especially in this deep of the
summer um july and august basically okay
like you know how when you walk into
like a sauna it's like that but all the
time
does it do does it get old seeing old
people everywhere that's not what you
see
i didn't see that many older maybe a
long time ago it was like that
maybe in certain communities but no it's
a young
uh it's a young you just seem like
everybody everybody and it's
white hispanic and black it's it's it's
it's an asian and some age but it's
mostly whites and hispanics with some
blacks
and it's got a good club scene and
and everybody gets along
i didn't see a lot of there isn't a lot
of hatred here everybody's getting along
it's a fun place
it has a
resort a vacation resort slash disney
slash
cocaine cowboy vibe to it it's it's
kind of like cross between california
and maybe like i don't know
vegas
and dagobah
[Laughter]
now see and like uh in columbia it's
it's just depends and it depends on
where you are
there's a lot of diversity even between
even inside a city
danny rowland ghostface said and i'm not
sure if this is a joke or not but he
said are the basements in florida cool
at least yeah we don't generally have to
we don't we don't have basements here
right um you can't really because the of
the water changes
yeah um particularly not it's not as bad
here in like central florida where i
grew up in daytona
um we're right on the coast and we're
right at sea level so honestly like
you'd go out in your yard and dig down
like four feet and there was water yeah
so it's like you can't really
you can't really have a basement
i mean the one place i had that had a
basement with my grandfather's house the
basement was actually half above ground
you know what i mean yeah so it's like
the house was like a little bit above
and then like half of the basement was
like underground so it's like you don't
really see
i know because i know like up north like
a lot of houses have because you know
i've been like visited friends in
baltimore and stuff like that and they
like have you know two-story house and
there's like a basement we don't really
have that here
we don't really have basements you can't
they would flood the whole south has
changed a lot the whole south i mean we
had a cute little lesbian friend
who [ __ ] left here because she didn't
like it and moved to mississippi
to [ __ ] biloxi
on the gulf coast and she loves it there
you know i live there too you know
it's because it's not the same
mississippi as it was the [ __ ]
gulf coast of mississippi is now
the high-end neighborhood of new orleans
that's and that's what it looks like and
that's what it feels like it's very kind
of french colonial looking but it's all
modern it's all rebuilt now casinos
everywhere
you know
yeah well and like i think it's better
it's not the south that you see in in
movies from the 80s well in florida in
particular is kind of like different
because florida
is like i said there's not a lot of
people that are
from here like i am but i don't meet a
lot of people that were born here well
we're in central florida though yeah and
so yeah central florida it's so there's
people moving here from like everywhere
like all over the country
is mississippi
yeah panhandle that's a different that's
like almost like a different state yeah
and um south florida is north cuba it's
central
yeah that's basically a cuban yeah it's
central america and and it works out
good man that's very good well it's been
like that for been like that forever as
long as yeah as long as i can remember
yeah
but you know it's
honestly like i said look at look at
miami look at new pictures of miami it's
a [ __ ] tropical paradise city
skyscrapers with [ __ ] parks and it's
a green city it looks like it's in the
middle of the jungle because it kind of
is
but it's one of the most beautiful
cities in the world
well they're always trying and
particularly because a lot of stuff and
i think i've mentioned this before
orlando in particular like the central
florida area yeah uh i don't know if you
guys know but 40 years ago this was a
[ __ ] swamp yeah until disney came and
started building the park here and then
like all the stuff grew up around it
um so but they actually have tried to
make everything
um you know like the neighborhood where
we live they definitely try to make it
like nice houses and stuff but they
definitely have to try to like surround
it with trees and parkland and trails
and stuff like that so you kind of feel
like you're in a rural environment even
though you're like we're literally like
less than two miles from the freeway
um but they do try to make it seem like
you're out in the woods and it sometimes
it does kind of seem like you're out in
the woods because like i said you get
[ __ ] bears wandering across your
driveway and what not
um
but you know they've done a good job of
like trying to
make everything but like i said that
where we we live is more like an upper
middle class victor goes type of area
florida's the golden girls in disney no
it is not man it is not well in some
places florida's porn for kids well yeah
florida is a [ __ ] porn and drugs and
disney and drugs yeah yeah
and then and then [ __ ] grandparents
goes well isn't covet running [ __ ]
crazy uh our friend toby works at the
hospital florida general hospital he's a
nurse there that's that my leather daddy
buddy and um he said he never noticed
anything unusual there was no it depends
on the police there was no influx of any
sick people
they had a whole [ __ ]
thing when the so-called pandemic first
started intense and [ __ ] nobody came
nothing's going wrong all right
um
the it's normal just normal [ __ ]
nothing's happening um the
and then somebody else was saying um
what what about
oh and don't be bragging about florida
buildings huh yeah yeah yeah yeah that
particular and also we have sinkholes we
have sinkholes that will swallow up it's
like cenotes [ __ ] boom it's like and
all of a sudden
yeah and honestly that can happen
anywhere because like i said we are at
sea level right um and so we don't have
we're not
florida is not like on any bedrock or
anything like that yeah it's basically
just kind of like you know sand and dirt
and then like there's the ocean it's
like right there and it's like there's
not really a lot of [ __ ] underneath like
underlying it so every now and then uh
the earth will decide hey i don't really
like this particular troop and then
it'll be like this big [ __ ] sinkhole
and i'll swallow like all these
so you know what i mean the building
that fell
first of all that was a cocaine era
building that was a cartel building
that's who built that [ __ ]
and they knew that [ __ ] has was falling
for [ __ ] 10 15 years they told those
[ __ ] it was following they
didn't do anything about it
well yeah i mean well i mean i kind of
feel like too that like
people that own the buildings they don't
want to like pay the money right to
upgrade it yeah and evidently rent was
cheap there so people stayed
well
a lot of people don't have a choice yeah
you know what i mean but that building
was falling anyway yeah but like i said
put yourself
put yourself in in the point of view of
someone like me like what if i was
living there and it's like this is super
cheap it's like 600 months like holy
crap this is so cheap and it's like well
you need to move because like blah blah
i'm like yeah i think i'll risk it
because it's like everywhere else is
like twice the money or more right so
it's kind of like you can't really
and you know it's not just that it's not
just the fact can you pay the rent but
you also have to usually pay two or
three months rent uh
up front yeah and a lot of people can't
afford that so
a lot of those people probably didn't
have like a lot of choice yeah just
saying well i would have moved i don't
give a [ __ ] i said this you can just
like sleep out this building is [ __ ]
falling down and they've got jacks on
the outside of it and they're trying to
stuff [ __ ] [ __ ] underneath the
foundation
they all knew everybody that lived there
knew that that building was [ __ ]
coming down and they didn't [ __ ]
hightail it
um although i've i blame the city the
city could have come and should have
come in there and said this building's
condemned you got to get the [ __ ] out of
here
but cocaine and money [ __ ] talks in
florida
in miami miami is not the rest of the
united states it's central america it
just is and you're not going to change
it
they got people running from [ __ ] going
from new york and trying to move in
there to do those new york scams paid
parking and all the [ __ ] new york
toll bridges and [ __ ] all the scams that
new yorkers do and they're getting
blackballed and kicked out of there if
you go to florida understand that that
is cuban
territory that's just what's going to
happen if you play ball with them and
you're like them you know the culture
it's going to be fine but if you go in
there
as a hot shot and throw your weight
around you're going to get black bald
that's just how it is that's that's the
word on the street okay that's what i've
been hearing
but i would love to move to miami
it's hot though
it's even hotter there i know i've been
there yeah grandpa's hammer says sea
rises a few feet from global warming in
the next 20 years will you be underwater
uh daytona will be
uh
orlando well maybe 20 feet
yeah probably probably uh daytona
definitely would be because daytona is
right at sea level that's where i grew
up sea levels haven't changed though
okay no please shut that
i don't know where pookie went to did
she go outside or
i don't know what's going on uh yeah
daytona will totally be underwater
which no big loss
i'm not gonna
i'm not being shitty like seriously a
lot of my family members still live
there but it's like the city is like it
wouldn't be any big loss i'm just saying
uh but you know maybe it i don't know i
kind of feel like
hurricanes we don't get them as bad like
in central florida because we're like
you know several miles off the coast
like an hour and a half off the coast
um but you know victor says tom denies
everything he doesn't like
the same houses on the coast have been
there for [ __ ] 30 40 50 years the sea
level hasn't changed
that is uh not the case they're still
there
i grew up on the coast everything's
still there i grew up on the coast do
you know how much of the beach has like
is gone but the house the beach was much
larger yeah because they were still
there they built the houses a little bit
farther back and actually the farther
you go up a1a
uh they were actually smart enough to
build the houses up on [ __ ] stilts
then you just move the houses back you
know what i mean it's not gonna be like
you're there one day and all of a sudden
the ocean hits you it would take a long
time kanavatsalan says uh his picture
says tom is the earth round or flat i
ain't worried about that the earth is
[ __ ] flat yeah of course
um connor watson says now you all think
you're smart look man [ __ ] you can't
you can't control the weather hush yeah
kanavatsan says cool shirt jenny are
those the ones you're making no i didn't
make this one i actually got this one
from uh bustedtees.com
uh i just
you know i just saw it and i thought it
was funny so i bought it
um so we're gonna talk about some
[ __ ] cases about because like look
look how much i still have to
do
and you're
doing your shenanigans
[Laughter]
oh i know what you talked about oh
are your feelings hurt i put that [ __ ]
in time his feelings are hurt i put that
[ __ ] in time out
do vaccines cause autism says victory uh
i don't know depend on the vaccine uh no
they don't but uh thank you everything
we depend on thank you for playing
thank you for playing but no all right
all right so let's talk about some cases
these most of the cases that i wanted to
talk about on the show like i said
i feel like the
the most popular case popular that's a
weird word to use but you know what i
mean the most well-known case of munch
house and by proxy
is um you know the kind of like uh gypsy
rosely like that that kind of like
whatever dd blanchard case
if we don't get to that because i think
we talked about on the sidetrack show
like a while back but
i do have that in here so we might get
to it again but we'll see i put some
other ones in here maybe we mentioned
this on the side track show i can't
really remember this it was a while back
but i have more like details about the
[ __ ]
david he's drunk with power yeah right
you of course
[Laughter]
look man [ __ ] and i went to the [ __ ]
coast of mississippi the coastline's
exactly the same as it was a little boy
all the buildings are still there that's
so scientifically
accurate i only care what happens in my
lifetime i'll give a [ __ ] about all your
little [ __ ] well yeah we know that
yeah okay that's why we don't listen to
you yeah
y'all are gonna die anyway
okay well you know bro yeah i don't care
about your children either that's nice
if you had children it's on you
you're being so pleasant thomas
oh my goodness the coastline was the
same
okay yeah all right yeah the same
casinos were in the same spots they were
when i was a little kid they're there
you sit there and try to rationalize it
all you want man the [ __ ] casino was
still there tom's like i saw a thing and
therefore it's true
everywhere yeah well i don't care
yeah i know i don't care
well then why should i want to listen to
you then no no one else you're worried
about things outside the scope of your
control
yeah okay can i talk about like the
actual topic of this what you want to do
yeah yeah you're getting like a little
no i'm not you're getting no i'm not i'm
having fun with your stupid hair i got a
[ __ ] wig on me talking about
with your big old forehead yeah
it's not a forehead it's just
it's a wig it's just a head it's just a
[ __ ] head
it's a five head it's a six head it's a
ten head and forty hit
all the way back
oh now he's gonna pull it way forward
pull it all the way up to your eyebrows
that's there you go all of a sudden i'm
a neanderthal i'm going to put that [ __ ]
down here like that now you kind of look
like a grandma yeah
[Laughter]
he looks like a crab
david june says i wish i could put
people in timeout do you want me to make
you a moderator and then you can put
people in timeout like if you're like do
you want to kind of say thomas just
projecting projecting masculinity that's
the next pronunciation projecting
that's pretty good man
yeah i thought i made you a mod so you
can be able you can put people in
timeout if you want i do like don't like
no i'm not talking to you i'm talking to
david june he could do what he wants
yeah that's what i said i was pretty
sure i had made him a mod before see i
don't talk in there so they can't put me
in timeouts
no one wants to put you in timeout
if i wanted to put you in my timeout i'd
have to like punch you in the face and
like knock you out or something because
you're not going to stop talking
otherwise but yeah you're not talking
well yeah like i said yeah he's a mod so
you can you can put people in timeout if
you want to like don't abuse the power
though i mean yeah you can if you watch
it it doesn't it doesn't like last that
long i don't think
don't they when you put somebody in time
out it's only what like 70 minutes
projecting projecting it's international
you are projecting yeah yeah all right
please like can we get back to the topic
yeah yeah yeah yeah
are you sure yeah
are you sure yeah
projecting
he has this habit of like
this is why i keep going are you sure
are you sure because like i open my
mouth to talk and then he keeps on
talking yeah i don't know
all right so can we talk about okay so
we're going to talk about some [ __ ] now
so sh
thank you
all right so we're going to talk about
some cases of
munchausen syndrome and munchausen
cinder by proxy right
so let's talk about
mary beth tinning
now
here's this woman here
supposedly and this is very common with
mer with uh munchas and by proxy
supposedly a very devoted mother because
that's another thing and i don't
remember if i mentioned this or not but
that's another thing they've noticed
is that people that have particularly
munches and by proxy
um
they're like super super like attentive
to
the child
uh or victim if you'd prefer
uh what other people are watching
when other people are not watching like
if you have a camera on them or
something like that they get like super
neglectful and maybe even abusive when
no one else is looking at them so all of
their stuff is like performative
so to an extent like i said they are
aware of
the image that they're projecting to
other people
so mary beth tinning
uh she supposedly okay so from the 13
uh years between 1972 and 1985
she lived in chennai
new york and she lost
uh you know nine
babies who died uh you know babies and
children
now
like i said i kind of feel like 1972
1985 no one was real hip to
this munchausen by proxy thing
so
sadly
it took a pretty long time for
authorities to like twig onto what this
[ __ ] was doing right
um you know and like i said i hate to be
dismissive i know it's a mental illness
but
on the other hand uh you're also like
killing your children
so
you know it's kind of a whole thing
so basically uh her daughter jennifer uh
was born in january of 1972.
uh my name is jennifer and i was also
born in 1972. so you know it's kind of a
thing there
she was eight days old
and
died
now
this particular death they did an
autopsy on the child i'm not entirely
sure why because i don't know if they
automatically do autopsies particularly
back in 1972 do they automatically do an
autopsy and a baby that died just
i'm not really sure but they did an
autopsy
and they uh concluded that this baby had
died of meningitis
now because this baby had never been
taken home
um
the authorities
retrospectively
said probably
uh this baby actually did have some
disease and like died of natural causes
if you want to call it that
uh because in light of what happened
later
could have been but like i said the you
know the mom didn't really have any
chance to like take this baby home and
like [ __ ] with it you know what i mean
she didn't leave the hospital the baby
died
you know [ __ ] happens and maybe it was
natural causes which is sad
but
could be
uh that that wasn't the case but i don't
know
allegedly
so
um
about three weeks after that
apparently the baby that had been born
had an older brother who was two years
old named joseph tenning jr
now this two-year-old three weeks after
his baby
sister
died
um
he also died he was actually dead on
arrival
uh in ellis hospital at chennai in
chenectady new york
now at this point like i said no one is
suspecting anything right even though
like she just had a baby the baby died
apparently of meningitis
uh which can happen three weeks later
her two-year-old
dies
of what they think is a viral infection
and a seizure disorder
they didn't do an autopsy though because
like i said at this point they don't
they're not really suspicious like i
said this is the early 1970s
i don't think
munchausen syndrome was really that
widely
uh talked about or known about
um and
you know like i said it's easy and
retrospect to say like oh my god like
nine of her [ __ ] kids died spoiler
alert but it's like
you know at this point you know she had
one kid that died then oh my god like a
later one died and it's just like oh
it's like really tragic so i kind of
feel like that was kind of the issue
that was going on here so i'm not going
to [ __ ] on authorities for not
being real uh you know
upon the game of what was going on
so this two-year-old dies
supposedly from a viral infection or
seizure disorder but they didn't do an
autopsy
six weeks after that
another child
barbara attending who was four
she died on march 20th
now they did do an autopsy on her but
they couldn't really find any obvious
cause of death
so at this point they said well maybe it
was a cardiac arrest maybe it was just
one of those things
so they attributed it to
that now at this point
you know the hospital was getting a
little bit suspicious so they did
actually report this death to the police
because they said look this woman just
had a baby the baby died and then her
two-year-old died and then this kid died
too and that's a little weird so they
did actually report that to the police
but the police kind of looked into it
sort of half-assedly allegedly and
didn't really do anything about it
because they kind of went and talked to
like the hospital doctors and they were
just kind of like yeah we
we can't really you know we can't find
any evidence that anybody like did
anything to cause it
so there was that
now
later on this woman had another baby uh
timothy now when this baby was two weeks
old he also died at the same hospital
and the doctors couldn't figure out what
the cause was um so they said well maybe
it's sids you know sudden infant death
syndrome which is kind of like
it's one of those kind of diseases where
it's like it's not really a disease but
it's just kind of like
this is what we
say when it's like baby suddenly dies
and we can't figure out why you know
what i mean it's one of those so they
attributed it to that
uh so later on uh september 2nd 1975
another one of her kids nathan
uh died at five months old
and they did do an autopsy on this kid
and they said the cause of death was
probably pulmonary edema
now another kid holy crap
she's really like racking up some kid
deaths this is like really depressing
so another kid died uh
almost four years later february of 1979
um
mary tinning she died at six months uh
or she died like after her third
birthday rather she was three years old
like three and a half years old and she
died and they also called that sids even
though
she was three and a half years old which
that seems a little old for sids but
okay but that was they couldn't like
figure out like what had killed her so
they just determined that
um and then another kid died too
like about a year later
uh jonathan who was three months old and
he died in march 24th 1980 and again
they could find no cause of death
now at this point for whatever reason
because like i said [ __ ]
uh you know the the kind of like system
of adoption and all the so that they
don't really like talk to each other and
stuff so somebody somewhere
let this
woman or this family like adopt more
children
so
they adopt another
daughter named tammy lynn tinning
who was three months old
now at in december of 1985 this baby
was found
unconscious in her bed with blood on the
pillow
now
the mom
takes her to st claire's hospital
uh but at that point it was already too
late to save her
now this is a different hospital than
the than earlier and like i said this is
several years later so it's kind of like
i don't know i feel like i'm gonna like
when i'm reading a litany of it like i
said it's like nine [ __ ] kids
uh it sounds like oh my god why didn't
somebody do something but you have to it
was like months and years like in
between this [ __ ] happening so
you're gonna get like different nurses
different doctors different people like
working on this so it's like they
wouldn't necessarily remember like
associate [ __ ] with the you know it's
just like [ __ ] happens
so
she gets brought in she dies
and
she her death is also attributed to sids
however at this point they did actually
alert the authorities because i guess
somebody remembered something hey this
[ __ ] has been in here like a whole
bunch of times and
maybe somebody should like look into it
so they started an investigation
uh so mary beth tinning the mom she gets
arrested in early february of 1986.
now when she gets arrested
uh she actually did confess
to
killing
tammy lynn who was the adopted baby
um by pressing a pillow over her face
because she kept like crying and fussing
and she was like trying to get her to be
quiet i guess that's kind of what her
angle was
uh when she was in custody she also
confessed to killing
timothy and nathan two of her earlier
kids
but
uh vehemently denied killing
any of the numerous other ones
but timothy and nathan she apparently um
you know came right out and said and
this is a quote i smothered them with a
pillow because i'm not a good mother
so you know uh yeah that's what she said
now in 87 july of 87 uh she actually
ended up getting convicted of
second-degree murder uh in only
one of the deaths uh tambie linds who
was the three-month-old baby that she
said that she had smothered with a
pillow
um but she did get actually she only got
second degree murder because the jurors
apparently were not convinced that she
had deliberately killed the child
um
they thought that there was something
the matter with her in the sense that
like i said i don't i don't think they
said this at the trial but they did like
kind of imply that maybe she had like
some kind of mental illness like i said
munch hasn't sent her by proxy and that
was like making her do these kind of
things so they kind of like
gave her a lesser sentence because of
that
um
so it's really weird because they asked
the husband about this
and i was reading this article about it
that said um the husband joseph seemed
said quote seemed bewildered by the
whole affair
uh apparently like so the media like
asked him about um hey how do you feel
about your wife like essentially
allegedly uh killing like eight or nine
of the kids and like is that weird or
whatever
um
and he said
and this is apparently a direct quote he
said
you have to trust your wife
she has her things to do and as long as
she gets them done you don't ask
questions
what does that mean i don't know like as
long as your laundry gets done you don't
ask questions as long as the babies
aren't crying like you don't ask
questions what the [ __ ] does that mean
so it's like i kind of feel like i don't
think i mentioned this earlier but
they said that one thing that was real
prevalent
among people among women particularly
that had munchausen by proxy was that
the fathers of the children
were usually if they were present were
real real like distant or uninvolved in
like the children's care so like they
had no idea like what the [ __ ] was going
on with the [ __ ] and they're just like
yeah that's that's a woman's job she
will let that we'll let her figure it
out uh which in this case is probably
the worst possible thing to do
so that those dudes are not very
intensive to the wife either so maybe
that might have accelerated their desire
to grandstand
well yeah and i think that might be a
factor because a lot of the women that
had that present with this disorder so
like i said i don't this is like a
general it's usually like ninety percent
much as my proxy at least
ninety percent
uh or women that are doing this to their
children uh and the other 10 you know
usually unmarried dudes uh between like
30 and 50 years old
so i kind of feel like and a lot of the
women that present with it had a lot of
history of neglect or a history of
sexual abuse emotional abuse things like
that so
it's almost kind of like they're getting
attention like the only way they know
how
i suppose or the only way they think
they can get attention either by making
themselves ill
or
by you know in in the case of munchausen
by proxy making their children ill and
making everyone feel sympathy for them
and also
uh you know at the same time
making them
seem like mother of the year
because look at this burden i have to
bear
and i'm just i'm this doting mother
that's taking care of this you know kid
that has cancer or whatever
and you know look at how like you know
conscientious i am like taking care of
so so it's all kind of like trying to
get validation
so
i kind of feel like that's where a lot
of it is coming from so like i said i
think that's why it's pretty common that
in what that when there's a family
dynamic presence in the sense that
there's actually a father there because
a lot of times there's not uh but if the
father is present he's usually one of
those yeah i'm gonna let the i'm gonna
let her take care of the kid type of
situations or he's not really around
all that much
um and so like you said it might be a
case of she's trying to get attention
from him as well yeah with a brush you
know
what do you mean brush there's a brush
right here
i just bought a brand new hairbrush yeah
there you go
well my my old one was like really like
[ __ ] up and i was looking at it the
other day and i'm like oh my god
you don't think about buying a new
hairbrush but
i just thought one the other day so i
just bought one
no i need that yes oh i thought you were
done with it no no no no tammy says
damn he said team
said that you need to brush that wig
well yeah he never does though he
doesn't understand that it's not like
you can't just like throw that [ __ ] on
you have to groom it just like you'd
groom regular hair see
david's gonna be listening to us i guess
while he's on his trip okay okay
tila says jen tom needs his own brush he
doesn't have his own anything he doesn't
have his own phone he doesn't have his
own brush you can't understand my man's
success is judged by if he doesn't have
a phone and he doesn't have any [ __ ]
keys to anything you know he's made it
he's made it
well you do have keys for things but
pookie too yeah yeah right yeah just for
like some motorcycles
he's got a big old gigantic key ring he
works for somebody else
i don't know i can see like a really lot
of flaws in that in that scenario how
many keys do you think elon musk has
just to his car
and his house probably that's one dude
how many keys you think bill gates has
i can do this [ __ ] all day long
well well the thing about it is all
hypothetical because i don't know how
many keys but i don't think he might
have a [ __ ]
i mean you would think somebody that was
that successful it's like i'm not gonna
farm out my [ __ ] to like other people
because they might like [ __ ] steal
for me so i'm gonna have the keys of the
[ __ ] i mean that's what i would think
but i'm a control freak so you know
uh i mean you know yeah he didn't have
his own phone he doesn't have his own
phone because he just expects me to
do like secretary [ __ ] i had a phone for
[ __ ] years and nobody ever called me
on it and i very rarely ever well now
it's like now every time the man clinic
the man clinic calls and then i have to
like go all the way to walk around
hey they called you you have to go pick
your [ __ ] up now it's like i got this
right here get your own phone i got this
i can call another [ __ ] or you
know over [ __ ] but you know if you don't
telephone that's no i'm not that old
come on
well i don't like having a phone either
but with my office i have to have a
phone because it's the office because
your people call me yeah like the va
clinic calls me the videos you know it's
all like an office phone that's how i
look at it we don't talk on it
we don't talk on it it's all a scam they
try to get you to have that damn phone
yes and you don't talk on it but they
want you to have a damn number to open
up accounts and [ __ ] and says what do i
want to [ __ ] phone for i don't talk
like that goddamn i don't talk on the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is [ __ ] obsolete
for you because they're all calling me
nobody needs it the next thing you're
gonna do next thing that's gonna happen
is they're gonna say what kind of
typewriter you have
i don't have a typewriter oh you have a
typewriter we can't do business with you
see david june made the same joke i did
tom doesn't have keys anymore because
pookie stole his motorcycle oh that's
one exactly it's just one key we don't
know where find it i'll find out we
don't know where she put that i'll find
it eventually i'm i've i got out of the
box
i'm convinced that she took it and stuck
it i think she didn't take it
there's no other explanation like i said
everything else the end of it's rubber
and chewy so that's kind of like her
thing she took it to go chew on it she
took it to chew on it probably because
she likes somewhere around here
so yeah so like i said we're talking
about mary beth tenning who
like i said uh she only got convicted
really uh of the one even though she
confessed to like killing two other of
her nine children if you're keeping
track at home uh but she did actually
get incarcerated uh in bedford hills new
york and she was denied parole six times
but eventually was granted parole not
that long ago july
2018
and got released in august of 2018. so
she's actually been out for a couple of
years i don't know where she has been
subsequently if i was her i'd probably
be like keeping a low profile but you
know
but yeah so she did go to prison for
actually a very long time
so now let's talk about
uh
lacey spears
now this woman
is i believe this is one that's uh this
is [ __ ] up but she's kind of known as
salt mom
um because they did a whole show like on
investigation discovery about her but
just laughing at what they're saying
oh tammy says look at look at how pretty
is when he brushes and [ __ ] t goes
look at all that narcissism and [ __ ]
well you know yeah yeah of course it's
look this is part 10 10 years [ __ ]
this is part of the reason why you all
watch this show is this [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] the [ __ ] i do because you are a
ridiculous person
that's how it is
you're entertainingly ridiculous yeah
stop this [ __ ] no need for me too says i
saw a video of a dog stealing a phone
see i wouldn't trust like honestly if if
something
large went missing i would more blame
beijing because
she like i said she has a thing
she likes little stuffed animals
and she carries them around the house
and her mouth she doesn't hide them
though she like wants everybody to see
him she lays them out in the middle of
living rooms like there it is that's for
you
pookie is more kind of like hey i like
this but i don't think she thinks about
hiding it i think she's like hey i'm
going to take this over here and like
and then she forgets and then she chews
on it a while and then forgets about her
like kicks it under the bed or something
like that
um she's not trying to hide it from me
she's just like wants to play with it
but then she just gets bored so you know
we'll we'll probably find it one of
these days
i i just like wonderful i won't be able
to ride that motorcycle until i find it
i mean i got other motorcycles like a
ride but i'm not i don't want i got that
other one but well it's like i don't
know like you kept coming here today
it's like well where's that i'm like
what do you want me to do about it i
don't know where to go that closet apart
for the look
i mean i didn't take it
i haven't seen it it has to be here or
the motorcycle wouldn't be here
well yeah i know that yeah but it's like
that's
i i have no idea where it could be i
have no idea i haven't seen it last time
i saw it it was on the nightstand on
your side of the bed right that's the
last time i saw it and honestly like
pookie is really really into
poking her little head up above on your
side of the nightstand and being like
taking a little paw and like pulling
stuff off
just to be a butthole
uh so i kind of suspect that that might
have been what happened to it
i gotta move this up
move this up so to the caucasian level
see
i don't know your forehead looks kind of
big that's how that's that's
there you go
that's about it tila said you should get
a metal detector and go around the house
with it yeah
no no do you think that might be
anything no
well yeah but everything's metal here
it's not it's not i'll find it
we'll see
all right so like i said we're talking
about lacey spears let me let me like do
this [ __ ] please how much do we have
left a lot [ __ ]
i might take my clothes off
really are we making any money are we
really we're not making any money man i
gotta get these guys to [ __ ] pay me
man [ __ ] take my clothes off and [ __ ]
with my [ __ ] wagon
okay zach hasn't sent me any
money victor not sending me any money
gays he is victor sent some money yo
daddy okay that's right but that was
probably like for my cool
[ __ ] in timeout
you didn't put victory in timeout use it
for a few minute few minutes you didn't
put victor in timeout that was somebody
else okay
i'm [ __ ] just having fun man don't
take any of this just said if i put you
all in the [ __ ] timeout i'm just
[ __ ] with you
i put regulars in timeout
and then they try to put me in timeout
because some of them but you can't put a
moderator in timeout moderators are
trying to put each other in timeout you
can't do it
you can't do it i just i could like i
could like ban you from the from the
chat though okay i'll still be here on
the screen
i would still be here on the screen
like i said i might well i'll also i
could like put roofies in your drink and
you would fall asleep this doesn't
matter
i still wake up
i wake up and i was like what the [ __ ]
was that hiccup's amani thank you very
much thank you very much
oh yeah
money thank you taylor keep your clothes
on
yeah yeah
[ __ ] awesome
i love you too that's all you have to do
is threaten to take your clothes off
hey you yeah they're like no keep those
off keith's
[Laughter]
that's probably like a good strategy you
should probably do i know what i'm doing
i'm shaking them up stirring them up
oh my god
all right so what was that okay
i'm talking about lacy spears like i
said she's better known as salt mom
which is [ __ ] up
when you hear about why she's called
that
so
this happened back in 2014
and this is all about
her son who was five years old
whose name was uh garnett paul thompson
spears
and he basically
died from being poisoned by
table salt that was injected and they're
pretty sure
yeah [ __ ]
so you know this [ __ ] needed her ass
beat
like i said i know it's a mental illness
i'm trying not to get like angry about
it but god damn it like i said do that
[ __ ] to yourself fine
but
you're doing it to a little kid holy
[ __ ] crap and it's like it's sad
because it's like did you guys remember
we reviewed that movie it's i think it's
on netflix or hulu i can't remember but
it's called run
and it's sort of loosely kind of based
on like a case of munchausen by proxy
which is like a mom
that
told her daughter her whole life that
like she couldn't walk and she couldn't
she had all these diseases and stuff
except she totally didn't um which is
kind of very very loosely based on the
dd blanchard gypsy rose blanchard case
um but it's like a pretty good movie if
you like but it's a [ __ ] up [ __ ]
scenario it's [ __ ] up
okay so lacey spears uh was actually
from alabama
and then she gave birth to
uh garnett who was her son when she was
only like in her early 20s
now then she ended up like moving to
florida
florida man again
uh with her grandmother
and then moved back to new york thank
you david june where's my pizza tila
okay tina says more for more where this
comes from keep them all on board
she's [ __ ] funny don't worry about it
don't do it look don't worry about it
zach i'm just [ __ ] with you bro i'm
just [ __ ] with you
he just [ __ ] with everybody don't
it's all fun and games i mean even
though i don't know
and then [ __ ] khan's going later on
tom keep project projecting project with
a y projecting masculinity yeah yeah
[ __ ] right
he's trying very hard just projecting
masculinity he's trying very hard yeah
yeah i'm trying i gotta try give him
some leeway well you do you do oh is
that what you think
yeah you are you are trying very hard
i'm trying i'm not trying
this is all natural uh-huh okay it is
all natural you just tell yourself that
all right what the [ __ ] are you talking
about this [ __ ] is trying to okay okay
all right okay you want another drink
are you good uh no
no i still got that all right i still
got some where's my brush
where's my brush do you it's gonna be my
brush when i ask for it
why don't you get your armpit that's
some [ __ ] that's gonna be a [ __ ]
shirt guess what it's mine when i asked
for it get yourself it's right there no
i just want it it's right there
it's your own brush i just bought that
[ __ ] and it's brand new i'm gonna wear
this [ __ ] out i have seriously when we
go to the movies i'm gonna wear this i
have seriously only brushed my hair with
that one time because i just got it this
morning what would you do if i wore this
to a theater
nothing no i think you think i think i'd
pass do you think they'd really think
that was my hair
no one would even look at you sideways
they would even look sideways you don't
think no because you wear them nobody
notices no
i think they would know i think they
would go that's not his hair
i don't think anybody would think about
it really i think you're overestimating
how much people think about you tom
[Laughter]
no i just think it'd be funny to wear
this [ __ ] in public is to see how you it
doesn't look that weird that's what i
mean it's not like you're wearing a
[ __ ] wig that's like a mozart wig
with like a [ __ ] ship or a swan yeah
i know that i know obviously that's fake
that could be your real hair
so you get
no one's thinking about it everybody's
just like oh well supposed to switch out
if i said like okay i i'm projecting
myself into an employee of amc theaters
or whatever
it's like i wouldn't even like look i
don't even barely look at people anyway
like in my day-to-day life i'm just like
whatever like you're just a blur
so it's like and and if you work in
retail you look at people even less
because people are the worst so it's
just kind of like you don't even want to
look at people do you don't notice do
you want to get that amc [ __ ] deal
back again i don't know i'm thinking
about it
we might we might all right at least
they didn't like do it on like
you know without telling everybody right
you know that would be uncool but uh
yeah so i don't know like no like i said
it just looks like your hair it doesn't
really look like
i mean that one does right the other
one's done i mean obviously if you were
like the [ __ ] michael caine wig
everyone would think you look like a
[ __ ] mental patient yeah but that one
actually just like looks like real hair
so yeah so where was i okay so
lacey spears like i said she was in her
early 20s uh she moves to florida to
live with her grandma with her son
garnet or garnett i'm not really sure
where the emphasis is there
then she moved back to new york to go to
a community college now
it seems that she kind of got into like
telling people falsehoods uh right when
she moved back to new york
basically i'm not really sure like who
the dad was or what the dad did but she
started telling people
that
the dad of the kid was actually a cop
and he had died in a car accident and
i'm assuming that that is not the case
uh so that maybe the dad was still alive
she wasn't talking to him it was a
one-night stand she'd remember who it
was i don't really know but she kind of
like started
fabricating this narrative about like
the dad
so um
basically
you know what the real story was was
like the dude that was the dad was like
just like a friend of hers like i said
that she had kind of like had sex with
and it's like he kind of wanted to hey
that's my kid and she was like yeah no
thanks and she didn't want anything to
do with them so she just like started
telling everybody that he was dead which
you know that's [ __ ] up
um so
she to an extent like i said i feel like
there's a lot of stuff like
women that have
because like 90 of the people that they
know that have munchausen syndrome like
as in
they make themselves ill
are women um you know 10 of them are
single men though like single white men
from 30 to 50 not young they're like
middle aged
so
she kind of started off with this thing
where
because i feel like some women that have
that to start with when they have kids
then they start imposing it on their
children so it's almost kind of like
they're
you know taking the burden off
themselves and like putting it on
someone which is [ __ ] up because it's
kind of like
well like i said it's bad enough you're
like doing [ __ ] to yourself like hurting
yourself but now you're like
fobbing that off on like another
person who didn't ask for that so
again very [ __ ] up
so
even before he was born or even when he
was still like a kid her her child um
she still she did the same kind of stuff
that would be associated with uh
munchausen she like faked illnesses
um she would do other [ __ ] like
she pretended like other kids were her
kids
like i guess like in other situations oh
yeah that's my kid over there when that
totally wasn't her kid she would do that
kind of stuff
um you know and uh so the thing about it
is that
she
so when she had the kid she started a
blog and i know there's a whole
subculture of
mommy blogs
which are kind of like which okay
i'm not going to [ __ ] on it too much
because yeah like i understand that like
you know women have kids and it's like
you know maybe sometimes it's like oh
they're clueless or they want to know
like what's going on like how do i like
what's the best ideas just like
everything else it's just like you know
you're looking for information but there
is
kind of like a sub subculture of this
mommy blogger thing
that's really a little bit uh toxic
let's let's give it that word and i kind
of feel like
she was definitely in that line
um because she basically started a blog
about how her kid
had all of these health problems
and she's like writing this blog
pretty much
you know cataloging
all of the health problems that he had
and what she was doing about it
uh spoiler alert the kid didn't really
have any health problems uh she was just
inventing them
and
making it seem like much worse than she
was and making it seem like
she was this big it's almost kind of
like this weird like martyr complex i
kind of feel like there's kind of some
overlap there you know what i'm saying
where it's just kind of like
oh my god my kid has all these problems
and i'm i'm so selfless that i'm like
taking care of this it's it's that kind
of [ __ ] like i said i don't think
they're completely conscious of it but
there definitely is an aspect of that
now sadly
her son uh garnett paul thompson uh
ended up dying
uh january 2014 when he was five years
old
now
what they suspected that she had been
doing
was that they thought that she had been
putting
excess
excessive amounts of salt in his feeding
tube
which
isn't it scary how easy it is to just
like kill somebody like that holy crap
all you have to do is like yeah all you
have to do is just like take somebody
especially if it's like a little kid or
something but even an adult it would
kill an adult if you put enough of it in
there it's like all you have to do is
like sneak into their hotel room and
like
please don't do this i'm just saying
that all you have to do is like sneak in
their hotel room
or their hospital room and like put
salt in it like a bunch of salt you
could do it with sugar you could do it
yeah you could do it with anything which
like i said
humans are so [ __ ] fragile yeah and
they probably wouldn't catch you
although they did catch her because
they had a camera
like in his room i think because he was
having seizures and stuff it not because
they were suspicious of her necessarily
but um you know they just were
monitoring him because of other reasons
but they saw her
coming in there
and taking him to the bathroom
and it looked like that she had
a cup in her hand that had like a bunch
of salt in it so he so maybe she was
like feeding it to him and the kid was
like five he didn't know any better
right so you know they thought that
maybe like i said that that was the
evidence that they had and when he died
like they did the autopsy and they're
like okay well um you know the the level
of sodium like in his bloodstream is
like way higher than it ought to be
so they kind of like put two and two
together
and said that uh it's very likely that
she was just like feeding this kid like
abs you know excessive like amounts of
so he was swallowing it
yeah
either that or she was like putting in
his feeding tube like when they weren't
looking
um so you know like in in his uh you
know the gastrointestinal like you know
the feeding tube
so i'd kill that [ __ ] i mean yeah
and they did think too they thought it
was interesting that the couple times
that she took him to the bathroom with
this cup that looked like it had salt in
it uh you know as soon as he came out
like he did he'd start
having these symptoms that's another um
that's another way they diagnose
munchausen syndrome by proxy um you know
as it happens
is
you know if the kid
is sick every time the mom is around
uh but then when the mom's not around
all the symptoms disappear
that's another thing that's like a kind
of a red flag
so
you know that that was another thing too
she was like always around because they
tend to be
when they bring their kids into the
hospital they tend to be like very like
super super like attentive and super
conscientious and they won't leave the
kid alone uh which is one thing that
they look out for
because
they know that when they're not around
the kid anymore like if the kid is
you know taken out of their custody for
a short amount of time um then the
symptoms will disappear because you know
the mom is not administering
this [ __ ] to them anymore
so that's kind of another thing that
they look for
now she ended up getting uh
she was guilty of second-degree murder
now she got 20 years to life
um
it's interesting because the judge
even though her defense tried to argue
it's like hey all you have is like video
of me taking the kid into the bathroom
with a cup that you thought was salt
and then
you know he had a weirdly high sodium
content in the blood you know which is
which shouldn't have happened uh you
know
probably like you know depending on like
the disease that he had and um you know
the fact that he became violently ill
both times like after she shook him in
the bathroom
so and you know and like i said they
started to suspect that but defense
attorneys you know try to argue that
it's like well that's not enough
evidence to like to convict her on but
the judge still did convict her he
didn't give her the maximum sentence
um because he did really seem to realize
that she probably did have munchausen
cinder by proxy
um but he still gave her like i said 20
years to life because that's still
murder
uh you know
even if it's second degree
uh so she is actually uh she's 33
she's in her 30s nowadays and um she's
still in prison
uh early as possible release date june
of 2034
uh even though she's
says that she didn't have anything to do
with it uh you know but
i stomp on her head
yeah yeah [ __ ] her
feeding that kid salt
can you imagine no yeah i just can't
imagine i'm just like i don't know it's
just kind of like
you don't normally want to hit on a
woman you don't want to hit a woman but
i'd beat that bitch's ass
well some people i don't even i don't
care what gender they are some people
neither ask his ass
yeah grantham's hammer said when i was a
cop we really didn't personally care
whether adults killed adults we cared
greatly when adults hurt or killed kids
yeah which i yeah that's kind of as it
should be yeah i don't care either as
long as as long as i mean it depends it
depends on who the adult is it depends
on what we're talking about as long as
they're both combatants if they're in
the [ __ ] drug crate trade and they're
[ __ ] trapped they're trying to or
they're just like fighting or something
like that it's like yeah that's bad but
that's been going on since the dawn of
man back on the [ __ ] 201 with the
[ __ ] apes with the [ __ ] the
monolith and the [ __ ] but they were
doing that [ __ ] back then but you know
but then you have situations where like
some dude just jumping out from a bush
and like dragging an innocent woman like
into the [ __ ] bushes there are
certain things something else there are
certain things that violate
the normal inborn human instincts
and this whole thing about
murdering children
during the nurturing phase no
no no
you know especially if it's the mother
you know
i mean since the dawn of man
back during all that tribal warfare
they'd wipe out entire villages and
children were also in those villages
sometimes although sometimes they
actually saved the children and
recruited them that was going on even in
the 1800s you know i mean on the great
plains
the lakota indians if they would wipe
out a damn
bunch of settlers you know or pioneers
and wagons they didn't kill children
they usually took them
and raised them as their own
you know they're people you know they
can be useful they haven't been turned
into enemy people at this point so
indians did that a lot
and they did it to each other too
um
so you know but
the mom killing the the her own children
for her own attention now come on
and like i said i know
yeah i know that it's subconscious i
know that it's a mental illness yeah but
that doesn't that doesn't on the other
hand a lot of serial killers have a
mentality list too and that doesn't
really excuse me mental illness doesn't
really excuse it it explains it i don't
it doesn't excuse me yeah
exactly it doesn't excuse it yeah a
mental illness doesn't exempt you from
the punishment and the punishment should
just be liquidation you don't need
people like that
i mean like i said it depends on what
the mental illness is like if it can be
like some people i don't have a problem
if they're really [ __ ] up i don't
really bother like you know you can just
put like put them in the hospital and
like try to treat them or whatever but
it's just kind of like why would you
bother uh well honestly i don't i don't
know it's just it's a
you know it's a sliding scale
um i'm more of the thing where it's just
kind of like look if you're so mentally
ill that you don't know what you're
doing is wrong you gotta go yeah then
well no that's not what i was gonna say
but you finished my sadness but you know
what i mean that's not what i was gonna
say i was actually gonna say those
people can't help it that's something
else if you absolutely know what you're
doing is wrong and you're doing it
anyway and you don't give a [ __ ] about
it those people i don't have a problem
with like wiping those people out i'm
going to say both of them both of them
gotta go
but like i go in some way or another you
can't have them in society
right i know that but i'm just saying
that it's like it like i said it's just
like we were talking about earlier it
depends on the individual it depends on
the individual and like i said it's you
know i was watching that documentary
about [ __ ] dennis nilsson earlier who
obviously knew what he was doing was bad
uh and then tried to like pull some uh
self-aggrandizing
uh
narrative about you know like
exaggerating how
i don't know he was almost trying to
like make himself a romantic figure in
some way
and
that dude i don't have any problem just
like hitting that dude in the head with
a brick and just like [ __ ] not even
worried about it anymore like i said if
you have a mental illness if you have
some kind of like but that's not your
fault
i'm not saying like the outcome is good
i'm just saying it's not your fault
entirely so that should be a mitigating
circumstance that's all i'm saying if
you absolutely know what you're doing is
bad and you do it anyway and you don't
feel bad about it then i don't feel bad
about like [ __ ] just you know
shooting you like a rabid dog honestly
but um you know what i mean so so it's
kind of like like i said the gray area
so let's talk about this woman let me
tell you something before we go
part of the human condition
is there has to be people in this
[ __ ] world and grandpa is going to
tell you this you know i'm from the
soldier class he's from the law
enforcement class
there's
there's a certain
class of people in this world who they
were born
in a way to where you have to [ __ ]
regulate
you know what i mean
and the average person has to understand
regulation
and you must regulate you know what i
mean you can't have these
random [ __ ] doing [ __ ] well
everybody can't just run around doing
whatever they want to do it's an
internal
instinct though
i'm talking about to regulate
you're talking about a very
sophisticated system that we have here
in the united states it's not like this
in other countries
in other countries they'd see that they
would just [ __ ] kill that person all
right and that's the way it's been for
thousands and thousands of years
you just can't let that exist
here you're gonna [ __ ] involve all
these professions and [ __ ] to okay to
get to make it official as if they
[ __ ] know what the [ __ ] they're doing
you know
in a way like well is if you know can
you have people just run around do
whatever they want to do yeah you can
there's a lot of places that are like
that brazil's like that
you just do whatever you want to do
but you do pay
you eventually pay if you're bad it
catches up with you
it's part of the system
nature doesn't approve a [ __ ] like this
nature doesn't approve with [ __ ]
uh being bad all the time eventually
people will get you
that goes even to the even to the uh to
the to the primate kingdom well [ __ ]
bites you in the ass yeah
so
the legal professions and everything are
just basically more like uh
uh they're kind of overco in some ways
they're kind of just officializing what
happens in nature anyway
that's that's my two cents on the whole
thing
they're just making money off of it
making sure that it's okay like a double
check you know
so let's talk about they're wrong too
though let's talk about
lisa hayden johnson now if you're from
the uk
you probably know this woman
because this woman
was allegedly supposedly the mother of
the illest child
in britain
so i kind of feel like like i said if
you saw the movie run this is kind of
like this kind of situation i don't know
if this was what this was based on i
think it was based on another case
but this is kind of similar so what this
woman did she had a son
uh who in the uk press if you're a minor
um and you didn't like commit a crime
because this kid didn't um they don't
release your name to the press so i'm
not entirely sure what this kid's name
was
but the mom
what she would do she told
everybody and she told the son also
uh that he had uh an intolerance to
sunlight
she told him that he couldn't walk uh
you know and had him in a wheelchair
and said that he had like all kind of
problems like he had to be fed through a
tube um so she's like he had all these
kind of problems she would even do [ __ ]
like she would send him to school in the
wheelchair obviously because she told
him he couldn't walk and she put like
this really like super bright green like
yellow green and yellow hat on him so
that
if like emergency services had to get to
him quickly like they could find him
because he had like this [ __ ] hat on
right
now
she goes to the presents talking about
like her
you know like i said she's talking about
her burden about like you know how many
illnesses this child has
so obviously people being you know
generally good people being well-meaning
so they gave her like a lot of donations
like she got a lot of money out of it
um and this went on for six
[ __ ]
years
uh so this woman was not only scamming
like donations off of just random people
and the public and stuff
but was also
um getting some compensation from the
state because you know she had a you
know a handicapped child so you get a
little bit of money for that so she was
kind of like getting that as well
now she would what she would do and
remember i said earlier that
a lot of times people that have this uh
disorder
will be like super super friendly and
accommodating and everything like that
as long as you're going along with their
[ __ ] but the second that you
question them or challenge them they get
really defensive and go full karen on
your ass
that's essentially what happened with
this kind of woman she had like that
kind of personality
so
you know she would um you know she would
take the kid
to the hospital for whatever treatment
and they'd be like look we can't find
xyz like that you're saying is wrong
with this kid and then she would get
like all indignant about it and be like
oh well i'm gonna sue you and i'm gonna
do this and the other and she would like
have a [ __ ] flip out about it and she
would like go other places
so she did this like for she ran this
scam for like [ __ ]
six years uh she also told the doctors
too that she was a qualified nurse which
she wasn't
and um she's like i know what's best for
my child i know what's wrong with him
blahdy blah
and again would threaten them with legal
action if they questioned her
now what ended up happening in this case
this is [ __ ] up so what ended up
happening with this case and like i said
if you're from the uk you might have
heard of this lady because i'm you know
i from what i understand she was like
pretty famous
uh what ended up happening was that the
cops when they started looking into the
case they found a video
of
the sun
and they were on vacation like on a
cruise ship
and he was running around like in a
bathing suit and like he was like
swimming and he was like
and he was like eating all this like
fattening food and stuff like that even
though one she said that he couldn't
walk and was you know about you know
wheelchair-bound and two said that he
couldn't keep solid food down um because
he would throw everything back up so
everything had to be like a liquid diet
so they found this video of him just
like running around in swim trunks like
a normal kid and eating like normal food
like a normal kid
and uh they started to get a little bit
suspicious right
so
uh
she also said this woman said
uh that she had that her kid had
i'm trying to think of like all the all
the disorders that he supposedly had she
he supposedly had diabetes
uh he supposedly had some kind of like
neurological disorder uh which was the
thing that made it so that he couldn't
walk properly
she also said he had cerebral palsy
uh she also said he had cystic fibrosis
she's really piling the [ __ ] on here uh
she also said that he had a metabolic
disorder a bunch of food allergies and
that he was a sunlight intolerant so
like i said she had like a whole kind of
litany and stuff that she was like
saying that her son had
um
and she was apparently obnoxious enough
to like get some doctors to get along to
go along with it just i don't know just
like to get her to shut up or whatever
um
she got about 20 000 pounds a year
in benefits which
that's a lot but
you know
she also kind of uh another thing that
she did though i guess that wasn't
enough for her so she actually would go
to like the press and give them this
kind of like poor me story like look at
this kid that i have and he has all
these
problems and like i said all these
people would donate money
um so she got a lot of people to pay for
her and the son to go on vacation
uh she got on tv she got to meet tony
blair
it was kind of so she was definitely
doing it for money and attention which
like i said
that would seem to preclude munchausen
syndrome because one of the things of
munchausen syndrome is that you're doing
it for reasons other than
monetary gain
but in this case this is more munchausen
by proxy
um
i don't know i kind of feel like she was
just doing it because she got off on it
but i also kind of feel like she was
doing it just like to get [ __ ] money
also
um
so
for a while like i guess the neighbors
were also kind of suspicious of her
they said they'd seen the kid like run
around in the
yard like playing soccer and stuff and
eating stuff that he supposedly wasn't
supposed to be eating because he
couldn't keep solid food down blah blah
blah
um and a couple of them reported her but
nobody really listened so
like i said it took a while like i said
it was like six years um but eventually
like doctors report it to social
services and they kind of looked into it
and found out that
likely it was all [ __ ]
uh at which point
when they this is [ __ ] up too
when they uh arrested lisa hayden
johnson for all the [ __ ] that she was
doing about her son
she tried to like kind of do a lateral
move and she was like oh i got beat up
and raped
um
and cut her own face up
to uh you know they they later
determined to make it look like she'd
been attacked so she was kind of trying
to like
i guess like i said garner more sympathy
or
you know
get get people's attention off the
allegations that she was [ __ ] her kid
up
but you know
uh apparently
they uh she kind of like backed off of
that though when the police said oh yeah
we have a suspect in custody and then
she backed because i guess she didn't
want somebody to get arrested like
when nothing had happened
now interestingly the dad of the kid was
also kinda i don't know if he was
exactly in on it
but
he was kind of in on it even though he
wasn't really like living with them at
the time but he kind of knew what was
going on like with the whole scam and
everything
because they weren't exactly keeping it
a secret that this kid actually could
really walk and like
eat whatever he wanted you know what i
mean because there was video of it so
they weren't like that secretive about
it so i guess the dad kind of knew about
it too
um she only ended up serving
three years and three months in prison
however now she now to be fair
the kid didn't die
um and the kid didn't
uh you know have any horrible like
physical
you know lingering symptoms from the
[ __ ] that she did it was mostly just hey
sit in a wheelchair and pretend
that
you have all these you know
symptoms so we can get this done the
others this is kind of more
a scammy kind of thing but you know it
comes up a lot under that case she told
him project sickness
projecting masculinity
yeah yeah you're pre-acting projecting
all right so
let's talk about blanca montano now this
is back in 2011.
so uh blanca had a five-month-old
daughter um and also had another like a
son that was a little bit older
so in 2011 february of 2011
she takes them to the university of
arizona medical center
um
because they had or you know she said
they had the flu where they were
presenting symptoms for the flu
so they do the medical tests on these
kids uh the medical tests show the kids
don't actually have the flu they
actually have
e coli
uh the boy gets treated and released uh
because he got kind of got better but
the girl got sicker and sicker
you know like i said the little girl was
only five months old she was just like a
baby
so what i had with the baby was that she
was kind of like in the hospital and
then she would get
she got treated for the bacterial
infection like i said they figured out
that it was e coli
um and then so she started to get better
but then like she would get sick again
um and ended up like developing a whole
bunch of different like bacterial
diseases
at which point like a bunch of
specialists are brought in like what the
[ __ ] is going on with this baby
so they did like a bunch of different
tests on her they did like a
laparoscopic surgery they did like um
bone marrow biopsy they did like all
kind of stuff like what the hell is
going on why does this kid have so many
bacterial infections
so doctors couldn't really find anything
that was like causing all of this or why
this would happen
so at this point the doctors are like
okay well maybe her mom
is doing this on purpose so they were
pretty on the ball they were kind of
like they couldn't figure out what it
was they're like okay well
let's see if that's what's causing it so
they set up uh hidden cameras
in the hospital room uh to monitor the
mom for five days
now
what they found when they monitored
the kid's room for five days was that
the mom would come in
and take the iv lines like and put them
in her mouth
and they'll like do like she would
adulterate them with things right and
then like put them back
into the baby damn
thank you no need for me too okay i'm
home and free to watch tom model wigs
this is not a wig modeling show i saw
these [ __ ] in there talking it is
kind of get me a pippy long stocking wig
oh that's a good one too or you know you
could always towards tim's poop and
thank you to any wig you what's your
like wendy from wendy's who also has
it's kind of similar although pippy long
stockings are kind of i don't know what
the wendy's any wig you buy me i will
wear it i'm the [ __ ] clown of this
[ __ ] show
he has no shame no
no of course not he has no
shame yeah so
so like i said so they capture this
woman
uh adulterating the kids iv lines
putting them in her mouth like putting
things in them they couldn't really see
what it was
uh she also did [ __ ] like
trying to cover up the lens of the
camera i guess she found the hidden
camera at some point she was like trying
to put cotton over it [ __ ] like that
so when they confront her about it she's
like oh that was totally uh explainable
i was just like playing with the girl's
feet or i was just like her iv lines
were tangled it was like totally fine
so at this point like the hospital
workers are like yeah okay so
they kind of meet with her she kind of
stonewalls them so then they call the
police department in tucson arizona
and uh you know it's like hey check that
out and they also called uh cps probably
really so
so cps takes custody baby
in march of 2011.
now
a strange thing though is that one of
the social workers they brought in from
cps uh that interviewed uh blanca
montano
uh alleged that blanca montano when they
were interviewing her actually said
that she was surprised nobody had called
cps before now
so
she apparently i don't know so she
apparently knew that she was like doing
something bad and she's like oh my god
it took you guys forever
to finally get around to calling cps
holy [ __ ] okay so
uh so yeah so doctors like basically cps
were like yeah um we're taking your baby
away like i said probably rightfully so
um
so they they took the kid away
and
when the kid was out of the mom's
custody like i said
uh surprisingly not surprisingly no new
bacterial uh infections developed so
they determined yeah this is probably
like the mom she was uh they found out
later what she was doing thank you david
june everyone else is handing out a
dollar i want to be included okay thank
you very much
keep them keep them flashbulbs rolling
people otherwise he'll take otherwise
he'll take his pants off i'll take my
pants off
and y'all [ __ ] be stunned
yeah
she's like yeah
well you know it's just about to [ __ ]
i'm just trying to trying to put on a
good show that's all
jenny's face
jay is doing a good job though people
well i'm trying to get through the cases
and you're just like [ __ ] being being
ridiculous no i'm not being ridiculous
i'm [ __ ] i'm i'm i'm talking to all
everybody in the crowd while you're
working yeah i'm too hot and arrogant
answer these questions i'm too hot and
arrogant to answer
they're asking me about the damn pippi
long it's so distracting i can't i can't
i can't have to talk about it i can't
[ __ ] i'm talking about dead babies
jesus christ they're answering me all
they're asking me all these damn
questions about pippi long stocking wigs
and somebody said she needed a bowl cut
wig also
they're [ __ ] with me they [ __ ] with
me yeah you can be like moe for the
three stooges
yeah thank you tila dagnabbit keep them
clothes on
see the more you threaten to take your
pants off the more people are like no
please see i got them getting i got this
i got this whole system
game got this whole system game
yeah so basically what this [ __ ] was
doing they determined later
uh because if you all remember when the
kids first got brought into the hospital
in 2011 and they said yeah they don't
have the flu they have e coli yeah you
know why that was is because she was
putting like um
poop molecules in their [ __ ]
she getting the poop molecules from from
her butthole i guess
i don't know like from you can get poop
molecules pretty much any but poop
molecules are kind of everywhere
rub the [ __ ] off your toothbrush did you
guys see
that uh that mythbusters
this is why i keep my toothbrush in a
drawer
uh there's nobody in here that would
[ __ ] [ __ ] with your toothbrush you're
talking about i wouldn't [ __ ] with your
toothbrush no that's not what i'm saying
okay
they're saying
that in a regular house that has a
bathroom with a toilet that flushes if
you leave the lid up when you flush yeah
then all the poop molecules kind of
drift out and some of them inevitably
landed i think this is fresh
it's in another room though i know but
like i said in a in a normal bathroom
where it's like so that's why they
suggest
uh you know keep your toothbrush like
keep a you know plastic cover over to
keep it in a drawer or something like
that to minimize the amount of poop
molecules that are on your toothbrush
just saying
you know there's poop molecules
everywhere you can't avoid it
but
i i just think it's funny that you're
saying where does she get poop molecules
it's like where does anybody get poop
molecules from their butt
everybody has poop molecules
farting down into the tube or something
i don't know like i don't even want it
well i kind of do want to know i admit
because i'm like messed up like that
probably getting out of the toilet
putting toilet water into it and [ __ ]
injecting it could be or yeah or she's
just like rubbing her finger like in her
butthole and then like putting it in the
[ __ ] iv
that is nasty but yeah she was doing
[ __ ] like that so basically she was like
giving her kids e coli yeah
um
yeah and she had like a bunch of
syringes in her purse they found it's
just kind of like all this kind of [ __ ]
so
when they like confronted her with it
she actually did confess she said okay
well i was making the baby sick
because
the dad took off and i wanted attention
from him like she wanted him to come
back to help her
raise the baby because he had taken off
i guess that sounds like a lie too so
well i mean i don't know it's it's hard
to say um
because he actually did take off but
there's more to it than that i don't
know it's just like like i said it's
like [ __ ] complicating she's just
trying to justify it
yeah i don't know
it's just kind of like okay so they do a
trial and it's like at the trial they're
like well basically
they're trying to prove like did she
actually introduce poop molecules into
the whole iv situation or could it be
that you know maybe the hospital workers
maybe they weren't like you know
they didn't have proper hygiene maybe
they weren't wearing gloves they didn't
wash their hands like they were supposed
to and maybe it was one of the hospital
workers that did it that was the what
the defense was trying to argue
but
[Music]
i guess the jury didn't buy it because
this chick got sentenced to
13 years in prison and that was back in
2013 13 that's it 13 years they didn't
give her for attempted murder or that
was attempted murder
uh well the baby didn't die um so it's
attempted birth and yeah i guess it was
still but i it seems like they kind of
like maybe listen to the sentence
somewhat because
i don't know like i said maybe they
introduced some reasonable doubt because
it's very possible because you can't get
infections in hospitals because like i
said you're around a lot of six people
and people that are working with sick
people and if you don't
uh observe proper hygiene protocols it's
very very easy to pass infections from
one person to another so it's like so it
was very easy for the defense to kind of
argue that it's like you know
she you know the baby could have very
easily gotten an infection from
someone other than like a hospital
worker rather than the mom even though
they did see the mom like doing some
shady [ __ ] in the room allegedly i'm
just saying
all right so let's talk about
leslie
wilfred
what
peace we got i told you before not you
but other people i'm too pretty to be
answering questions right now i got the
wig on when the wig's on i'm on pretty
mode i don't answer the question what
the [ __ ] happened to this here okay go
ahead are you all right yeah mark
you're too pretty to answer questions
i'm too pretty to answer questions here
like a girl girls are too pretty to
answer questions right
oh so i answer questions so what does
that mean no just no that's what are you
implying okay
see she said see how she flips see how
she flips [ __ ] around on me like you
said it no i'm just having fun i'm just
having fun okay i ain't talking about it
no need for me too says i brush in the
shower not just but a lot of people do
that a lot of people don't i do that i
don't but it's only because
you know we have that with just a
stand-up shower and then the sink's over
here and like i said i keep my
toothbrush in a drawer but the answer
question we got all kinds of shows about
state penitentiaries no we don't yeah we
did we had that one member brought that
[ __ ]
uh what was it cropsy it wasn't a state
penitentiary but it was like a state um
well that was like a like a psychiatric
psychiatric ward and then and that was
more like an urban legend
i have been wanting to do the answer and
then the panzeram show had a lot to do
with pet attention i have been wanting
to do a show about like the alcatraz
right yeah
but i keep putting in the pool and it
never wins
i think that would be a good show
yeah but you know what i mean we have so
many good topics we still have to do
yeah
you know right
tell me dig that hole tom [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's her she's real good at flipping
[ __ ] around on me see
she doesn't go along with it's all my
fault she doesn't go along with the
crazy [ __ ] that i do she has to [ __ ]
check it well because i don't have any
patience
it's so funny games i'm just trying to
have how many patients it's all fun and
games he tries to go off with some like
[ __ ] inflated [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm
just like
stop it
but yeah so all right so let's talk
about leslie wilfred okay so
now
okay so what happened here
apparently this is one of those
situations where everyone thought this
is like you know your nice normal family
you know that's that's never the case
but okay
so they get married like uh leslie
wolfer and her husband uh chris
got married in 2007.
now leslie already had four kids from
her previous marriage chris had uh one
kid a son from his own marriage
now 2008
uh leslie
supposedly
became uh pregnant with twins
now
like i said this is one of the
situations where oh they're so normal
it's like oh the show acted in school in
the church and blah blah blah i was
gonna watch people like that man now to
see you don't get to watch all of them
because most of them are probably like
normal but
i don't know i i kind of feel like every
time like you know a btk situation
happens oh my god he was such a nice guy
he was like getting into the church and
he had a family and blah blah it doesn't
mean [ __ ] it doesn't mean anything
so you know and a lot of times they
don't know the dude anybody can be a
[ __ ] psycho so you know a lot of
times when they go to those cases they
don't make assumptions they actually
don't know the dude
they just saw him there
you know yeah it's very it's very easy
to like project kind of like a normal
facade if nobody knows you just keep
seeing they don't know the dude
yeah
the only dude that knew him was his
friend
yeah remember that and his friend
forgave him
remember that [ __ ]
he goes i don't care about
dennis you're still my friend
do you remember that guy
of all the things to like drop a friend
about i kind of feel like being a serial
killer be way up there on the list no no
no yeah we're not friends go back into
the raider case no i know i know i had a
friend
and he's like everybody's talking bad
about dennis
[ __ ] he did a lot of good for the
community he was a good guy he had a
problem
and [ __ ] everybody's [ __ ] running
from him now
you know but this is a problem he
couldn't have controlled blah blah blah
and he's telling the news that and he's
like [ __ ] and he's like dennis i'm
still gonna write to you in prison
[ __ ] you know you're you know i'm
still your friend yeah i remember that
yeah remember that he's like he's like
these people are turning on you but
[ __ ] i know you know he was like you
know
i know you had a problem and [ __ ]
that wasn't you type of deal you know
it still was though
and like i said of all the reasons to
turn on somebody seems like being a
serial killer is probably like probably
number one but they would immediately
hang out and [ __ ] talk about stuff
and [ __ ] talk about you know he was
what was funny is that um
he was a similar personality type as
raider you know what i mean like you
could tell they would be drinking
buddies well you know well you know well
whatever you know you know there's like
sharon serial killer no uh i don't think
they did that
they were the kind of person like oh you
know today you know the [ __ ] you know
the way everything's going it's terrible
it's all [ __ ] up yeah they were just
kind of like those kind of guys
um
i don't know it's just
somebody might be in the comment section
might drop drop that dude's name but he
hit his interview was quite interesting
the dynamic between a serial killer and
a non-serial killer
he blew off all the psychology [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's just like
yeah he had a serious sexual problem
but it was uh that and he was killing
people
but that's not who he really was that's
how that guy rationalized it
that's not who he really was he had some
kind of mental problem but he's still my
friend i'm standing next i'm standing
with him
he was a good man who had something
wrong with him
and that was how he rationalized it
i don't believe that but that's how he
rationalized it because like i said it's
very high
interesting very interesting it is i
mean i can go with that up to a point
but uh that person being a serial killer
is way beyond that point way beyond i
was fascinated i was very fascinated
that that was his take on it and that
was evidently his best friend
he knew him the best
he didn't know about the killings but he
evidently knew him the best he said he
knew him better than his wife knew him
probably true yeah
um
and he stood by dennis didn't seem like
a person that would open up to a woman
because i don't think he even though i
do think i mean he didn't kill his wife
he did really seem to have affection for
his wife to the extent that he could
have affection yeah and his family um
his family is a window dressing i think
mostly yeah i don't really think that he
could feel any deep
he wants love or empathy or anything
toward anyone particularly not a woman
so i really don't think well i don't
think that's what it was i don't want
him to be normal and to be normal in his
mind you had to have a wife and a family
so he did he had to do but what but and
and i think he did care about them as
much as he could
but that's
that's not who he really was
he was a serial killer
yeah and and
i mean honestly to that thing i kind of
feel like
i don't know if this is cut some kind of
because i've thought about this a lot
actually because i kind of i read a lot
about serial killers and i'm kind of
interested in that kind of psychology
to what extent
is there
a real you
and a fake you right because i do kind
of feel like people still have this
leftover
i feel like this is maybe like um
a leftover from like maybe i don't know
the light better even earlier where
people have like a real them there's
like this core like a little popcorn
kernel like down there but like all of
this is like other [ __ ] yeah um societal
stuff and i kind of feel like people
still have that perception of there's
like a dichotomy there's like a real you
and then there's like a you that you
like
to others
and i don't know if that's the case
though the japanese the japanese and
other eastern societies call it the
public face
right and then and i think that people
still have this yeah there's a certain
amount in the western there you know
there's a real me but then there's like
the me that i project to other people i
don't know if that's as clear-cut as we
think it is if we had a bunch of money
though
i think it would be [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
to make him make a movie
about dennis and his friend
i bet you that'd be a badass movie
well it's interesting it's interesting
because they made something that was
dahmer like that my friend dahmer yeah
well yeah that was like a fictional
movie yeah fictional movie but you do
the [ __ ] real
about this dude and his friend
[ __ ] you know what i mean uh what
[ __ ] what's his name [ __ ] slipped out
of my [ __ ] mind um
what am i talking about raider
dennis raider yeah
[ __ ] um i would love to see my friend
raider my friend dennis
or something like that from
that dude's [ __ ] words
from from although you have to be okay
so another thing too is that
if
let's just say okay so we know dennis
raider's a serial killer and we know
that he was very good at
um projecting a certain
uh facade for people
so to what extent
did this friend know the real him
if he if dennis raider's whole persona
was not the real him because the real
him was a [ __ ] cereal he claimed that
he knew him better than his wife that he
knew him better yeah but that's a
subjective yeah
i would kind of opinion i would kind of
kind of agree with that that maybe uh
two guys could probably exchange
information that yeah the wife wouldn't
know about so he probably did in a
certain way but on the other hand you
know what it was like i think how
superficial maybe that's what i'm saying
that well that's exactly what i was just
gonna say it's like how deep was this
friendship between these two dudes
probably not that and you know and i
don't know this dude personally but
dennis raider from what i know was very
secretive and very he was very
interested in like projecting
so
the fact that he was like close friends
with this dude that doesn't mean the
same thing as it would mean if somebody
that wasn't a serial killer and they
like actually like opened themselves up
and was like vulnerable to someone else
and was like had a deep friendship with
somebody i don't think he had a deep
friendship with anybody because he was
hiding too much let me may explain a
little bit i'm a mass player oh goody
you ready
[Laughter]
friendship let me brace myself brace
yourself
um
friendship between men is very different
between friendship between between well
that's kind of what i'm getting at
that's what i'm getting at and
friendship between men has more to do
with the exchange of information
well that's what i mean it's more based
on
an activity you're doing right but the
thing is for some reason you know i'm a
man you know what i mean for some reason
i get more into the exchange of
information than the emotional exchange
of [ __ ] feelings
i do that
but
but there's something real kind of
men kind of bond over [ __ ] trading
information and things that they know
about or they're talking and and it's
silly [ __ ]
it's like
talking about the development of world
war ii aircraft engines yeah i know that
was the best race car that's what that's
exactly what i was getting at is that a
dude that says he was the best friend of
a serial killer i'm like what does that
mean though because you were just like
hanging out fishing here's the thing
here's the [ __ ] thing that you're
missing for us that's deep there's some
kind but that's not
though well that's from your your
opinion because during that time there's
some kind of a weird
emotional bonding during all that
because it's just a different way of
doing it
you know i mean it and i think some of
the guys will [ __ ] chime in they go
yeah it is weird it is it's men's
biology is different
and they might get more deep over
trading
information or talking about stories and
it might be something like video games
or engines or
something mechanical and then there's
like some kind of a relationship about
that it's
now women wouldn't appreciate that they
wouldn't not that well that's not real
well i appreciate it between men it's
like it is real it's a different way of
looking at things no the what i'm trying
to get at i don't i don't and i don't
really think that if you're like i don't
i don't think that you're getting this
no i am not getting it yeah men you know
no no i'm just saying i'm not i'm not
sure if you'll like understand what i'm
saying right yeah
that's exactly what i'm saying is
because men's friendships are like that
they're very different um i don't think
that somebody that who was a dude that
hung out with a serial killer that said
oh i was his best friend or whatever i
don't think that would necessarily mean
the same thing
as
someone that was
you know say like two women that were
like best friends or
married couple that were like kind of
like i said somebody that was in a
relationship that was more based on
being emotionally vulnerable to that
other person and like telling them a
bunch of well no that that's what i'm
saying is that because they don't have
an uh a relationship like that
um
you wouldn't necessarily it wouldn't be
the same as right you know being best
friends with a serial killer like if i
found out my female best friend was a
serial killer holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that
would be like i would be like floored
because
me as a woman like a lot of my friends
we tell each other like all kind of [ __ ]
that like probably like two dude friends
wouldn't tell each other yeah friendship
between men isn't isn't that's what i'm
saying so yeah that's what i'm saying
one isn't less than the other no i
didn't say that i didn't say that i just
said it was different and i just said in
the context of being a best friend with
a serial killer which is what we were
talking about um
i wouldn't put the same weight
on a dude that was best friends with a
serial killer dude because that
friendship is probably not the same
as the relationship between you know for
example two women best friends
or no i didn't say that or i just said
it was different or
like uh you know a man and wife type of
relationship where the whole
relationship is based around being
emotionally vulnerable
that's not meaningful for us that much
but that's not right but see that's what
i mean you're not you're not getting
that that's not what i'm saying i'm not
getting it that's not what i'm saying
for me i don't know i don't get it for
for men actually
uh friendships the exchange of
information and is kind of like that's
our version of nurture in a way because
we're trading things that are helpful
between each other so there is kind of a
but there is kind of like a zen there is
a different vibe like
you know uh he he
we're aligned to each other we're in the
same
clique uh this is an allegiance you know
we're helping each other it's very
different with women
very friendship between women or amanda
it's very different
but it's it's biology i think
that that's the only way i can describe
it maybe somebody in the in the
comments section it's gonna talk about
but see the friendship is very different
between men but yeah but
that's exactly what i'm saying though
i don't think that you're like getting
like you're just repeating like yeah i
i'm acknowledging that yeah but
that's not germane to like what i'm
saying because i'm saying that in the
context of for example being best
friends with a serial killer yeah i'm
just saying that maybe if the serial
killer was a man because i know they're
all not like some of them are women um
being a serial killer who and your best
friend is a man and having that best
friend say oh i didn't know or i just
forgive him or something like that that
doesn't have necessarily the same impact
as someone who was in
like i said like a spouse relationship
with that serial killer or someone who
you know if the serial killer was a
woman and like their best friend was a
woman that might be like a different
dynamic no one's saying it's better or
nobody's saying i'm acknowledging that
it's different and that's kind of the
point that i'm making and i don't
yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying i'm saying
the same [ __ ] the same [ __ ] but you're
just like making my point for me but
you're like arguing with me you know i
didn't mean it that way if that's just
the way i heard it because some of these
dudes who are at that level will fight
to defend each other and they've done it
by not telling on each other that's
happened in some of the cases that we're
talking about that's probably what we're
talk that's probably that same
phenomenon of he's got a problem you
know but he's my friend
you know what i mean
it's it's just a weird thing i mean you
have women who love dudes who are
[ __ ] criminals in the most part
[ __ ] up
you know they have women that love dudes
that are criminals who are killing women
and it's that same thing or they're or
likely that show we saw last night they
love this dude but he's [ __ ] planning
to rob the damn casino you know what i
mean it's the same although being a
serial killer and being a bank robber
those are two different dynamics like i
don't i'm not saying don't get involved
with like dudes that do heists and [ __ ]
because that's also [ __ ] up and she
that ended up biting her in the ass but
well not really because she didn't get
caught she turned herself in yeah but i
was on the run but she lived on the run
for years and it's not worth it yeah but
they did it on her identification
boy she should have saw that coming
yeah but i'm just saying that's kind of
like a different dynamic she was v she
was very young he was much older uh i
think she liked the romanticism of like
oh we're on the lam it's like bonnie and
clyde i think she was like into that
because she was kind of immature like i
you know i get that they didn't kill
anybody
uh so you know i get that
but you know we want all this money and
we're gonna go like live on the lamb
it'll be like [ __ ] like she had like an
idealistic like romantic yeah conception
you see graham says right it says i have
very few true bros in my life but we
tell each other everything but even then
we leave certain things out yeah of
course because i bet dennis raider was a
riot to hang out with lots of church
talk and how to measure yeah
i kind of feel like he would be like
annoying as [ __ ] that question for tom
how many true brothers does he have and
would he admit
uh would he admit to them he was a
serial killer
hypothetically that's a good question
actually um
uh well [ __ ] there's some of them from
high school
at least there's at least two from my
high school period and then there's
probably about
five or six of them from the army period
but then once you get to a certain age
you start you stop making friends like
that you might have noticed that too
when you're out of your 20s you no
longer need ma male friends at that
level well i've heard that like a lot of
people i and i've heard this complaint i
don't have this problem but a lot of
people um once they're out of college so
it's very hard to make friends they
don't really want to hang out with
people they work with which i get
because i don't really want to do that
either but it's like um
we don't really have the same kind of
thing because like i said we're in the
god scene we still go out um so we know
a lot of people that are you know around
there so we still hang out with a lot of
those people so i never really had a
problem like making friends like later
on but i but in general i do know that
that's kind of because you're not like
hanging around with people every day
that are into this i know what he's
asking me
i know he's asking me
if i were a serial killer
could i tell any of them which you
better not be no because that will
happen i will knock you around
if i was a serial killer could i tell
any of them and i would say yeah but it
would only be one and you know who it is
i could tell steve steve wouldn't
[ __ ] rat on me he would [ __ ] try
to get me help he says man you can't do
that
but um no i could probably tell you
obviously no but there's just certain
things but that that never
of course that that's never a threat
because
i'm not a serial killer you know what i
mean now could i [ __ ] a [ __ ] up
can i gun somebody down can i do
something in the line of [ __ ] action
hell yeah it was my job same as yours
same as yours it's the same
it's just that we were protecting two
different systems with the two different
mentalities of two different training
philosophies
um did i like my job yeah i miss it i
miss it that's who that's that's that
was the mentality i was formed in but
there's other things that i enjoy too
so you i can distract myself away from
that you know
but uh no man [ __ ]
can i just say right now like if you
legit told me seriously that you were a
serial killer yeah i would poison you
[Laughter]
and i'm like not even kidding about that
well i don't show any of the signs of
the serial killers that's why you're
[ __ ] even talking that way because i
can
that's not true serial killers are
sexual
deviants they're they're it's a sexually
motivated murder
they have a bunch of sexual hang-ups
it is their sexual orientation
most of them can't live for very long
it's rare that one of them can have a
successful relationship raider was one
of the few most of them can't do that
and i'm pretty convinced that his family
did not know yeah
they didn't seem to he was a very rare
one well i mean like i said you have to
think too in the context of the time
yeah um you know dad
went off to work and he was just kind of
like distant you didn't really get too
much because i kind of feel like that
serial killers and maybe this is why you
don't see as much nowadays too like
among many other reasons is i kind of
feel like particularly in the 50s
through maybe like the
mid 70s i kind of feel like it was
normal
for
the dad of the family to be kind of like
a little bit removed from the rest of
the family they weren't like sharing
their feelings they weren't
you know they were just being like very
superficially involved uh you know with
family members and [ __ ] like that so i
kind of feel like they could get away
with that kind of [ __ ] and no one would
really question it all that much but you
know the deal granters bro
in the defense of in the defense of
[ __ ] the unit or family friends and
the self i will [ __ ] lay you out like
[ __ ] bacon i will [ __ ] fry you up
i don't have any [ __ ]
problem with that
but to kill someone
for a sexual thrill to waste some
perfectly good woman over some [ __ ] like
that no [ __ ] no
that's [ __ ] right there that's
that's that's the that's the activities
of a serial rapist
and a [ __ ]
some kind of [ __ ] freakazoid that's a
nobody
you know what i mean it's just sex isn't
like that
sex isn't that important
why the [ __ ] would you do that man you
will go to [ __ ] prison or be killed
and then you have yeah like was it worth
it then you'd have to [ __ ] live with
that [ __ ] afterwards what the [ __ ] yeah
that's some kind of [ __ ] weird sex
like there's millions of people out
there that you could potentially have
sex and enjoy yourself with right yeah
um you really don't like don't have sex
with a million people though no
i'm just saying that it's like you know
the potential is there and there's
always the if you need what you need it
that bad well first of all they're not
doing it for sex that is never [ __ ]
in the equation when you talk to these
dudes where you hear them talk it's not
about the sex
[ __ ] um it's about emotion and all
kinds of weird [ __ ] [ __ ] that's going
through their heads
but no
dude they got a whole they got whole
armies of professional women ready to
serve
if you have the [ __ ] if you have
money you don't need to [ __ ] kill
anybody over that also bro just buy a
sex doll yeah okay
seriously
if you're gonna be in the [ __ ] if
you're gonna be that way yeah yeah it's
like we have the internet now yeah um
you can see anything you want to see you
can buy a sex doll that looks almost
like a real person yeah um you know so
just like just do that it was never that
though that's not what syria killing was
about when you go back and talk to those
it was never that it was weird mental
problems power
hatred and it was it wasn't really about
the sex yeah i don't i i kind of feel
like that's another thing well it's just
you know and and a lot of people have
said this too it's like rape is not
about sex it's about power you're you're
you want power power you want dominance
over someone is what you want hatred and
stuff yeah
um so let's see so where was i so can i
get back to my [ __ ] well now it's like
it took so long that now i have to go to
the bathroom
look at like you do i'm gonna do what i
want to do with the [ __ ] show do you
have somebody to talk do you have
something to talk about yeah yeah he
stole my brush i just got that today i'm
btk
tom raider is all gay tom porno i don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
bro
i don't know what they're talking about
i'm talking about eating cold ham chat
heat eating cold ham sandwich
yeah shrimp tacos yes from tacos are
good
[ __ ] crap just go [ __ ] i'll give
steve you're calling out you'll be
callings and that's [ __ ] funny
now steve was over here [ __ ] um i
guess about a year ago need to see his
ass again
steve's doing good he just gave birth to
i think two kids
got married a young wife got brand new
[ __ ] kids and [ __ ] and he's [ __ ]
he's an old guy he's our age
got a young wife and everything
victor's saying i already put the show
on time time out and then david goes and
says don't punish the show bro
i don't know why he's putting the show
on timeout
victor's mad because i put his ass on
timeout
but i put a bunch of people on timeout
i'm gonna do that sometimes you know
what i mean i'll put a [ __ ] on timeout
start acting crazy
and then i'm just talking and then david
tom what console do you play want to
send you a game i actually got x the new
xbox xbox one
he has an xbox i got xbox one i like
xbox one i just got the new um alien uh
isolation having problems there going
through that one yeah give him a hair
alien isolation
i bought a big package of damn batman
games i'm only part of the way through
the very first one that i think it's
like arkham asylum and all that [ __ ]
those are all right but there's getting
kind of stale all that [ __ ] jumping
up on the top of the [ __ ] gargoyles
and [ __ ]
they get kind of repetitive you know um
but um alien and alien isolation is
really good it's kind of like a horror
horror survival game
so far it's been pretty good
wait
oh may i you can go and then hold on i'm
gonna go yeah well get me another drink
okay
all right my shit's empty okay
can i please get back to my cases
[Laughter]
do what you want to do and then you like
talk some dogs okay so he's gone so
we're talking about uh leslie wilfred
that's where i was all right so again
this is where we went off the rails
because i said this looked like a normal
family right so uh leslie and her
husband chris they get married in 2007.
she had four kids from a prior marriage
he had a son uh from a marriage uh prior
now uh shortly after they got married um
allegedly uh leslie became pregnant with
twins
now as i said they were very active in
the church and like the school and
everything like that like everybody said
oh they seem like the perfect family
like all their kids were super well
behaved blah blah now
they did um because they were pretty
active in like the school and the church
and everything like so a lot of people
in the community did know that two of
their kids
supposedly uh had really serious health
issues because you know what the show is
about you know where this is going but
supposedly like two of the kids had
really serious health issues
so leslie had a 13 year old son whose
name was charles now charles again
allegedly needed a new
liver uh you know
so
it got to a point where
the stepdad chris was actually going to
donate
wait he was going to donate his liver
i'm still like donate part of his
leverage you can't donate your liver
you've only got one uh so i don't know
what the deal was there but i'm just
saying that's like what my note said
he's gonna donate his liver
so charles who was 13 had already had
his gallbladder removed uh a few years
prior to this because uh he had been
like he had chronic vomiting like he was
throwing up all the time so
i you know i guess he had his
gallbladder removed
in hindsight probably unnecessarily but
you know
uh she also had a nine-year-old daughter
named teresa
who was supposedly dying from
leukemia now uh because everyone in the
community kind of knew about this
all the like convenience stores and like
[ __ ] like that in town had like those
little you know he has little cans in
the front where it's like hey this kid
in town is like dying of this that and
the others like please put some money in
here uh yeah so
her
daughter had that like there were all
this candle over people would put money
in
um
now there was also a thing where chris's
son because like i said he had one son
from a prior marriage also his name was
nathan and he supposedly
had you didn't bring me another drink oh
i forgot
maybe i had to let the cats in and do
all kinds of stuff now
he had to do all kinds he had to do like
two things
so
he had to do two things and he got
confused all right so
yeah so this son nathan supposedly had
mental health issues so severe that his
parents thought he was
dangerous
like he had like some kind of violent
psychosis or some kind of [ __ ] like that
uh and that he was like attacking the
family
uh they didn't
you know uh you know other people didn't
ever see him around like he wasn't
really allowed out of the house and like
this kind of [ __ ]
now
apparently what happened when this
family kind of came to the attention of
authorities it happened in fall of 2008
the cops get called out to the wilfred's
household
after nathan the you know chris's son
supposedly
threatened the whole family with a knife
because like i said he was supposedly
some violent uh you know he had some
violent kind of psychosis and was like
dangerous and whatnot
so
because this was a minor
and they were
supposedly
threatening the family with violence
as a standard procedure in these cases
cps is brought in
cps comes in
um and they over the next few months
they kind of like have several meetings
uh with the parents about nathan and
about like what the issue could be
now during these appointments though uh
people that worked for cps noticed that
the mom leslie
um
was acting a little weird like enough so
that they kind of noticed it
and they're like um
they noticed that she made several
statements
saying that nathan
uh was
going to
uh was responsible for like the
well-being of her twins who hadn't been
born yet um you know she or he was a
danger to them
whatever
um
so the people from cps started to think
this was a little
strange a couple weeks after this
incident when the police were brought in
leslie calls her family from the
hospital and says
unbeknownst to anyone
i gave birth to these twins who were
only five months old at the time and
they're both dead
um a few days after that in november of
2008
there was this big [ __ ] funeral
service in town because like i said
these this family was kind of like
active in the church and the school and
everything like that so all these people
came out and all people had like donated
because they supposedly had a couple
kids that had like leukemia and had
other problems so a bunch of people came
just like oh my god like you had twins
they were like early and then they died
and it's so sad
so they have this [ __ ] whole funeral
service right at the church like that
the family went to
um there were even like these two urns
that were shaped like teddy bears
they had like framed ultrasound pictures
like next to the urns and everything
like that
they even like even leslie had written
this poem
that was supposed this is like kind of
creepy
not gonna lie um she read a poem that
was supposedly from the point of view of
these two unborn children
uh called a letter to our daddy which
like i said damn it's a little [ __ ] up
um
so at this point like i said the cps had
kind of been involved because of the
nathan situation and some of them
thought that like the mom was a little
fishy
so
they started looking into the [ __ ] a
little bit further
uh and once these twins were stillborn
they were like yeah we need to like
further investigate this so the this
employee of cps like called the
sheriff's department
and you know one office the sheriff's
department like looks further into the
matter
at which point they determine that
leslie
had not only had twins uh you know not
only not had twins that had were
stillborn but had never been pregnant in
the first place damn
she had pretended that she was pregnant
for five months then had this big
treasure thing big tragic thing about
looks oh the babies died she even went
online
and bought
two teddy bear-shaped urns
uh and had a [ __ ] funeral service
there's nothing in the urns there's
nothing in there she wasn't she wasn't
pregnant
um
so she had this whole [ __ ] theater
going on about the [ __ ] [ __ ] and it
turned out later they found out that in
fact uh she you know she had some four
kids of her own she actually could not
get pregnant because she had had her
tubes tied prior to her getting married
which her husband chris did not know
so this whole thing was like a [ __ ]
farce right
so as the cops uh you know that was
obviously a giant red flag so the cops
like look farther into the [ __ ] they
find out that her 13 year old son
charles actually uh his liver was fine
and he didn't need a liver transplant uh
even you know at all and also um
they also thought that maybe even though
they couldn't prove this they suspected
that uh charles's mom had actually maybe
been poisoning him which was what was
causing his symptoms
stop stop it pokey
um
and the thing about it like i said the
kid's gallbladder had been removed um
and apparently
she had had to go to like a bunch of
doctors before she would find one that
was that would actually do that you know
what i mean like she had to like bully
somebody into doing it because a lot of
doctors were like yeah we don't think
there's anything wrong with them so
there's uh that whole kind of thing and
then obviously they found out later on
the daughter teresa also did not have
leukemia
uh and had not been going to the
hospital for chemo uh it was all again
like theater
holy crap poop
what the hell no
she's like she's being so bad yeah she's
being so bad
uh so yeah so they found out all of that
um and then
okay so remember the thing about nathan
who was chris's son
and he was the one that they said oh
he's a danger to the family and like
he's gonna stab us and they would that
was the one like the police got called
on yeah okay well they found out that
nathan
had actually they had been forcing him
to sleep in a two by two foot box
every night they would put him in a box
to sleep and they put like plastic bands
around his arms to keep him from like
moving around
so they were essentially like keeping
him in a [ __ ]
stomach
what is the matter with him to go in
there
you know she wants to go back let her go
in the closet she wants to go outside
come on let her go in the closet it's
too late to go outside
it's almost 10.
okay
let her go in the closet
yeah so nathan this kid who was
supposedly this violent psychopath
they were actually like tying up this
kid's arms and putting him in a two
fight two by two foot box and making him
sleep in there
um and their story was oh well
um if we don't do that like he'll bust
out and like [ __ ] jason voorhees our
ass or some [ __ ] like that like they
came up with some [ __ ] like that
so
uh you know so they take the kid away
and they do like some psychiatric
evaluation on the kid and they're like
um unsurprisingly the only thing the
matter with this kid is [ __ ] ptsd
because he's been sleeping in a [ __ ]
box yeah there's nothing else wrong with
him he's fine yeah so you know uh so
like i said this this woman
had exhibited symptoms uh early on of
munchausen syndrome in that she claimed
illness for herself that was something
that she did and then once she had kids
later she kind of like fobbed it off on
them
uh as well so uh you know so there was
that whole thing uh she did have a they
she was diagnosed with a personality
disorder uh they think it was probably
borderline personality disorder or
narcissistic personality disorder um
so they sent her to court uh and she
pleaded guilty uh including uh two a
bunch of charges including a bunch of
accounts of cruelty to children and she
actually got sentenced to eight years
in prison and 30 years of probation uh
her husband was also charged with one
count of cruelty to children because he
knew about the whole of putting nathan
in the box situation and that was his
biological child uh the children were
thankfully all taken away and put in
foster care
um and none of the and the parents are
not permitted to contact any of their
children uh going forward so you know
like i said not great that they're put
with strangers but better than the
[ __ ] parents that they had obviously
uh so let's talk about uh next case i
guess this will probably be the last one
because we're already going like four
hours
so like four hours well that's what
happens when you
like on something
she played with me she's playing me
i'm blaming you because it's your fault
you're just like going off i was just
like [ __ ] for four hours okay
yeah you weren't talking for four hours
but you kept going off on like things
and like distracting me from you right
from the you guys you guys see how it is
yeah okay
[Laughter]
omri vampire says i have a theory that
tom is possessed by man because man said
i could yeah because man that's why he's
been mansplaining to you jen
dude he always transplants that's all he
knows how to do it
that's all he knows how to do it
all right so let's talk about uh
what
that's all i know how to do yeah damn
it's true
um
that's like just how he talks it's it's
it's mansplained language look it's it's
a whole
this is i know you don't
yeah okay see again yeah that's how it
goes this is just yeah yeah you see so i
i just roll my eyes and just kind of
don't listen keep on keeping on
you know so let's talk about uh hope
ibarra
now uh
again this is a woman that started out
uh displaying symptoms of manchester
syndrome like towards herself in the
beginning and then later when she had
children like manifested against her
kids as well
because one thing that she did
maybe even before she had kids
was that she claimed that she had cancer
and that she'd relapse like two or three
times
um and her big thing was like yo you
guys i'm dying
and she said she'd already picked out
her burial plot and she'd already picked
out her coffin
um you know so it was like a whole thing
and again much like that [ __ ] we were
talking about earlier with the mommy
blogger uh this woman also had a blog
where she was like detailing her
experiences uh with cancer and how she
was picking out the casket and
everything which like i said if you know
if you really have cancer and you're
really dying and you need to like blog
to like get your feelings out about that
okay fine but it's like
keep in mind there's probably like a
small percentage of people that are just
like making [ __ ] up and this woman was
one of those people
so yeah so she has this whole blog where
she's talking about dying and then she's
like writing like sorrowful letters to
her three kids but i will after i'm gone
and all this other kind of stuff
um you know what i mean uh she also said
that her youngest kid uh also had a
terminal disease so you know there was
that whole thing she's spreading the
[ __ ] around
now hope had uh like i said she had
three kids she had her second kid in
1999
and
this kid she told everybody uh including
her husband uh all her family her
friends and stuff like that that the kid
who was her second kid like i said had
cerebral palsy
and actually had like the leg braces and
she put the the little girl uh in leg
braces
but um
when her third kid was born in 2004
somehow magically
um the cerebral palsy that her second
kid had uh somehow like magically
disappeared i guess because she was like
fobbing more like putting more attention
on the third kid
now the third kid was actually born
uh prematurely
and
i'm not sure like i don't know if that
like contributed because you know it
does seem like from everything that i've
seen that her third kid was actually
born prematurely it wasn't like all made
up or anything
so you know there are some health issues
associated with that so it might have
just been like she took that little
kernel of like oh there's these little
health issues this little tiny kid you
know born charlie and i'm just gonna
like build this whole edifice of
[ __ ] on top of it i don't know
but so
so so what hope said was like this kid
oh she has all these medical issues like
from the time she was born um
she did have cystic fibrosis like she's
like she has cystic fibrosis like she
ended up being like a poster for that
[ __ ] and everything
um
and it does seem like there was some
obviously there's some kind of like
pathological thing but
hope ibarra was apparently not above
like making money off the [ __ ] because
she did actually kind of go public and
say look she has cystic fibrosis and i'm
trying to like i can't afford the
medical bills and i'm really trying to
like
raise money for it so she had a bunch of
fundraisers and ended up like garnering
about a hundred thousand dollars
um so
this kid
went through four years
of various tests procedures surgeries
uh various things for cystic fibrosis
and um
they later found out the kid probably
didn't even have that
she didn't have that
um so hope ibarra gets arrested in
october of 2009
um after everybody like wised up to what
the [ __ ] she was doing
um
now
i was gonna say to her credit but i
don't want to give her any credit
hopefully eventually admitted
uh yeah that she had been abusing her
daughter
uh and she was like she even admitted to
like altering tests
um because she apparently like knew
again like these people have a lot of
like medical knowledge people that have
this disorder
so they know how to like fake
symptoms they know like what symptoms
doctors are looking for so they know how
to like um generate that they're reading
books yeah so that's kind of yeah either
they're in nursing or they're if there
are doctors themselves or they just like
read extensively on the internet so they
kind of like know
uh what symptoms to present like to get
the uh diagnosis that they're looking
for so she wanted her daughter to have
cystic fibrosis so she basically knew
like how she would have to
uh you know finagle the test to make it
look like that so that's what she did
um and she did eventually admit to doing
that
she also said that she had stolen
pathogens from where she worked because
i assumed she was also in the healthcare
field
and made her daughter sick with those
um she also would drain blood from her
daughter
um which
might have triggered some particular
symptoms uh her daughter going into
anaphylactic shock uh for example
uh and then later after all this came
out they also found out that all the
[ __ ] that hope ibarra herself was saying
uh you know earlier like when before the
kids were born
about her having cancer of you know i'm
in my third
you know it's a gun to remission like
for the third time or whatever i'm dying
i'm picking out a cancer yeah or i'm
picking out a coffin they were like yeah
they found out that yeah she never
really had a cancer either she had also
made up some other [ __ ] like oh she had
a phd
um she also pretended to be pregnant
with twins at some point uh just like
that last one so that seems to be a
fairly common thing uh she also faked a
miscarriage she also held a fake funeral
uh for the dead babies uh just like the
last woman which weird um i get it but
it's still weird um
and uh she also maybe uh infected a
couple of her co-workers with the
pathogens that she saw from the lab so
there was also that
so uh she got uh
she went to trial in october of 2010 and
she pled guilty
she actually ended up getting sentenced
to 10 years
um
she did admit to some of the [ __ ] but
she was also kind of like downplaying
some of it as well um she was kind of
like yeah i knew the girl wasn't that
sick but i knew she was kind of sick and
so i was trying to get her help so i was
like exaggerating she did kind of like
say that
um
but they have noted that even while
she's been in prison
she's still kind of up to the old
shenanigans uh she says
oh i get diabetic comas and i have
memory loss and it's like and i have
hearing impairment
um and all this other kind of stuff so
she's i don't know so she's still kind
of
making stories up i kind of feel like
um so
you know allegedly while she was in
prison so now she was actually like i
said she was uh sentenced to 10 years
uh so she did get out
in uh
2018 or 2019. i think she got it in 2019
or 2020.
um i haven't seen much of her since she
got out however
there is a youtube channel
and i was thinking this i saw this
earlier and i was like oh my god there's
a youtube channel for [ __ ] everything
right
everything is on the internet there's a
youtube channel
called munch house and moms
okay
there's a whole youtube channel called
that
and they had an interview with hope
ibarra from this month
so she's been out of jail
i think she's been out of jail about a
year maybe more at this point because
like i said she served her son she was
only sentenced to 10 years um you know
her her kids didn't die
which thankfully um but she still like
put them through
horrible [ __ ] [ __ ] that they
didn't have to go through
and she's like i said got her own
problem saying like oh i have cancer and
i'm dying and all this other kind of
crap but at least she didn't kill
anybody but so they did still sentence
her to 10 years but she did do her time
and she's out uh so
i didn't really watch most of the
interview because i'm just kind of like
i don't know if i could sit through this
or not because like i don't know it's
just gonna make me mad but
i'm just saying she served her time so
i'm not gonna like [ __ ] on her too much
but seriously i hope she got some
[ __ ] help because this isn't [ __ ]
up [ __ ] man like i said i don't know why
i keep like associating it with i guess
because
um you know i don't i don't see a lot of
shows about munch house and syndrome
although i kind of feel like
that's kind of like a
in in the past few years
since 2018 2019 i feel like there's been
a lot of like true crime shows um you
know like investigation discovery and
stuff like that that have come out about
women that have that because i feel like
a lot of people are fascinated by that
uh
diagnosis yeah um
but
i feel like it's still pretty
misunderstood but like i said i kind of
feel like i'm associating it weirdly
with
hoarders because we watch a lot of
hoarders and even though the the two
things aren't associated
you
can still see that pathological you can
see the still pathological because like
i said i watch hoarders and like i said
my grandfather was a hoarder i
understand it's a pathology i understand
they can't help it like i understand
if you have a factitious disorder
against yourself a you know factitious
disorder where you're like abusing
children i understand that's a pathology
so to a certain degree you can't help it
because a lot of it is subconscious you
don't realize
fully what you're doing i get it but it
still makes me really angry because
you're still affecting
other people
and not
realizing i don't know it's just like it
makes me really mad
yeah so this kind of like i mean
obviously hoarders that's not like to
the same degree because they're not
they're usually only hurting themselves
directly although they're indirectly
psychologically hurting their whole
entire families
but
this is like way worse because like i
said it's a you know it in in cases of
munch housing center by proxy it's it's
child abuse is what it is
um and in a lot of cases like i said
very rightfully so cps cps have taken
their children away
um which they should
because the thing about it is that even
though they can't help it like
you know intent isn't magic you're
affecting somebody else you're affecting
a child
who
doesn't understand that you have
something to matter with your brain
um so
they really should not be cared for by a
person like that
you know what i'm saying yep so you know
getting that um
yeah no need for me too said kids in
that environment can to get neglected
even if there isn't any active abuse
yeah and like
like i said it's all a matter of degree
because i've seen some episodes of
hoarders where
um
you know where the person
you know was hoarding and they
absolutely did have children that were
living in that house and animals too a
lot of them have like dogs and cats and
stuff which is also like not forgivable
you bringing your kids up in that in an
environment like that
that's gonna [ __ ] your kids up like
forever so that's still again a form of
child abuse even if you're not beating
the [ __ ] out of your kids even if you're
not injecting your children with fecal
matter like some of these people are
doing um
it's still it's
it's the same kind of thing it's just
not to the same degree i guess
so
i don't know so maybe that's why i'm
associating those two things i don't
know uh no need for me too says i lived
with a few yeah like i said my
grandfather was a hoarder i didn't
i grew up there off and on because like
i said
we were growing up like sometimes we
lived in my grandfather's house and we
kind of moved around a lot um
the thing about it was that his house
he they had he had like a big house
and my grandmother lived there for a
time like when i was a kid like into the
70s and when she lived there it was all
you know she kept it clean
after she left
um
he kind of like fell apart he couldn't
keep his [ __ ] together and uh everything
just
went to
[ __ ]
uh and he just hoarded ever so like
there was [ __ ] everywhere um it
wasn't it wasn't like a you know i'm
pooping in a bag type of situation it
wasn't like that because you know we've
talked about that uh before but he liked
to
collect stuff cars camera equipment
jewelry you thought he could come
computers yeah it's like i feel like
they're
the thing about it and i see this more
with like male hoarders than women
hoarders although it's kind of like the
same pathology but male hoarders are
more like i see potential in this
i could although women do too i guess
because they're kind of like oh i could
buy this and it's like i could make
something with it
i could this could be useful in some way
right people didn't want these this yeah
money right and so i kind of feel like
it's sort of the same thing but you kind
of see this the thing with men where
it's kind of like
you know i'm gonna like buy this like
shitty car i'm gonna fix it up and i'm
gonna sell it i'm gonna make all this
money i'm gonna like get this com get
these computer parts i'm gonna like
build a computer and sell it so i kind
of feel like that my grandfather had a
little bit of that like going on so he
always had like electronics it was
always like cars boats electronics
[ __ ] like that and it was just kind of
like
it wasn't um his house was like gross
but they don't i mean they don't really
clean to any great extent so
it kind of gets to a point where there
was rats
um there was massive [ __ ] spiders it
was roaches it was a kind of stuff he
did keep the upstairs kind of clean
because
he um you know
uh you know our aunts and uncles like we
lived up there for a little while like
he would rent out
or like let relatives live up there if
they needed to for a time
so he kind of kept that clean
but what ended up happening though was
that after a time
the place got so bad and then
embry riddle university which is you
know right down the street and they had
like a bunch of frat houses in on that
street and they bought that property and
they tore that house down which is sad
because that was a cool house
um but they tore it down and they put a
frat house there and then he moved to
another house on the beach side and in a
very short time how long did he live
there two years three years maybe and he
completely filled it up and he
completely filled it up to a point where
when we went in there after he died
because he died kind of suddenly like of
a brain hemorrhage and we went in there
after
and
it was so filled up with stuff the
stairs had uh collapsed
so you couldn't actually and he they had
collapsed and he didn't tell anybody and
he was going upstairs but he put like a
series of buckets
so he could like walk
up to the second floor
we didn't know and then like we went in
there and like my my poor mom and like
all her siblings were stuck having to
like clean out
this house i mean i think they did
eventually like
clean it out and somebody bought it so
they did they were actually able to
clean it out to some extent but his old
house
um was so
[ __ ] up that they had to tear it down
so
which which happens a lot on hoarders
too because you put all that crap in
your house
you know
roof's going to fall in floor is going
to fall in
mold's going to grow
all that rat feces and stuff like that
you know
it's just not going to
you're just going to have to tear it
down salt the earth start over
[Laughter]
what are you talking about oh no she was
saying this we were talking about
[ __ ] one of mouse's dresses she
couldn't find it it was like a [ __ ]
white
mardi gras
outfit with a little eye little mask a
little eye mask she can't find it
it's in the instagram folder
i tried to share it but i couldn't share
it because i couldn't get a link
well probably because other people's
photos are like right
you can't like share them with others
she's looking at it because that would
be weird if you could do that right
it's kind of like a it's kind of like a
french
dress
really
and it's all white with [ __ ] like
little white
like demonia
i bought one like i bought one like that
to wear with my bride of frankenstein
right outfit i haven't worn it again
though though i don't look good in white
it kind of had it kind of had that new
orleans kind of
you know what i mean voodoo kind of look
it was cool
but um but you can't see it is there
anything else on this subject
should we go ahead and shut it no like i
said i had one more case which is duty
blanchard but i'm pretty sure we talked
about that on the sidetrack show and
that's a pretty well known case anyway
yeah and since we've already been going
for like four hours or 15 minutes
then probably we should like wrap it up
like i said there's i don't remember
when we did it but we did a side track
show and i'm pretty sure we talked about
the dd blancher yes which is totally
[ __ ] up because there was whole like
somebody got murdered on that [ __ ]
you know like yeah not the way that you
think
yeah for continuous it sounds beautiful
but i can't see it through the bit
you'll you'll see it if you keep going
through it but now yeah that [ __ ]
that that's an awesome dress
all those girls have [ __ ] awesome
dresses jenny's got all kinds of [ __ ]
awesome dresses and [ __ ] just depends on
what event
that they're gonna go to
yeah because i kind of feel like
unless i'm doing something i mean i like
getting dressed up
but sometimes
sometimes it depends on the event i'm
just kind of like man i really don't
want to like [ __ ] she's even got
japanese stuff she's got yakuta's and
stuff like that we she has one of those
um it's just you know
but
for uh for a black girl the damn
new orleans [ __ ] voodoo or haitian
[ __ ] it looks
there's a lot of [ __ ] you can put a
lot of spin on that in the gothic
uh scene
it looks really good yeah yeah you can
get away with a lot in your [ __ ] it's
gotta be right
you know
i like to have let like i said if
there's gonna be like an event or if
it's gonna be like a theme event
um i like to have at least like three or
four hours to get ready in the photo
you'll see her she's up on top of a box
in a club in that white outfit dancing
and [ __ ] it's taking it probably at her
feet level
you'll see it
tila said also i went on that voltaire
youtube channel because i was talking
about that on wednesday yeah and his
halloween shows are fine yeah he he's
like a pretty cool dude yeah he's all
right uh his music is cool like i said i
really need to go because i saw him on i
didn't realize that he had a whole
uh you know home decoration
youtube channel until i saw him on jade
the libra and they were doing halloween
you know decor shopping and i was like
oh [ __ ] i should go check that i mean i
should have known because he had like
old books talking about that
um i should have known that he'd like
parlayed that into like a youtube
channel cause you know i admitted that
[ __ ] so yeah i'll go check that out but
yeah he seems like a nice dude i'm just
saying
um yeah danny rowling ghostface says
yeah the gypsy rose case has to do with
uh
munchausen syndrome where the daughter
and her boyfriend murdered the mother
for treating her like as she was sick
all the time and honestly i have to say
like i said i you know i i did have this
lined up but it's been going a long time
and i think we talked about on the side
track show anyway so i don't really
repeat it
but i will say i know that gypsy rose
got some time
for
essentially hiring her boyfriend to kill
her mom but her mom
had been
um
telling her that she was crippled and
uh mentally challenged and she like that
like her whole entire life
uh not really letting her go outside not
letting her have her own internet they
had a shared facebook for [ __ ] sake um
you know
so it was that kind of situation so i'm
not saying like
like the mom deserved to be murdered
but
i find that i cannot blame her i can't
blame her
because she had been abused for like so
many years
and then finally she was just like [ __ ]
this i just can't take it anymore um so
i can't really blame her and honestly
she
she did get some time but not
that much all right t this is the photo
i was telling you about this is a survey
can see it
you can find it
okay
no need for me too says ever thought of
doing a collab with another channel i
have thought about it but
i don't know every time i think about it
i'm like god that sounds like so much
trouble yeah
we've been guests on other channels we
have been on a bunch of other people's
shows i've been on a bunch of other
people's shows uh matter of fact i gotta
do
sunday i'm recording i don't know when
it's going to be up but sunday i'm
recording a like a panel show
uh which is going to be all about
handmaid's tale which like i said which
is why i've been watching it i'm almost
like i'm more than halfway through
season four so i'm trying to finish it
before sunday um so i'm doing that
september 4th
i'm also recording
another show
about
i don't even know what it's about but
it's about just like whatever my
projects are at the time so we're going
to like talk about true crime and all
that kind of crap um
yeah it's honestly we've had i don't
know like we've had like guests on the
show and stuff like that and it's like
cool but
i don't know it feels like every time
it's like this big giant
pain
i just it's like techn like there's
always like technical issues
um and when it comes time to like edit
it or whatever it's just like this big
giant i don't know maybe it's better now
but
it just always seems like such a pain
and it always seems like so daunting
like whenever i wanted to i've been
there done that such a pain
it is it's like
it just always seems like a huge pain in
the ass it's like
it seems so like easy nowadays because
we just have everything set up it's like
we just come in here i push the button
and we just start talking and it's just
like it's fun but
every time i like try to think of it i'm
like oh god do i really have to like
[ __ ] louis says she he likes it when
you're on the conspiracy conspira normal
podcast
well the reason they're
because conspiring normal we've done
that show like so many times and that
show is like super fun yeah they're fun
we've done that show you guys so many
crazy questions and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
it's good and and they know more about
the our show than we know
yeah because
those guys like adam sane and those guys
are like they're like bigger like way
bigger fans they're like super fans
um
so
it's funny because it's one of those
things i kind of feel like now we're in
a position sometimes you know how like
actors that were in like some friday the
13th movie like 30 years ago and they go
to a horror convention and you get like
all these nerds like me like coming back
to oh my god how did it feel like doing
like [ __ ] that was like 30 years ago i
don't remember anything that happened
like 30 years ago it's kind of like that
but it's like now he'll like ask me
about something that happened on a show
like that we did like six months ago i'm
like i don't did we do a show about that
i don't even remember it's like we do so
much
we we do so much content we do so many
movies we do so many books we do so many
topics
i have to check every single time um
with movies with books with everything
did i do this already
because i can't remember yeah i legit
can't remember at this point we've done
so much stuff that i legit can't
remember if we've already done it or not
so i always have to do like a search
isn't that sad
that's so [ __ ] sad
i was doing the other day when i was
doing the review which i just put up
yesterday i think of um under the shadow
that um iranian
uh movie by babaka and bari
i put that up and i was like uh babak
and vari also directed wounds
the movie that came out in 2019 and i
was like i could have [ __ ] sworn
i knew that i had reviewed the book i
remembered that because i remember
somebody said oh that's from a book and
like you know i got that i reviewed the
book i remember that because it was a
short story collection but i could have
[ __ ] sworn that we had done the movie
too because i watched the movie and i
remembered that
but we hadn't done the movie and i was
like really did we really not review
that movie i could have sworn that we
[ __ ] reviewed that movie but i guess
we did it
because i couldn't find it now lenore
thomas johnson says oh my god i catch
you live finally
we've never seen you here before lenoir
even though you've been well because
she's never caught us live before yeah
i've never seen you here i mean
we're not in our best uh state right now
because it's like we
we've been drinking for
more than four hours yeah i know at this
stage
spooky stop it
stop it you cannot dig through books and
pookie is really really wow pook yeah do
you know what time it is
she doesn't care she's like i don't care
what time it is you know what time it is
no my hair is coming off you know better
my hair is coming off
pookie it is 10 18 p.m
there you go she's
don't do that i hit her with the hair
and she ran out after 10 p.m she's not
allowed to go outside yeah
but and she knows that but she still
tries
she's been really a brat tonight yeah
why are you being crazy
she's back come up here pope yeah come
here
say hi to everybody be on the show be on
the show hey
hi sweet pea
hey
what's up she's hiding
what's up
what are you doing poop
you have fine
not really not really she's like no no
she's like i don't know what he is i
don't like this okay
poor pokey
you've been outside yeah i've been
outside oh yeah
she's so abused goodness
i just i don't know she's so spoiled
because drinking is awesome yeah
we we didn't go we didn't want to go out
tonight we spent so much money the past
couple months
taylor says does pookie like catnip yeah
oh my gosh oh yeah
honestly okay i have to tell you guys we
have these things called minties it's
the [ __ ] weirdest thing i get them
from chewy.com yeah they're these little
what are they're like a little it's
they're soft it's a little bar of
[ __ ] a little bar of materials little
leaves green beans on either side
they're made out of it's mint not catnip
right man but god damn it loves it she
loves she'll grab him with a single paw
with her claws and rub him on her face
and she'll be on her back rubbing that
[ __ ] on her face going
beijing does it too yeah
i have a bunch of them she can't stand
it minties she was doing it last night
yeah you have to get a new one like
every few months or so because i guess
the smell goes away yeah but
i bought like several of them i think
they're like two bucks each or something
i get them off i've never seen a cat
pick something up with one claw with one
paw like that and rub it she's like
she starts fighting it and rubbing her
face with it she does that like for ages
yeah
roll it around on her back
so for some reason it's like she loves
those more than catnip because we have
the catnip spray she likes those too she
likes that too yeah we have like the
catnip sprinkle yeah like you can
sprinkle it on the rug or whatever yeah
they like that they like to roll around
on it but those minty toys man holy [ __ ]
i don't know like you know all cats are
different but
pookie loves them
beijing also loves them yeah because
i've caught beijing beijing is like
she's older
so
she doesn't i kind of feel like she
feels like it's undignified for people
to see her like
acting all
you know whatever
so
so if you catch her like doing some [ __ ]
like rubbing that thing all over her
face she's kind of like
yeah she's gets embarrassed she gets
embarrassed about it yeah but i've seen
her doing it too yeah see if they if
your boys like catnip get them get them
the little mint just see what happens
there's like mint things yeah it's like
um it's chewy.com and it comes they come
on like a little card i think they're
2.99 and it's like a little bar
and it has like little mint leaves on
the end and it has keep like a dog bone
kind of a little bit it's made out of
made out of material like a broth that
man our cats [ __ ] love those yeah
they're like a girl they will just like
they're just like oh i can't stand them
they just rub it all over their faces
they can't tell and just roll around and
roll around it's like [ __ ] healthy it
seems to be
harder on them than catnip
seems to be like it's like just being
coke and crack
they can't take it yeah
oh my god
yeah danny rowling says that's the cool
thing about casting it high on kitty
weed yeah if unlike dogs yeah it's like
giving them catnip is just like so
[ __ ] [ __ ] funny yeah we have that
we have the temptations catnip too they
eat that also
but um they do like catnip spray catnip
and just real catnip but
they actually [ __ ] act the funniest
with [ __ ] with those little mints
yeah
and like i said i don't know if all cats
react like that but
yeah but our two counts pookie
especially like [ __ ] loves those
little minty things and i bought so many
of them like over because every now and
then like every
five or six months like when the smell
goes out like i'll buy another one like
i'll buy another couple and like throw
them out he just saved that website to
her favorites yeah [ __ ] um
what are you doing poke
yeah chewy
and chewy.com delivers real fast
yeah like usually like the next day
yeah you can get temptations and [ __ ] i
bought a ton of [ __ ] from them i like
chewie but like um yeah esther is
talking about temptations has catnip
trees yeah we have those we bought
all different uh flavors yeah i buy them
in bulk actually because
there's honestly something called
temptations t if you give her something
called temptations
they won't eat anything else after that
they hardly will eat cat food after that
they want those honestly like we have
like [ __ ] tons of like wet food yeah um
cookie will eat like a bite or two of
wet food yeah but she doesn't really
care about it she doesn't really care
about dry food she just wants [ __ ]
temptation temptations yeah
um
any flavor i don't know what the [ __ ]
they put in there crack
but
honestly it's just like so we've taken
to i'm like look
to get her to eat yeah you kind of gotta
like leave her a bunch of like a big
handful of like treats yeah temptations
and grainies she eats greenies too yeah
she likes greenies also
temptations i feel like she likes the
chicken ones the best although they eat
them all the cookout flavor is good like
with the red
i think that's like liver
the catnip ones
salmon remember there was like a milk
flavor yeah that was like the purple one
they kind of like those but they kind of
get sick of them outright they eat
anything they eat all anything that says
temptation but like i said i don't
really know and honestly she's got to a
point now where it's like she knows the
sound of the box so it's kind of like
yeah and if her little bowl because we
have a little bowl in the room that has
like little treats in it
if there's not enough uh treats on it
she will like start knocking into the
box like so it'll make a note it's like
who won't eat human food i tried to give
her to try no she wasn't she what do you
do
the only thing she ever showed interest
in was parmesan cheese yeah same with
beige she like parmesan because it's
steak stinks stinky parmesan cheese you
like that
she likes whipped cream whipped cream
yeah that's um she likes to like if
you're eating something she kind of like
sticks her face and like what are you
eating but then she's like nah yeah she
doesn't care about beijing also does not
care about human food yeah but
for whatever reason if you're eating
like a couple times we were eating like
something like like peach cobbler or
something like that or strawberry
shortcake
something like that that had whipped
cream on it
and for whatever reason pookie is really
interested in that she's like how much
like what you got what you got and then
like tom's like hey it's whipped cream
and she's like oh okay and she would
lick that
normally though she doesn't like
she's not interested in human food at
all and beijing isn't either i know some
kids i know some cats are but neither of
our cats are interested in human food
um they mostly just want treats to be
honest with you
they don't give a [ __ ] because most of
the time we have like a bunch of
different you know you go to sam's and
you get like those big boxes of like
different like a variety of different
wet foods
um and
we've tried a bunch of different ones
they seem to like some of them but not
most of them you're kind of like you put
a spoonful of it out and they're just
like they smell it and they're just like
nah yeah not feeling it yeah they'll
lick it a little bit and like nah nah
and then they leave yeah so
i don't know i don't know what they want
it's probably about time to shut it down
yeah you think yeah
tila says my older boy likes spinach and
kale which is odd it's really healthy i
had i used to have a cat that was really
into do you remember like those little
debbie donut sticks
for whatever reason my cat loved those
and potato chips
but i don't i don't know uh thank you
david june tom say hi to my roommate is
btk threaten him okay
you gotta you gotta do that
you have to understand so
here we go
i've known david for a long time now
and um i keep hearing that he's got a
guy with him living him with him as a
roommate
and it
it's okay you know
you can be david's roommate but you
don't want to get on his bad side
he might call me and i might come down
there and measure your grass
[Laughter]
or kill your dog if i'm gonna measure
your grass it it's gonna have to be the
the proper height and what is the proper
height dennis
two and three quarter inches okay fair
enough that's the s that's the state of
that that that's that's the the state of
florida this is two and three quarter
inches at all times
that seemed a little long yeah
that big
that big
that's considered same size as my wien
[Laughter]
yeah you got two before i could it's the
wing
[Laughter]
do you take the wean out and like
measure it next to it so i got it
memorized
a whole lifetime oh my god how [ __ ]
funny would that be if you looked out
the window and saw a dude like you came
out of the van and like just like took
his life
whole life time is stroking you know
my lifetime is stroking i get that three
quarter inches yeah you have like some
muscle memory like a large [ __ ]
the girls are all laughing not as fun as
a [ __ ] i guarantee
all right let's go let's go really ghost
faces i should pretend
that i'm btk's daughter carrie
oh my god i'm not gonna do that
[Laughter]
i just want to say [ __ ] you guys
i'm gonna laugh at a man's small ween
and
[Laughter]
you know okay well i mean to be fair
dennis it wasn't just your small wing
yeah that is the whole gestalt of what
we're laughing yeah yeah so
you know what i'm saying he's laughing
[Laughter]
all right i understand tila yeah you're
laughing at these little white boys i i
understand i understand
being all
spoiled and [ __ ] stole that bbc
[Laughter]
you're gonna you're gonna have to
understand you know that
come on man i can't go this down this
direction really i can't go down this
direction now you can't are you not
man has to compensate you know
well
you torture your kill we all know how we
all know about the compensation yeah
oh my god
man we got to eat i know [ __ ] you
keep wanting to do the show guys shut it
down she's going i haven't had that in a
while she hadn't had the bbc oh that's
where i forgot oh yeah i forgot you were
you you married a white boy yeah okay so
you go ahead go ahead with your little
wayne then
[Laughter]
so you acknowledge that white boys have
little wings yeah yeah according
according to
courtney everything everything's a
matter of perspective
[Laughter]
sure yeah depending on what you're
comparing it to depends on what you
compare it to yeah are you comparing it
to like some big [ __ ] like you know
you know that big like [ __ ]
tube of beef you get it sam yeah yeah if
you're comparing it to that yeah
baseball yeah pretty small competitors
are the best of the best
comparing it to how you're long your
grasses yeah that's what you're doing
but yeah so
oh my god
all right
uh hopefully this has been kind of an
informative show she's got that
bwc see yeah the big white [ __ ] okay
yeah it's out there you know look
it's out there just like out there in
the wild somewhere in the ocean you know
you never know what could happen you
know well sure there's like a great
white there's all kind of mythical
beasts it's a great white it's all kind
of mythical beasts
on the ocean
sea monsters and whatnot we don't we
don't know if they exist or not it's
like bigfoot
well they know what i mean i got video
videos
do they also have video evidence of big
white [ __ ] i feel like yeah yeah yeah
dude sure
fake it's fake
no it's not fake i'm just kidding it's
nothing i'm just kidding
the wild world of porn has everything
it does pretty much danny rolly
ghostface says i bet when dennis was
teaching the scouts how to tie knots he
probably slipped up and said nobody can
escape this yeah it's like yeah i kind
of i i always kind of like
i think like a black comedy about that
because i kind of feel like i know it's
[ __ ] up but
i kind of feel like that maybe they were
thinking about that all right so
hopefully this has been an entertaining
and sort of
mildly informative show she's going
don't just say it jenny she's trying to
get you to say that i got a little dick
you don't though yeah
[Laughter]
don't say it i know i know how everybody
wants me to say yeah
that's that's not the case no that's not
the case
i'll pull this [ __ ] out
well everything it wouldn't win a blue
ribbon but i'd probably get a second
place
probably
all right [ __ ] them okay i'm glad that
you have realistic expectations
it might make it a red ribbon
[Laughter]
which one's a red second place is it
second yeah
i don't remember i think everybody has
their own like [ __ ] parameters horses
it's this [ __ ] blue red ribbon in the
second place
yeah i guess so yeah and then like
what's the third one like white or
silver and i forgot
i camera
i think i kind of feel like it was
probably white yeah yeah
all right so hopefully like i said it's
been entertaining informative blah blah
uh we'll be back on sunday
i don't know we might either talk about
the dennis nilsson [ __ ] because i got
some thoughts
about that documentary um
which is on netflix or maybe
since we might not go out tomorrow night
because i don't know if i can take it
this weekend we might watch some movies
tomorrow
i don't know so i don't know what we're
gonna talk about sunday it'll be a
surprise
to everybody and to us because we don't
know
but hopefully everybody enjoyed their
time with us
how am i still like talking i don't know
been talking all night how am i still
talking i don't know
and i'm still kind of like mostly
coherent hopefully
even though yeah sandra didn't show up
tonight
oh i'm gonna have a spank that [ __ ]
next time i see her
well that's gonna be her next name
sandra who will be spanking next time
you see it yeah that'll be it that's one
of my regular shoes because she says all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] to keep me rolling
lenore thomas says not enough alcohol
well
there is a point where it is enough
alcohol yeah
it gets
i've gotten to that point many times
yeah yeah they're going to wrap it up
jen shut the [ __ ] down look they're
telling you just shut the [ __ ] down dude
let's go we're almost there for five
hours jenny [ __ ] shut up i'm so
hungry all i've had was a ham and cheese
sandwich today i know we're on a diet
and alcohol i'm getting trying to get
lean up in this [ __ ]
oh
well okay oh
my clothes came off okay sort of go
ahead okay yeah
your clothes came off no no no no what
did you think i said no no
what do you think what'd you think of it
but yeah so i i definitely eat something
before i go to sleep because i'm super
hard but i'm super hungry i had a ham
and cheese sandwich and that was
seven hours ago something like that
i haven't been eating all that much
but yeah so come back sunday
we'll talk about a movie probably but we
don't know what it is yet uh thank you
everybody for coming by thanks for super
chats all of that fun stuff uh thanks
for hanging out with us on a friday
night we have enjoyed our time with you
i'm so glad we had this time together
you stopped picking it up on it all
right so we'll see you guys on sunday
afternoon thanks for dropping by we'll
see you next time
bye